BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
GOAL IS. I'VE BEEN OUT OVER A
WE'VE ALREADY FOR PARTICIPATE
IN TODAY'S HEARING OPEN HER BIG
EVERYONE. WELL ALLOWING THE
BACK TO. OUR PANEL ALL OF THE
ON. YOUR REMOTELY ONLINE.
BECAUSE THERE WEREN'T PEOPLE
TAKEN INTO HEARING LIKE WE HAVE
SOME WE HAVE ALL OUR MEMBERS
PRESENT STYLISH. YEAH ORD. GOOD
AND WE THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY SUB
COMMITTEE ONE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
READ SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. ALL
OF OUR PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA
ARE APPEARING REMOTELY USING
ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. THERE WILL
BE VOTES TAKEN IN TODAY'S
HEARING AFTER WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE. THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND ALSO
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
THE NUMBER IS TOLL FREE.
1-877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
TAKEN ON THE FIRST NINETEEN
ITEMS IN PART A OF THE AGENDA.
INCLUDING THE NON PRESENTATION
ITEMS ITEMS ELEVEN THROUGH
NINETEEN AT THE END OF THE
HEARING UPON CONCLUSION OF
PANEL TEN. ISSUES TWENTY THREE
SIXTY THREE OF PART A AND ALL
OF THE ISSUES IN PART B. OF THE
AGENDA OUR VOTE ONLY ITEMS FOR
WHICH THERE WILL BE NO
DISCUSSION ON AND ON WHICH WE
WILL BE VOTING. AND WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT WE
ESTABLISH CORE. ARAMBULA HERE
FRAZIER MATHIS PATTERSON RAMOS
RUBIO HERE WOOD YOUR- WE WILL
BEGIN WITH ONE ACTION. TO
APPROVE OF THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION ON ITEMS TWENTY
THROUGH SIXTY THREE IN PART A
OF THE AGENDA. CAN THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARAMBULA I FRAZIER MATHIS
PATTERSON RAMOS. RUBIO RIGHT
WOOD ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO PART B. OF
THE AGENDA FIRST WE WILL TAKE
AN ACTION IN SUPPORT OF THE
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IN THE
AGENDA FOR ALL ITEMS IN PART B.
EXCLUDING ITEMS NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT AND THIRTY THREE DO I
HAVE A MOTION. TO MOVE. WOULD
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BELA I
FRAZIER. MATHIS PATTERSON RAMOS
RUBIO FIVE WOOD. NEXT WE WILL
GO ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT OF PART B. DO I HAVE A
MOTION IN SUPPORT OF THE
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION ON ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT. SO DO WE
HAVE A SECOND. THANK WHAT THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ARAMBULA HI FRAZIER. MATHIS
PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO I WOULD.
FINALLY WE WILL GO TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY THREE OF PART B.
DO I HAVE A MOTION TO SUPPORT
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION ON
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE OF
PART B. THANK. CAN WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA HI
FRAZIER. HOME HI MATHIS
PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO WOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WITH THAT LET'S BEGIN
WITH PANEL ONE ON THE STAFF
WISHING THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION FOR THE PANELISTS
WHO ARE PRESENTERS PLEASE
PRESENT IN THE ORDER THAT YOUR
NAME APPEARS ON THE AGENDA
THERE ARE THREE PRESENTERS ON
THIS PANEL MONICA MORALES AND
TERRY SOUP KANALI DOLLMAN BOTH
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND TOBY EWING WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. WE WILL HOLD ALL
MEMBERS QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER
THE PRESENTERS HAVE CONCLUDED
LET'S BEGIN WITH MONICA MORALIS.
I GET AFTERNOON THANK YOU-
CHAIRMAN MONICA MORALES FOR THE
RECORD WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. I'M JUST REALLY
WANTED TO TAKE SOME TIME TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE AND BE THE
HIGHLIGHT- YOU KNOW OUR NEED TO
MOVE. A THE OPPOSITE SUICIDE
PREVENTION. IN JANUARY AS YOU
RECALL A NEW LAW A. B. TWELVE.
ON TWENTY ONE TWELVE EXCUSE ME
BECAME EFFECTIVE THAT ALLOWS
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TO ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION. AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. ALL
OF THE ROLE THAT CDPH WOULD
PLAY IS REALLY TRYING TO ALIGN
A LOT OF OUR EFFORTS AROUND
SINCE A CONVENTION ACROSS THE
STATE STARTED BY PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. WILL BE
TRYING TO CONDUCT- STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENTS BOTH REGIONALLY AS
WELL AS IN CERTAIN- COMMUNITIES
OF SUICIDE PREVENTION OLICIES
AND PRACTICES. AND REALLY
TRYING TO MONITOR AND TRACK ON
THAT- DISSEMINATION OF
INFORMATION REALLY TARGETING
SOME OF OUR PREVENTION EFFORTS
BOTH AT THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL INCONVENIENT EXPERTS THAT
REALLY CAN TARGET SOME OF OUR
MOST- IMPACTED POPULATIONS.
SUCH AS YOUTH NATIVE AMERICANS
AND SENIORS FOR EXAMPLE OUR
BALL REALLY IS TO THINK AS WE
PRESENTED AND SUBMITTED THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTER OF WAYS
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THE VISION
THAT THE COMMISSION HAD FOR THE
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION.
THE PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU IS
THERE PROCREATION OF SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
OF FOR FY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
NINE POINT TO REALLY SUPPORT
THE STAFFING OF FIVE FIFTIES TO
BE EXACT TO. ADMINISTER. THE
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION.
NOW WE BEEN MEETING WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. TO REALLY ALSO
NOT THIS NOW BUT HISTORICALLY
IN SOME OF OUR WORK THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING WITH THEM. TO REALLY
THINK THROUGH YOU KNOW HOW WE
CAN THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WHAT OTHER DEPARTMENTS
ARE DOING IN CALIFORNIA AND
INCLUDING OURSELVES. I'M WE
KNOW THAT THE- TRANSFER SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND STRIVING FOR
ZERO REALLY OUTLINED SOME OF
HIS KEY ACTIVITIES WE DON'T
FEEL THAT THERE IS- ANY
REDUNDANCIES WHAT WE DO WANT TO
CONTINUE TO HIGHLIGHT IS. YOU
KNOW THE COMMISSION FOR EXAMPLE
RECEIVED TWO MILLION TO REALLY
START THINKING ABOUT DOING SOME
STRATEGIC PLANNING WITH AND
BUILDING COALITIONS REALLY
LOOKING AT A RESEARCH AGENDA
THAT GOES BEYOND JUST DATA
SURVEILLANCE. AND SO WE PLAN TO
CONTINUE TO- THOSE EFFORTS AND
BY MEETING WITH THEM BUT ALSO
WE DON'T SEE THAT THERE IS
OVERLAP IN THE WORK THAT WE
WOULD BE DOING IN THE OFFICE OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION SINCE. SOME
OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT THEY'RE
DOING WILL CONCLUDE BY JUNE.
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WE REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
SUICIDE IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED. UP BY MULTIPLE
ENTITIES ITS SYSTEMATIC AND THE
MORE FOLKS THAT WE HAVE AT THE
TABLE TO COORDINATE REALLY
HELPED ELEVATE YOU KNOW THE
WORK TAKING PLACE- IN SUICIDE
PREVENTION IN CALIFORNIA. I
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE A
PLAN TO GET TO MEET WITH THE
KIND. TO FURTHER DEFINE WHAT'S
IN THE PLAN WHAT IS OUR ROLE IN
THE PREVENTION BROWN AND WHAT'S
REALLY IN THE ROLE THAT THEY'RE
DOING AND THEN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL. SO WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL
HELP FILL A GAP THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF THE
CORONATION. I'M IN WITH THE
PARTNERING WITH OFFICE OF
SUICIDE AND- TO KIND OF MOVE
THAT FORWARD ACROSS OUR SYSTEM
IS GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT. SOME OF OUR KEY KIND
OF START UP ACTIVITIES FOR US-
IF THIS MOVES FORWARD. IS
REALLY CONTINUING TO MEET OUR
MORE CONSISTENCY WITH
CONSISTENT WITH THE COMMISSION
REALLY THINKING ABOUT
DEVELOPING OUR IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN. FOR THE FIRST LIKE SHORT.
TERM BUT ALSO THE LONG TERM.
BRINGING IN OUR STAFF WE WOULD
DEFINITELY YOU KNOW IT'S A NEW
INITIATIVE FOR US WILL HAVE TO
HIRE KIND OF STARTING FROM
SCRATCH. SO THAT WILL BE A BIG
PRIORITY AND THEN IMMEDIATELY
THINKING ABOUT COMPETING IN THE
AN ADVISORY GROUP THAT CAN
REALLY HELP. GUIDE SOME OF
THESE EFFORTS I'M AND THEN
FINDING OF THINKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW. IN IRAN JANUARY. TO AND
THIS AND THIRD OR GENERATING TO
ABOUT SOME OF THE DATA ELEMENTS
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT
WE HAVE TO PUT IN PLACE. SO
WITH THAT I CAN POLICY NOW AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS. THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
FOR US THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM TERRY SU CANALE.
DALMAN ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT A MONICA AS HER
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
WONDERFUL NEXT WE WILL MOVE ON
TO BE DEALING WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- AS YOU KNOW THIS HAS
BEEN. SEVERAL YEARS IN THE
MAKING THIS SUBCOMMITTEE PLAYED
A VERY ESSENTIAL LEADERSHIP
ROLE IN HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED
TO REINVEST AROUND SUICIDE
PREVENTION IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A AN UPDATED STRATEGIC PLAN.
AND THE COMMISSION HAS BEEN-
VERY THANKFUL FOR THE SUPPORT
AND PARTNERSHIP OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS
WITH WORKS TO TRY TO MAKE THIS
REALITY I ALSO WANT TO- THINGS
NUMBER RAMOS FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
IN CALLING FOR THIS OFFICE
CONSISTENT WITH THE WORK THAT
WE HAVE DONE. ARE WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PLAN WE ARE
NOT CONCERNED ABOUT THE CASE IN
OUR OVERLAP. ALTHOUGH WE HAVE
NOT HAD A CHANCE TO HAVE A HIGH
LEVEL CONVERSATION WITH THE NEW
LEADERSHIP CDPH RECOGNIZING.
THAT THAT KOBE HAS REALLY TAKEN
UP MOST OF. THEIR TIME AT
SHOULD BE- WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT WE WOULD ASK YOU
TO CONSIDER. IN PARTICULARLY
ELEVATING THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION IN THE GRAND SCHEME
OF THE OVERALL HIGHER KEY AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ALL LAY OUT WHY. OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS CALIFORNIA WILL
BE. IMPLEMENTING A SHIP TO NINE
A DATE FOR MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
AND SUICIDE PREVENTION BASED ON
NEW FEDERAL GUIDANCE AND
FEDERAL LAW. WE'RE WORKING TO
BRING THE CRISIS NOW MODEL TO
CALIFORNIA WHICH WILL HAVE A
NEXUS TO THE NINE EIGHT EIGHT
SYSTEM. AND THOSE TWO THINGS
NEED TO BE CONNECTED TO OUR
SISTER PREVENTION EFFORTS
SIMILARLY THERE ARE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND ENHANCING MOBILE CRISIS.
WE HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS
INVESTMENTS AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO MORE IN TERMS OF
BUILDING OUT OUR SCHOOLMENTAL
HEALTH STRATEGIES AND SCHOOLS
ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE SAYS THAT
PREVENTION PLANS. B. THE
LEADERSHIP CHALLENGE THAT THE
COMMISSION SEES IN TERMS OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION INCLUDES
ENGAGING WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IT IT INCLUDES
CREATING AN INTEGRATED STRATEGY
THAT BRINGS OUT THE BEST OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES MANAGED CARE. STRUCK
ME THE PULP THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH YEAH THE SURGEON
GENERAL- WE ASK AND WE HOPE THE
MENTAL HEALTH COMMISSION. THAT
HIGH LEVEL LEADERSHIP. REALLY
NEEDS TO BE SOMETHING IN THE
RANGE OF A CAREER EXECUTIVE
ASSIGNMENT SO THAT THE SO THAT
WE CAN HAVE THAT LEVEL OF
ENGAGEMENT WITH FEDERAL
PARTNERS WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WITH OUR- TRIBAL
PARTNERS AS WITH HIGHLIGHTED IN
THE LEGISLATION THAT HAS LED
TO. A CONVERSATION WE'RE HAVING
TODAY WE THINK IT IS ESSENTIAL
THAT AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BEGINS TO BUILD OUT AND
IMPLEMENT OUR STRATEGY ON
SUICIDE PREVENTION. THAT IT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE A VERY
SENSITIVE POSITION THAT IS
WORKING TOWARDS A HOLISTIC
VISION OF THE ROLE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION IN THE CONTEXT OF
THESE OTHER MAJOR INITIATIVES
THAT WILL BE ESSENTIAL. IF
WE'RE GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
STRENGTHENING NOT JUST OUR
DIRECT PREVENTION WORK BETTER
UPSTREAM PRIMARY PREVENTION
RESILIENCY SUPPORT. AND
ENGAGEMENT OR- DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE.
AB WE RECOGNIZE THAT CITY PAGES
DONE A PHENOMENAL JOB IN TRYING
DOWN FEDERAL MONEY TO SUPPORT
SUICIDE PREVENTION EFFORTS WE
ARE WORKING WITH AS WAS
MENTIONED. IN THAT CAN THE
ANALYSIS AND THE BAY CITY AND
THE COMMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT ARE WORKING WITH
INTERNAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT- AT
OVER TWO DOZEN COUNTY
STRENGTHENED THEIR SISTER
PREVENTION EFFORTS. WE THINK
THERE ARE COUPLE OF CHALLENGES
THAT THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS ONE IS
STRENGTHENING OUR STRATEGY
AROUND REAL TIME SUICIDE
PREVENTION DATA. YOU KNOW WE
WILL NOT BE SURPRISED TO HEAR
TOMORROW THE PROGRESS THAT
WE'VE MADE IN ADDRESSING THE
GAP IN VACCINATION RATES TODAY
WE WILL HAVE REAL TIME
INFORMATION. WE NEED REAL TIME
INFORMATION AROUND RISK SELF
INJURY HARM AND SUICIDE SO THAT
WE CAN DELIVER PROGRAMMATIC AND
POLICY RESPONSES. THAT ARE-
TIMELY. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
THIS IN AREAS OF OPIOID
ADDICTIONS AND DEATHS
ATTRIBUTED TO OPIOID WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO THIS IN OTHER AREAS
OF HEALTHCARE. CALIFORNIA MUST
STRENGTHEN ITS STRATEGY TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE WORLD OF
SUICIDE IN A TIMELY MANNER. WE
THINK THAT'S GOING TO TAKE MORE
STAFF THAN IS ENVISIONED IN THE
B. C. P. ADDITIONALLY OUTREACH
IN COORDINATION IS GOING TO BE
EXCEPTIONALLY IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. OFTEN BEAR THE GREATEST
BURDEN OF RISK STOP ARM AND
SUICIDE SO SOME ADDITIONAL
STAFF TO REALLY STRENGTHEN
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. WE THINK
THERE'S A COMMUNICATIONS
ELEMENT THAT HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED AND THAT
COMMUNICATION ELEMENT MUST BE
HANDLED VERY SENSITIVELY AND
ENGAGE SURVIVORS OF SUICIDE
ATTEMPTS OF THE WAY WE TALK
ABOUT RSK. AND HARM AND
SUICIDE DOES NOT. ITSELF CREATE
ADDITIONAL HARM- YEAH WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE A BROADER
INVESTMENT- BOTH ONE TIME FUNDS
SOMETHING IN THE RANGE OF FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
IMMEDIATE QUESTIONS. AROUND
PARTNERING WITH COUNTIES
SCHOOLS TRIBES COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AND SOMETHING IN THE RANGE OF
TWO TO FIVE MILLION I'M GOING
TO REALLY SUPPORT THE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE THAT IS GOING TO BE
NECESSARY. IN CONNECTION WITH
OUR FEDERAL PRIVATE COUNTY AND
OTHER PUBLIC PARTNERS TO REALLY
MAKE THIS STRATEGY WHAT WE NEED
IN CALIFORNIA TO SAVE LIVES
EVERY DAY. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AGAIN WE HAVE NOT HAD
A CHANCE TO HAVE THAT DETAILED
DISCUSSION WITH THE LEADERSHIP
CDPH. BUT I RIGHT SHARE SOME OF
THE FUNCTIONAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE. STAYED AT THE OFFICE
NEEDS PURSUE. LIKE TO SEE
FINDING HELLO WITH THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. THANK THANK VERY
MUCH- MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROSS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU TO
THE PRESENTERS- CERTAINLY AS
THE AUTHOR OF AB AT TWENTY ONE
TWELVE THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION IN THE
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SOMETHING THAT'S- VERY
IMPORTANT- I'M HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ENCINA
HEARING THE PRESENTATIONS WILL
BE FOR ANA THANK ALL THOSE THAT
AREN'T. ENGAGED AND- MOVING
FORWARD ON SOME OF THE- REQUEST
OF FUNDING WE SEE COMING FROM-
THE FINANCE DEPARTMENT WITH THE
CLOSE TO EIGHT HUNDRED- K. BUT-
TO- MISTER- EWINGS- COMMENTS
THERE'S FAR MORE TO DO THIS IS
A JUST A FIRST STEP. IN REALLY
ADDRESSING THE- SUICIDE RATES
ESPECIALLY AMONGST THE-
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR INCLUDING
THE NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO DIVE
INTO THOSE DEMOGRAPHICS WHERE
WE SEE THE UPTICKS- IN A
SUICIDE PREVENTION FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO THANK ALL THOSE IN MY
COLLEAGUES FOR MOVING FORWARD
ON TWENTY ONE TWELVE TODAY WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
FORWARD TO STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND CERTAINLY TO-
CONTINUE TO- ADVOCATE FOR MORE
FUNDING UNTIL WE GET TO THE
POINT WHERE WE- REALLY HAVE THE
FUNNY WE NEED. AROUND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT IT IS HEART.
WARMING TO HEAR THAT FINALLY
THE SUICIDE PREVENTION IN THE
DISCUSSION AROUND IT HAS GOT TO
THE LEVEL TO WHERE IT IS HERE
IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE. WITH
A BILL OF OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND NOW WITH THE
DISCUSSION OF FUNDING TO ENSURE
THAT THAT CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD. FOR ALL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN AGAIN- WITH
THE NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE PART.
OF THE DISCUSSION MOVING
FORWARD AS FAR AS BUILDING THAT
PLAN THAT SO MANY. HAVE SEEN
THAT NOW IS AFFECTING ALL THE
YOU INCLUDING THE YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES FOR
THEM THANK ALL THE PRESENTERS
FOR CONTINUING TO MOVE FORWARD
ON THIS TOPIC. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND AGAIN. YOU KNOW YOU'LL-
YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN SPOT ON
WEDNESDAY. PRIOR PRESENTATIONS
TO THIS COMMITTEE AND I REALLY
DO. APPRECIATE THAT WHAT I'D
LIKE TO KIND OF GET A CLARITY
ON IS. THE ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGH
THEIR EL CAP. ON SUICIDE
PREVENTION OF WHICH HAS BEEN
PRETTY. A PREDOMINANT- IN IN
THE YEARS PAST. AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT. THE REQUIREMENT BUT
THE LACK OF FUNDING AND LACK OF
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS LACK OF.
WHERE CAN WE HAVE THIS
INTEGRATION. TO BE EFFECTIVE TO
REDUCE THAT. AMOUNT OF- OF-
TRAGEDY IN OUR SCHOOLS ALSO AS
A AS A PARTNER. THAT QUESTION
WAS DIRECTED AT TO BE HEALING
IF YOU WANT TICKETS. THANK YOU.
WELL CONCERT WITH MY PRIOR
COMMENTS I THINK THIS IS THE
LEADERSHIP STRATEGY THAT NEEDS
TO BE PUT IN PLACE TODAY THE
STATE HAS- CREATE AN
APPROPRIATE POLICIES IN MANY
INSTANCES BUT THERE ARE SOME
PIECES THAT ARE MISSING THE-
ADEQUATE FUNDING SUFFICIENT
ATTENTION ON TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND CAPACITY
BUILDING WITH SCHOOLS WITH
PRIVATE SECTOR PARTNERS EVEN
HOW WE TALK ABOUT RISK AND HOW
WE TALK ABOUT SUICIDE
PREVENTION WE REALLY NEED TO
ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES. WE NEED TO
HAVE A BROAD VISION FOR WHAT IT
MEANS TO ENSURE THAT THESE
NUMBERS COME DOWN QUICKLY
DRAMATICALLY IN ACROSS ALL
SECTORS OF CALIFORNIA DOING
THAT WILL MEAN BUILDING OUT
ROBUST PARTNERSHIPS WITH
SCHOOLS WITH EMPLOYERS WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
HOSPITALS PUBLIC SAFETY AS A
PUBLIC SAFETY DEPARTMENTS
OFFICERS FIREFIGHTERS. ALL OF
US JUST LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT
THE CORONA VIRUS AND HOW THIS
IS A CHALLENGE THAT ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES NEED TO TAKE ON WE
NEED TO TAKE ON SUICIDE
PREVENTION IN THE SAME WAY AND
SO I THINK THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DIFFICULT CONVERSATION TO
HAVE MOVING FORWARD AROUND HOW
WE STRUCTURE THESE
RELATIONSHIPS HOW WE FUND THESE
STRATEGIES. WE TOO ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE PROPOSAL
HERE WE THINK IT FALLS A LITTLE
SHORT WE LIKE TO SEE SOME
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN STAFF
AND RESOURCES TO REALLY BRING
THE LEADERSHIP THAT IS
NECESSARY. TO TACKLE THIS
CHALLENGE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
I'M- I'M GONNA FOLLOW UP WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION IF I COULD
ON SOME OF THE COMMENTS FROM
TOBY EWING SPECIFICALLY I'D
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON HOW. OR
WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
STRENGTHENED REAL TIME DATA WAS
HOPING YOU COULD COMMENT ON
THAT PLEASE. I THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION AGAIN THIS IS ONE
COME AROUND IS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THAT'S DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE LOOKING INTO RIGHT
NOW I AGREE WITH TO BE WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT WAYS THAT
WE CAN THINK A LITTLE BIT
OUTSIDE OF BOXER BE MORE
INNOVATIVE WHEN IT COMES. TO
THE WAY THAT WE'RE COLLECTING
DATA RIGHT NOW WE RELY A LOT ON
OUR VITAL STATISTICS DATA WERE
ALSO WORKING AS MEDIAN L. ON
OUR- BALADEH REPORTING THAT WE
DEALING SO WE- THIS GOAL. ARE
WE ACTUALLY DO THIS ON FAST A
LITTLE MORE I'M ACCURATE ICE
AND BE ABLE MOVE SOME OF THE
PUBLIC FORWARD. AS HIS RULES
OUT ANY GOING TO BE OF THE FOR
PRIOR. IS AS AT THE MAIN WHAT
WE LEARNED FROM COVERED WHAT
CAN WE NOW CAN WE USE AND OF
THOSE. THAT HAVE BEEN ALREADY
PUT PLACE TO ELEVATE OF THE
WERE AROUND- YOU'RE RIGHT. AND
ENTRY OF- THE INCIDENTS THAT
HAVE AND CAL IT'S A FOR THEM
MINISTRY. I'M IN TWO COMMENTS
HAD MENTIONED THAT THERE MAY BE
A NEED FOR FONG. WOULD YOU MORE
STAFF- IF YOU MORE WOULD YOU BE
ABLE TO. PROVIDE MORE TIME. RT
IT AT LET'S HAS TO DO A LOT
WITH. RIGHT IN SO. THAT WE MAY.
IN THAT A LOT OF THESE IT IS.
AT THE LOW. LEVEL I'M AND SO
IT'S- THE I PLAN OF THE WAY
THAT THE DAY. INTO AND GETS TO
EVEN THE DEPART OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND SO AS YOU THINK
THROUGH THOSE. AND THEN ALL THE
IT TECH. NEW TO. BUILD BACK.
THAT'S AN ASSESSMENT THAT WE
WILL TO DO ORDER FROM TO KIND
OF. YOU KNOW WHAT EXACT- IS
NEEDED AT THIS POINT. I'M A
THANK FOR YOUR- TO HEAR FROM
THE- IS OUR- AND WANTING TO
ADDRESS THIS IS. HAD A- AND- IF.
IS A NEED FOR US TO A BROADER.
SO THAT WE CAN SUPPLY. THIS
OFFICE WE- MORE THAN HAPPY TO
BE IN THOSE KIND. AND SO LOOK
FOR. TO CONTINUING THAT TEND.
THANK YOU FOR CAN. RIGHT NOW.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MEMBERS-
TOBY I HAD A IF I COULD BEFORE
I. TOBY I'M ONE OUNCE A
QUESTION IF I COULD YOU AND
MEANT NINE EIGHT EIGHT. AS WELL
AS CRISIS NOW Mà WAS HER YOU
COULD A LEVEL DETAIL. THANK YOU.
AGAIN TO BE WITH MEN HEALTH
COMMISSION. SO FEDERAL LAW. IT
ALL ALL STATES MOVING TO IN. A
THREE DIGIT CALL IN SYSTEM TO
TAKE PRESS OFF THE NINE ONE. IN
THE ONE OF THE GOAL IS TO ADD.
HAVE MORE A MENTAL HEALTH. TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN CHRIST RATHER
THAN A LAWN. RESPONSE THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK TO DO. AROUND WHAT
KINDS OF CALL ARE COMING IN HOW
WE ADDRESS. THAT THE KIND OF
SERVICES THAT ARE OF- THERE YET
THERE'S SOME. OPINION AROUND
THIS A SYSTEM THAT IS PRIMARILY.
TO BE SERVICE RISK. VERSES
BROUGHT MENTAL HEALTH. HOW TO
SO OF THAT COME. WHICH TO TAKE
PLACE IN THE NEXT- TEN OR
TWELVE. BECAUSE OF SOME DEBT.
IS DO WE BUILD OFF OF OR REFER.
THE CERTIFY HOTLINE SYSTEM WITH
THE NINE EIGHT SAID ARE THEY
YOU CONNECT ARE THERE WEREN'T.
WE STILL HAVE TO PAY THAT OUT.
AGAIN I MENTIONED CRIED NOW
WHICH IS A NATIONAL MODEL
DEVELOPED BY SAM'S. IT'S
EVIDENCE BASED. WE'RE WORKING
WITH MORE THAN A DOZEN K. TO
IMPLEMENT THE CRISIS NOW MODEL.
THE IS REALLY A STRANGE. THE
CONDUCT. RESPONSE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH RIGHT. THANK YOU. TO
AVOID PRIMARY TO AVOID FORCED
INVOLVED. M. THERE'S A NAY.
HIGH AND THEY'RE NOT BE A TIED.
BETWEEN THE NUMBER THAT THAT
RESIDENTS CALLED. AND THE KINDS
OF RESPONSE THAT WERE. THAT
THEY WERE SEEING IN OUR
COMMUNITY SO THAT WHEN CALL
WITH THE MEN HEALTH. WE
ACTUALLY DELAY A MENTAL HEALTH
RISKS. WITH SOMEONE CALL WITH
THIS. CRISIS WE DELIVER SIMILAR
RISK AND SAVE LIVES. SO I'M
VERY HM LEVEL OF WORK TO DO
THAT IS ABOUT VISION STRATEGY
AND THEN IMPLEMENTATION THAT
INCLUDES HOW WE FUND THESE
SERVICES. HOW WE MAKE HOW WE
MANAGE THE SHIFT FROM NINE ONE
ONE TWO NINE EIGHT EIGHT HOW WE
PROVIDE THE GUIDANCE THE TECH
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT. IN ADDITION TO THE
DOZEN OR SO COUNTIES THAT WERE
WORKING WITH THE CRISIS NOW
WE'VE BEEN APPROACHED BY
ANOTHER TWO DOZEN COUNTIES. TO
SEE IF THERE'S ROOM FOR. THOSE
ADDITIONAL COUNTIES TO JOIN
THIS LEARNING COLLABORATIVE
THAT THE COMMISSION HAS BUILT
UNDER THIS CRISIS NOW MODEL.
AND THE LAST THING I MEN IS THE
STRATEGY I KNEW IN ENHANCE IN
FACT REMEMBER FROM MENTAL
HEALTH RISK. WELL A LOT.
BEGINNING IN. TO STRAIN UR MO
MALL REFER WHICH NEEDS TO BE A
TIE INTO THE NINE EIGHTY AND
CRIED NOW SO IT'S UNCLEAR. HOW
THE STATE'S SUICIDE PREVENTION
STRATEGY WILL CONNECT WITH THAT
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE RECOMMENDING
AT THIS POSITION BE HIGH LEVEL
EXECUTIVE POSITION THAT CAN
REALLY. LEAD AND SORT OUT MANY
OF THOSE ISSUES AND BE PART OF
THE STRATEGY. THROUGHOUT NINE
EIGHT EIGHT CRISIS NOW GLOBAL
PRICES WHICH WILL PRIMARILY BE.
LED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. I KNOW LIKE TO
TURN IT TO THE ADMIN. OF I
COULD- EARLIER YOU HAD SAID-
SUICIDE NEED TO BE A BY
MULTIPLE AND WAS HOPING COULD
COMMENT ABOUT THE ROLE THAT
NINE EIGHT EIGHT WOULD PLAY IN
SUICIDE PREVENTION. SORRY THAT
WAS FOR THE ADMINISTRATION. YES
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES MA'AM.
APOLOGIES THAT IS TECHNICAL
SHOULD YEAH I MEAN WE THAT THIS
IS ONE OF THIS THAT DEFINITELY
TO SHIP FOR ANY THAT WE ACROSS
THE SPECTRUM NOT JUST THE STATE
AND THE- EVEN WITH LOCAL CHURCH
AND. AND THAT IT'S AN THAT WHAT
CAN SEND. OF WE'RE HAVING OF
THAT THE ARE IN. LANE THE
GROUNDWORK FOR FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS I THINK ONLY TALK
ABOUT MULTIPLE ENTITIES- AND
DEALING WITH SUICIDE PREVENTION
FROM YOUTH ALL THE WAY TO
ADULTS THAT- THERE HAS TO BE
THAT- AS FAR AS AN OFFICE OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION WORK ALL
THESE FILLERS- PHILIP TO ONE
AREA SO THEN WE TRULY
UNDERSTAND THE DATA OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH WE
UNDERSTAND THE RESOURCES ARE
THERE. MORE OF A CLEARING HOUSE
TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT THAT'S A VISION
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON AN
ADVOCATE FOR AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR. LEADING THIS
DISCUSSION. I'D LIKE TO THANK
VERY MUCH PANEL ONE WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO PANEL TO ON THE
OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY. WE WILL HAVE TO
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THE LIZABETH
LANDSBERG. THE DIRECTOR OF POSH
PAD AND COREY HASHI DONNA WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. LET'S BEGIN WITH
DIRECTOR LYNCHBURG. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THOSE PLANS BURKE THE
DIRECTOR OF OFFENSE AND I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT THE PROPOSAL
TO CREATE THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY. HEALTHCARE
COSTS AE RISING AT AN
UNSUSTAINABLE RATE. ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FOUNDATIONOVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS INFLATION HAS
GROWN BY 44% OF THE COST OF
PREMIUMS HAS GROWN BY ALMOST
TWO HUNDRED AND 50% OR MORE
THAN FOUR TIMES THE RATE OF
INFLATION. THE STATE NEEDS A
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING OF
COST DRIVERS. AND DRIVERS OF
HEALTHCARE SPENDING. AND
STRATEGIES FOR CONTROLLING THE
COST OF HEALTH CARE WHILE
MAINTAINING QUALITY AND EQUITY
OF CARE. AS MOST ARE LIKELY
AWARE DOCTOR WOULD HAVE THE
POLICY BILL TO CREATE THE
OFFICE WHICH STARTED WITH THE
SAME LANGUAGE AS IN OUR TRAILER
BILL. WE'VE BEEN COLLABORATING
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT AND
TALKING TO STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
OUR PROPOSED OFFICE. I WANT TO
THANK DOCTOR WOULDN'T HAVE
STAFF FOR THEIR STEADFAST
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE AND
FOR THEIR COLLABORATION. THE
OFFICE WOULD BE CHARGED WITH
ANALYZING THE HEALTHCARE COSTS
MARKET FOR COST TRENDS AND
DRIVERS OF SPENDING. SETTING
AND ENFORCING HEALTH ARE COST
TARGETS AND MEASURING KEY
INDICATORS TO ENSURE WE ARE
ACHIEVING A HIGH VALUE SYSTEM
RATHER THAN A LOW COST LOW.
RATHER THAN A LOW COST AND LOW
ABOUT VALUE SYSTEM. SO WHEN I
JUST GO THROUGH THE KEY
ACTIVITIES AT THE POST OFFICE.
WE GET INCREASED PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY BY TOTAL
HEALTHCARE SPENDING IN THE
STATE. THE OFFICE WOULD REQUIRE
REPORTING OF TOTAL HEALTHCARE
EXPENDITURE DATA BROKEN DOWN BY
SERVICE CATEGORY SUCH AS
HOSPITAL CARE PHYSICIAN
SERVICES PERSCRIPTION DRUGS
EXCEPT FOR A- THIS DATA WOULD
BE SUPPLEMENTED WITH FINANCIAL
REPORTS FROM PROVIDERS AND
GRANULAR CLAIMS DATA FROM THE
EMERGING HEALTH CARE PAYMENT
STATUS SYSTEM. THE OFFICE WOULD
PUBLISH AN ANNUAL REPORT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE PUBLIC
MEETINGS ON HEALTHCARE SPENDING
TRENDS IN UNDERLYING FACTORS
ALONG WITH POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO CONTROL
COSTS AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF EQUITY OF THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. NEXT THE OFFICE WOULD
SET AN OVERALL STATEWIDE COST
TARGETS AND SPECIFIC TARGETS
FOR DIFFERENT SECTORS IN THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY. THOSE
TARGETS THE SPECIFIC SECTOR
TARGETS COULD BE BY HEALTHCARE
SECTOR AS WELL AS BY SPECIFIC
GEOGRAPHIC REGION. NEXT THE
OFFICE WOULD HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO ENFORCE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
COST TARGETS. THE OFFICE WOULD
PROGRESSIVELY ENFORCE
COMPLIANCE WITH COST TARGETS
BEGINNING WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND PROGRESSIVELY
INCREASED TO INCLUDE TESTIMONY
AT PUBLIC MEETINGS CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS AND ULTIMATELY IF
NECESSARY ASSESSMENT OF
FINANCIAL PENALTIES. THE OFFICE
WILL ALSO PROMOTE AND MEASURE
QUALITY IN EQUITY THROUGH
PERFORMANCE REPORTING. TO AVOID
UNANTICIPATED CONSEQUENCES THAT
COULD RESULT FROM FOCUSING ON
COST ALONE PERFORMANCE ON
QUALITY EQUITY MEASURES WELL
THE MEASURE TO GUARD AGAINST
NEGATIVE IMPACTS. THE OFFICE
WOULD LEVERAGE QUALITY IN
EQUITY METRICS USED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES COVER
CALIFORNIA ANOTHER EXISTING
MEASURES TO DECREASE
DUPLICATION OF EFFORT. NEXT THE
OFFICE WOULD SET A STATEWIDE
GOAL FOR ADOPTION OF
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT MODELS AND
DEVELOP STANDARDS FOR USE BY
PAYERS AND PROVIDERS. THE
OFFICE WOULD SET THE STATE WIDE
GOAL FOR ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
MODELS THAT PROMOTE SHIFTING
PAYMENTS FROM FEE FOR SERVICE
TO PAYMENTS THAT REWARD HIGH
QUALITY AND COST EFFECTIVE CARE.
THE OFFICE WOULD MEASURE
PROGRESS TOWARD THE GOAL AND
ADOPT STANDARDS FOR ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT MODELS TO BE USED BY
PROVIDERS AND PAYERS TURNING
CONTRACTING. THE OFFICE BUT
ALSO MEASURED PROVOKED AS THE
STATE SYSTEM WIDE INVESTMENT IN
PRIMARY CARE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. MODELS THAT INTEGRATE
HEALTH SERVICES HAVE BEEN SHOWN
TO IMPROVE ACCESS AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES. AS WELL AS REDUCE
DOWNSTREAM HEALTHCARE COSTS. IN
ORDER TO BUILD AND SUSTAIN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPACITY THE
OFFICE WOULD MEASURE THE
PERCENTAGE OF TOTAL HEALTH CARE
EXPENDITURES ALLOCATED TO
PRIMARY CARE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND THAT SPENDING
BENCHMARKS IN THESE AREAS. THE
OFFICE BUT ALSO MONITOR AND
ADDRESS HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
STABILITY COLLECTING DATA AND
ANALYZING CHANGES TO THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE TO AVOID
HARMFUL REDUCTIONS TO THE
WORKFORCE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA.
AND FINALLY THE OFFICE WOULD
HAVE A ROLE IN REVIEWING
PROPOSED HEALTHCARE
CONSOLIDATIONS KNOWLEDGE EVEN
IF IT'S GONNA BE THIS CAN BE AN
IMPORTANT DRIVER OF COST. TO
THE OFFICE BUT INCREASED PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY ON TRANSACTIONS
THAT MAY IMPACT MARKET
COMPETITION REVIEWING MERGERS
AND ACQUISITIONS NOT CURRENTLY
REVIEWED BY ANOTHER
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY. THE
COMMITTEE ASKED THAT I
RESPONSES TYPICALLY TO CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION I'M HAPPY
TO DO SO NOW- OF THE CHAIR WITH
LIKE. PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
SO I WANT TO FIRST START OFF BY
SAYING THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THIS DIALOGUE A VERY
THAT PERSPECTIVE. WITH RESPECT
TO EQUITABLE TREATMENT BETWEEN
PAYERS AND PROVIDERS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THEIR
EXISTING REVIEW PROCESSES BY
STATE DEPARTMENTS WITH RESPECT
TO THE REVIEW OF PREMIUMS AND
WE'RE LOOKING TO LEVERAGE THOSE
ANALYSES AND NOT DUPLICATE THEM.
FOR EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA LAW
EXTENDS RATE REVIEW FILING
REQUIREMENTS TO INCLUDE LARGE
GROUPS REQUIREMENT THAT GOES
BEYOND THAT REQUIRED BY THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. STATE
REGULATED PLANS IN THE
INDIVIDUAL SMALL AND LARGE
GROUP MARKETS MUST FILE RATE
INFORMATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE PRIOR
TO IMPLEMENTING A RATE CHANGE.
TAKING A BROADER VIEW THE
OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY WOULD FOCUS ON
ALL COST DRIVERS THAT AFFECT
PREMIUMS AND THE OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSES BORNE BY CONSUMERS.
THE OFFICE WILL EXAMINE THE
COST OF CARE BY LOOKING AT ALL
CONTRIBUTORS INCLUDING DOCTORS
AND OTHER PROVIDERS HOSPITALS
PHARMACEUTICAL MANUFACTURERS
AND THE ADMINISTRATIVECOSTS
AND PROFITS OF HEALTH PLANS.
NEXT WITH RESPECTIVE
CONTROLLING COSTS AT THE
EXPENSE OF QUALITY THE OFFICE
WILL HAVE GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE
THAT COST CONTAINMENT DOES NOT
COME AT THE EXPENSE OF QUALITY
EQUITY OR WORK FOR STABILITY
AND WE'RE BEING VERY PURPOSEFUL
ABOUT THAT. THE OFFICE WOULD
COLLECT DATA AND CAREFULLY
MONITOR EACH OF THESE AREAS. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND PRIMARY CARE NEEDED AND
BECAUSE WE HOPE WILL EVENTUALLY
REDUCE COSTS. AND WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE HIGH
COST CARE SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
EFFICIENT AND DELIVER VALUE AND
WE ARE EXPLORING HOW TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE. WHAT WOULD BE
UNIQUE ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
OFFICE HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES IS
THAT WE WILL COLLECT AND REPORT
DATA ON HARMFUL TRENDS AND
CHANGES IN THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE AND DEVELOP STANDARDS
TO INFORM STRATEGIES. TO LOWER
COSTS IN A WAY THAT PROMOTES
THE STABILITY AND TRAINING
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE. THE OFFICE WILL
ALSO REPORT QUALITY PERFORMANCE
IN EQUITY METRICS ON THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. IT'S PAYMENT
MODELS THAT REWARD HIGH QUALITY
AND COST EFFICIENT CARE AND
PROMOTE INVESTMENTS IN PRIMARY
CARE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. NEXT
THE OFFICE IS MINDFUL OF NOT
CREATING MISALIGNED INCENTIVES
AND UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OUR
PROPOSAL IS DESIGNED TO AVOID
THESE OUTCOMES THROUGH THE
EXAMPLE OF OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE HAD A HEAD START. THE
DIVERSE MEMBERSHIP EXPERTISE OF
THE ADVISORY BOARD AND
FACILITATING. LOOK CONVERSATION
FOR ONGOING IMPLEMENTATION
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARD TO THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND
COST SHIFTING IN THE NEXT ROUND
OF AMENDMENTS FOR AB ELEVEN
THIRTY SPECIFIC CATEGORIES ARE
REFERENCES TO POTENTIAL SECTOR
TARGETS HAVE BEEN ADJUSTED TO
NOT PRESUPPOSE WHAT SECTORS ARE
APPROPRIATE WE HEARD FEEDBACK
THAT CREATING NUMEROUS SECTOR
TARGETS COULD LEAD TO A SILO
APPROACH AND FRAGMENTATION
RATHER THAN A COOPERATIVE
APPROACH THAT WE ARE SEEKING
BETWEEN ENTITIES TO ACHIEVE
COST TARGETS AND WE WILL BE
MINDFUL. OF THIS AND SETTING
THE SECTOR TARGETS. AND FINALLY
WE- THAT THE PROCESSES OF
OFFICE NEED HAVE TRANSPARENCY
AND STAKEHOLDER INPUT. IN THE
PROCESS OF SETTING TARGET
SHOULD BE DONE IN A WAY THAT
INCREASES CONFIDENCE IN THE
PROGRAM. BY VIRTUE OF THE FACT
LOOKING NEEDING ACT ALL
MEETINGS OF THEADVISORY BOARD
WITH THE PUBLIC AND
STAKEHOLDERS WILL HAVE AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
ROBUST DISCUSSION AND SUBMIT
PUBLIC COMMENT ON PROPOSED COST
TARGETS. A SEPARATE MEETING
WITH THE DIRECTOR WOULD
FORMALLY ADOPT THE COST TARGETS
ARE ALSO PUBLIC MEETINGS
SUBJECT TO BAGLEY KEENE. AND I
WOULD JUST NOTE I THINK- I'VE
HAD EXPERIENCE IN THE EXAMPLE
WE SET FORTH IN THE WAY WE HAVE
ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S ALL
PAYER CLAIMS DATABASE. ARE YOU
SPEEDY PROGRAM I THINK IS
INDICATIVE OF THE WAY WE WOULD
WANT TO APPROACH STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY I
THINK ANYONE WHO'S BEEN PART OF
THE H. P. D. PROCESS- THE
BOARD. KNOWS THAT WE HAVE HEARD
A DIVERSE STAKEHOLDER INPUT
AND- I THINK IT'S PRETTY
AMAZING JOB OF COMING TO
CONSENSUS AFTER HEARING ALL OF
THOSE- DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
AND SO I THINK THAT SHOULD DO
IT- IN VIEW. BUT THE COMMITTEE
WAS SUDDEN WHAT WITH SOME
CONFIDENCE IN THE WAY THAT WE
APPROACH OUR OUR RELATIONSHIPS
pWITH STAKEHOLDERS. SO I'M HAPPY
TO STOP AT THIS POINT HELLO
MISTER CHAIR OR- QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR WILL NEXT GO
TO COREY HASHI DARK. WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA ACCORDING
FROM THE ILIO- GENERALLY WE
DON'T WE DON'T HAVE MAJOR
CONCERNS TO RAISE WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF AN OFFICE OF
AFFORDABILITY. JUST A FEW
CONSIDERATIONS TO RAISE GOING
FORWARD- GIVEN THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES HAVE BEEN
A MAJOR PUBLIC POLICY CONCERN
IN THE STATE FOR A WHILE- AND
THAT THERE'S BEEN LEGISLATIVE
INTEREST IN ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE- WE FIND THAT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS OFFICE
WHICH GENERALLY HAS THE GOAL OF
CONTAINING ESCALATING HEALTH
CARE COSTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. MAKES SENSE AND CONCEPT
AS A METHOD TO RESPOND TO THE
STATE'S AFFORDABILITY ISSUES-
WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL DOES INCLUDE A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCE REQUEST-
EVENTUALLY RAMPING UP TO OVER.
A HUNDRED TWENTY POSITIONS IN
ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN A FEW YEARS-
REGARDING THE RESOURCE REQUEST
THAT THE PROPOSED OFFICE IS
LARGELY MODELED AFTER. A
SIMILAR AFFORDABILITY
INITIATIVE IN MASSACHUSETTS
KNOWN AS THE MASSACHUSETTS
HEALTH POLICY COMMISSION OR THE
H. P. C. AND THE PROPOSED LEVEL
OF STAFFING IS GREATER THAN
THAT OF THE H. P. C. WHICH WE
FIND TO BE GENERALLY REASONABLE
BUT WOULD NOTE THAT THERE IS
SOME CONSTITUENTS ARE AND BE
ABOUT WHETHER. THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES WILL BE- THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OVER THE
COMING YEARS AND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO CHECK
IN WITH SOME DEGREE OF
REGULARITY. ON LEVEL ON WHETHER
THE LEVEL OF RESOURCES ATTACHED
TO THIS PROPOSAL ARE ARE
APPROPRIATE GOING FORWARD-
BEYOND THE STAFFING REQUEST WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THIS
PROPOSED OFFICE IS LIKELY GOING
TO BE VERY ADMINISTRATIVELY
COMPLEX TO IMPLEMENT- THERE ARE
A MULTITUDE OF ENTITIES IN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM BE VERY.
PROVIDERS OR PAYERS- AND IT'S
GOING TO BE A SIGNIFICANT. LEFT
FOR THIS OFFICE TO DETERMINE.
EXACTLY WHAT IT PER. TO AND-
WHAT TARGETS THESE ENTITIES
WILL BE REQUIRED TO MEET AND
SUCH AND SO I SUCH GOING
FORWARD THE LEGISLATURE. ARMY
ONE OF MONITOR MORE BROADLY THE
PROGRESS TOWARDS FULLY
IMPLEMENTING THIS OFFICES
ACTIVITIES- BUILT THOSE ARE ALL
OF OUR OFFICES COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
FURTHER ASSISTANCE WHERE NEEDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BEGIN
NOW WITH MEMBERS QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS. THANK
YOU CHARAMBA- I THINK THE
BIGGEST THING WITH THIS THE
STRIKES ME BESIDES THE ENORMOUS
ADMINISTRATIVE COST TO IT I
THINK ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS. AS IS YOU AND I WORKED
ON THESE BUDGETS FOR SEVEN
YEARS IS THAT. WE'RE WE'RE
BLOWIN 8090% OF THE MONEY ON
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND IT'S
NOT ACTUALLY GETTING DOWN TO
THE PEOPLE THAT'S THAT'S ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CONCERNS I HAVE
HERE. IN IN THE OTHER THE
SOMETHING ELSE WE'VE ALL BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IS THE FACT THAT
THESE COMPUTER SYSTEMS- THAT
THEY'VE BEEN USING THAT THE
AGENCIES DON'T WORK SO AS AS
THE- I WANT AN ANSWER ON THIS
ONE. IS AS AS WE GO TO MOVE- IN
AND DO ALL THIS NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE STUFF WHAT WHAT
COMPUTER SYSTEMS ARE GOING TO
BE OUT OF GOING TO FINALLY BE
AT A AT AN APP BASED SYSTEM
WHERE THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY
NEED THE SERVICES CAN PICK UP
THEIR PHONE AND ENTER THEIR
INFO AND DO SCREEN SHOTS AND-
BE PART OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. AND WE'RE CALIFORNIA
SO WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO IT
OR NOT. DEAR DEAR YOUR SCREEN
ALREADY FROZE THE TUG OF THE
COMPUTERS ARE. DIRECTOR YOUR-
FRIDA MAKE COMMENT IF YOU'D
LIKE OR WE CAN MOVE ON AS YOU
SEE FIT. SURE I'M HAPPY TO
BRIEFLY ADDRESS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS CONCERNED SO IN TERMS
OF AND IT ALSO RELATES OF WHAT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE NOTED SO IT IS TRUE THAT
THE WHEN WE STARTED OUR
STAFFING. MODEL WE DID LOOK TO
MASSACHUSETTS I THINK WE'VE ALL
RECOGNIZE THE CALIFORNIA'S
QUITE A BIT LARGER THAN THAN
MASSACHUSETTS AND BELIAU ALSO
NOTED THE COMPLEXITY OF THIS
PROGRAM SO THE WHOLE IDEA IS TO
IS TO- REALLY BEND THE COST
CURVE AND WE THINK THAT OUR
MODEL IS IT. IS THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF STAFFING GIVEN THE
COMPLEXITY OF HEALTHCARE- IN
CALIFORNIA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS RELATED TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMPUTER SYSTEMS
WERE HAPPY TO GO INTO MORE
DETAIL IF YOU WOULD LIKE I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN AN OPTION HAD FOR.
MONTHS AND I COULDN'T BE MORE.
IMPRESSED BY BY STAFF ABILITY
TO BUILD SYSTEMS VERY QUICKLY
AND VERY EFFICIENTLY SO THIS IS
NOT DESIGNED TO BE A CONSUMER
FACING- HELP OF COMPUTER SYSTEM
THAT WOULD HAVE AN APP ON A
PHONE UP FOR EXAMPLE. BUT WE
HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
BUILDING NEW SYSTEMS THAT
INTERFACE WITH WITH THE HEALTH
PLANS WITH THE PROVIDERS TECH
TO CAPTURE THEIR DATA SO I FEEL
VERY CONFIDENT- IN MY TEAM'S
ABILITY TO SUCCEED ON THE DATA
FRONT. ANNUAL ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO SHARE THE DATA BACK AND
FORTH IN AND DO THE THINGS
INSTEAD OF BEING STUCK IN A.
FILE LIKE YOU HAVE BEEN FOR THE
LAST DECADE. AB WE- I'M HAD A
REALLY FROM. AND SIX IN HER OF
SHOWING OUR DATA WE HAVE MANY
MANY DASHBOARDS- ON OUR SYSTEM
AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO SPEND TIME
WITH YOU OR YOUR STAFF. SHOWING
THE MULTITUDE OF DATA SETS THAT
ARE ARE AVAILABLE. FILE I'M
SURE SOME OF THE OTHER MEMBERS
MIGHT HAVE- QUESTIONS IN
REGARDS TO DASHBOARDS SO ALL OF
THE MENTOR. OF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT. WHAT
ABOUT THAT YOU AYE DIRECTOR
LANCE BERG- OBVIOUSLY OUR
OFFICE IS WORKING CLOSELY WITH
YOURS AS WE AS WE WORK ON THE
ON THE POLICY HERE- AND I JUST
WANT TO YOU KNOW. I GUESS I'LL
JUST PUT MY TWO CENTS INTO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CONCERNS ABOUT
DATA- I WOULD SAY THAT HE AS WE
LOOK AT THIS THERE'S A LOT OF
DATA SYSTEMS ALREADY OUT THERE
THAT THIS THIS OFFICE WILL DRAW
UPON EXISTING DATA SYSTEMS-
THAT DON'T REQUIRE THE KIND OF
CONNECTIVE ITTY N. AND
INTERACTIVE NEWS THAT YOU MIGHT
MIGHT THINK MIGHT NEED TO
HAPPEN. THE ALL PAYER CLAIMS
DATABASE WILL COME ONLINE IN IN
IN- TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE THAT WILL BE A HUGE
SOURCE OF INFORMATION THAT'S
ACTUALLY BEING BILLED AS WE FOR
THE PURPOSE FOR THAT FROM
SCRATCH- AND THAT'S GONNA BE A
HUGE BASIS OF INFORMATION FOR
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WHICH WILL ALSO
CREATE ITS OWN SEPARATE DATA
SYSTEM. AS WELL SO WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE RELYING THE
OPERATION OF THIS OFFICE WILL
BE RELYING ON ON ON OTHER
SYSTEMS PER SE IS GOING TO HAVE
ITS OWN ITS OWN SYSTEM AND THE
DATA WILL BE COMING FROM
ANOTHER SYSTEM THAT'S BEEN
BUILT A BILL BY OSP PAD SO. SO
I THINK THAT IT IS DIFFERENT
THAN AND LOOK TRUST TRUST ME I
SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION ON SOME
OF OUR OTHER DATA SYSTEMS I
THINK IT'S THE FACT OF HAVING
THAT PUBLIC SO THE UBLIC CAN
ACTUALLY SEE WHAT THAT'S GONNA
LOOK LIKE AND- UNDERSTAND THAT
COMPREHENSIVELY VERSUS. JUST A
HEY WE'RE BUILDING A SYSTEM.
WELL I THINK THAT ARE THE CA.
WHAT'S WHAT'S THE HERE IS THIS
IS NOT THE KIND OF INFORMATION
THAT'S GOING TO BE- TYPICALLY
CONSUMABLE BY THE PUBLIC. THE
IDEA IS TO- IS TO HAVE A GROUP
OF EXPERTS- THE ANALYZE THE
DATA. AND MAKE MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS SO THERE WON'T
BE APPS THERE WILL BE THAT KIND
OF THAT KIND OF THING. OUT
THERE FOR THE CONSUMERS TO LOOK
AT- THERE WILL BE HEARINGS-
WITH- THE AND THERE WILL ALSO
BE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO. TO MAKE
ENQUIRIES AS WELL SO THIS ISN'T
YOU KNOW THIS WON'T BE LIKE YOU
KNOW LIKE A LAB TEST. RIGHT CAN
GO ON MY PHONE AND GET SEE THE
RESULTS OF MY OF MY BLOOD WORK
IT'S NOT THAT KIND OF THING
THIS IS. A MUCH MORE GLOBAL AND
COMPREHENSIVE- DATA THAT'S-
QUITE FRANKLY GOING TO TAKE A
LOT OF A LOT OF EFFORT TO PUT
TOGETHER. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. SEVEN MONITORS FONG
THE STAFF QUESTIONS WHATEVER
THE CHAIR WITH LIKE. LET'S
BEGIN WITH THAT NOW AND THEN I
WILL ASK MY QUESTIONS AFTER
THAT IF I CAN DIRECTOR. OKAY SO
QUESTION ONE WE WERE ASKED TO
DESCRIBE ANY CHANGES THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE TO THE PROPOSAL SINCE
JANUARY SO WE HAVE NOT MODIFIED
THE ADMINISTRATION'S TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE HOWEVER WE HAVE
BEEN FULLER FROM COLLABORATING
WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHAT'S
OFFICE AND TALKING TO
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT OUR PROPOSED
OFFICE AND THOSE CONVERSATIONS
CONTINUE AS WE WORK THROUGH THE
ISSUES. BUT I DO WANT TO GO
THROUGH SOME OF THE MAJOR AREAS.
WHERE WE HAVE REACHED
AGREEMENT. A MAJOR CONCERN
REPORT RELATES TO THE DATA
DURING THE RECORDING TIMELINE
DUE TO THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC. SO WE'VE HEARD VERY
LOUD AND CLEAR FROM
STAKEHOLDERS THE IMPACT THE
PANDEMIC HAS HAD ON THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM- AND SO FOLKS
HAVE PERSUASIVELY NOTED THAT WE
SHOULD NOT BE USING THE
CURRENT. YEAR DATA SAYS THAT
OUR BASELINE. AT THE SAME TIME
WE THINK HAVING DATA FROM THE
PANDEMIC TIME FRAME WILL BE
USEFUL FOR ANALYSIS SO WE
AGREED TO HAVE THE OFFICE
COLLECT AGGREGATE DATA. ON THE
TOTAL COST OF CARE 420-192-2020
ONE- AND TO REPORT ON THIS. AND
THEN THE BASELINE DATA. IS
BEING PUSHED OUT- TWO YEARS
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. WHICH WOULD BE
RECORDED IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TO ESTABLISH THE BASELINE ANY
CAN BE RECORDED ON. AND THEN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR DATE WOULD
BE THE FIRST SET OF DATA THAT
WILL BE MEASURED AGAINST A TOP
COST TARGET. AND THEN FINALLY
WE'VE AGREED TO PUSH OUT BY TWO
YEARS THE SPECIFIC TARGETS BY
HEALTHCARE. SECTOR AND
GEOGRAPHIC REGION. WE'VE ALSO
OVER IF YOU ON THE COMPASS OF
THE ADVISORY. AND I ARE LOOKING
AT ADDING TWO MORE MEMBERS
WHICH WOULD BRING THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF MEMBERS TO ELEVEN.
ONE MEMBER WOULD REPRESENT A
PURCHASER OF HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE OR BENEFITS WHO ALSO
HAS EXPERIENCE IN HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY FINANCING. MANAGEMENT
OR ADMINISTRATION. THE OTHER
WOULD BE TO ADD THE CALPERS
CHIEF HEALTH DIRECTOR OR DOES
IT NEED TO THE FORT. AND ON THE
HEALTH CARE COST TARGETS WE
AGREE WITH CLARIFYING THAT THE
OUSTED DIRECTOR CAN ADJUST COST
TARGETS BY GEOGRAPHIC REGION
SUBREGION AND SECTORS. ON AND
FORCE MEANT WE HAD ALWAYS AND
WE THAT WE ALWAYS HAVE
INTENDED- TO HAVE A PROGRESSIVE
APPROACH TO ENFORCEMENT BUT
AGREED TO PUT LANGUAGE INTO THE
BILL CLARIFYING THAT THE OFFICE
WOULD ENFORCE THE PROVISIONS IN
A PROGRESSIVE MANNER. THE WILL
OF SEEK TO ASSIST HEALTHCARE
ENTITIES TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE INCLUDING THROUGHOUT
REACH TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS BEFORE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES UNLESS
THE VIOLATION IS EGREGIOUSFOR
EXAMPLE REPEATED FAILURE TO
FILE A CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN
OR IMPLEMENT CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLAN. ANHALTER PAYMENT MODELS
WE'VE AGREED THAT THE OFFICE
SHOULD REVIEW THOSE STANDARDS
AT LEAST EVERY FIVE YEARS TO
DETERMINE IF THE STANDARDS ARE
DELIVERING HIGH QUALITY COST
EFFICIENT AND EQUITABLE CARE
AND HEALTH CARE IT'S AN EVER
CHANGING AREA AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE- RELYING
ON THE MOST. RECENT MODELS AND
RESEARCH. AND FOR. PRIMARY CARE
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WE ALSO
AGREE WITH REQUIRING THE
SPENDING BENCHMARKS FOR PRIMARY
CARE TO CONSIDER CURRENT AND
FORMER UNDER FUNDING OF PRIMARY
CARE SERVICES. ON HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE STABILITY WE AGREE
THAT IN PURSUING AFFORDABILITY
WE WOULD RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
BOTH MAINTAIN AND INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS
AND RESPECTS COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS. WE ALSO
AGREE WITH THE CLARIFICATIONS
AS TO WHAT THE OFFICES ROLE
WOULD BE WITH RESPECT TO
CONSOLIDATION. MAKING CLEAR THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE OFFICE
AND THOSE THAT HAVE EXISTING
JURISDICTIONS OVER HEALTH CARE
MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS. THIS
WILL HELP REDUCE DUPLICATION OF
EFFORT AND ALLOW THE OFFICE TO
FOCUS ON GAPS IN REVIEW. SO
THAT'S THE SUMMARY- OF ISSUES
WE'VE WORKED OUT WHICH REFLECTS
TREMENDOUS ENGAGEMENT BY ALL
PARTIES I'M IN ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
AND- AS I BEGIN MY COMMENTS
TODAY I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
ACTUALLY. THANK ARE CALLING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD FOR
WORKING ON THIS I KNOW WE HAVE
BEGAN THIS CONVERSATION WHEN WE
WORKED ON A SELECT COMMITTEE
AND- YOUR PERSISTENCE AS WELL
NOTED HERE AND APPRECIATE- IF I
COULD ONLY HAVE THREE QUESTIONS
FOR YOU DIRECTOR RIGHT I WANTED
TO GET IN ABOUT THE SILO VERSUS
COLLABORATIVE. NATURE OF
SETTING TARGETS FOR SECTORS. I
WANTED TO. UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HOW WE DON'T SHIFT
COSTS OF FOR. A LOOKING AT
CERTAIN SECTORS AND POTENTIALLY
NOT OTHERS AND HOPING YOU COULD
COMMENT ABOUT HOW WE CAN MAKE A
COLLABORATIVE. ABSOLUTELY SO I
THINK WE NEED TO DO ABOVE AND
APPROACH HERE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BOTH LOOK
AT THE TOTAL COST OF CARE AND
HAVE- SPECIFIC STRATEGIES AND
GOALS FOR TOTAL COST OF CARE.
BUT ALSO TO LOOK UNDER THE HOOD
IT'S AT WORK TO UNDERSTAND THE
COST DRIVERS ARE THERE
PRIMARILY WITH HOSPITALS WHAT
PROVIDERS WITH TECHNOLOGY WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IT IS OUR
HOPE IS AGAIN WITH TRANSPARENCY
REPORTING TO BETTER UNDERSTAND.
HOW COSTS ARE CHANGING OVER
TIME BUT ALSO WE DO VERY MUCH
WANT TO HELP CONTRIBUTE TO THE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH IS A
PATH AS OPPOSED TO A SILENT
APPROACH- WE HOPE THAT THIS
WILL SPUR ADDITIONAL
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT SEGMENTS OF THE
HEALTHCARE. INDUSTRY TO WORK
TOGETHER TO MEET THE COST
TARGETS THAT ARE SET- AGAIN I'M
JUST KNOW THE ADVISORY BOARD IS
GOING TO PLAY SUCH A KEY ROLE-
IN IN HAVING ECONOMIC EXPERTISE
AND HAVING EXPERTISE ABOUT THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM- AND HOW IT
FUNCTIONS. AND SO WE HAVE FAITH
IN IN THE TRANSPARENCY OF THE
PUBLIC PROCESS THE ABILITY FOR
ALL OF THE PARTIES TO BE AT THE
TABLE I'M CONTRIBUTING AND FOR
THE ADVISORY BOARD CHAT TAKE
THAT INPUT AS THEY PICK WHAT
WHAT ECONOMIC INDICATORS MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR HEALTHCARE. AND
WHAT CONDITIONS- ARE HAPPENING
IN THE WORLD YOU KNOW WHO COULD
HAVE PREDICTED A FEW YEARS AGO
THAT WE WOULD. BE HERE WITH THE
PANDEMIC AND OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON HEALTHCARE
COSTS AND SO WE WOULD IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE BE ABLE TO BE
AGILE ENOUGH TO ADJUST. AS
CONDITIONS CHANGE- HELLO THOSE
LINES COMMUTER. COMMENT YOU
BROUGHT UP THE- BOARD I'M TRY
TO. REALLY HAVE A CLARIFICATION
BETWEEN THE ROLE OF THE OFFICE
AND THE ROLE OF THE ADVISORY
BOARD AND- HOW THAT INTERFACE
WILL WORK AND HOPING YOU COULD
COMMENT ON. SURE I THINK OF IT
IN PART- YOU KNOW COVER
CALIFORNIA BOARD I THINK IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE FOR US AS A RECENT
HEALTHCARE ENTITY- WHERE THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT STAFF THAT'S
DOING A LOT OF WORK THAT'S
DIRECTLY NEGOTIATING. WITH
HEALTH PLANS IT'S COLLECTING
DATA THAT'S DETERMINING
ELIGIBILITY- BUT THERE ARE KEY
POLICY DECISIONS THAT WILL BOTH
THERE'S AN ASPECT OF PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY AND HAVING A
BOARD. AND HAVING PRESENTATIONS
TO THE BOARD ABOUT ALL OF THE
COMPONENTS- IN TERMS OF THE
COVER CALIFORNIA. AND NOW. NOT
REGIONAL LIKE HAVING EXPERTS IN
THE HEALTHCARE FIELD I CAN HEAR
THAT INFORMATION AND MAKE SOME
OF THE KEY HOLE SO THE CONCEPT
OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. IS THAT WE WOULD
HAVE ADEQUATE STAFFING
ECONOMISTS- TOURNEY'S
RESEARCHERS A DATA COLLECTION
EXPERTS STATE AUDITORS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING THE
DATA PIECES RIGHT THAT WE'RE
BUILDING A SYSTEM. I'M DOING
THE ACTUARIAL AND OTHER TYPES
OF ECONOMIC ANALYSIS AND- THAT
FORECASTING THAT WE NEED TO DO-
AND TO PRESENT THAT INFORMATION
TO THE BOARD BUT BUT BY VIRTUE
OF. OF PRESENTING IT TO THE
BOARD ALSO IT'S PRESENTED TO
THE PUBLIC AND THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY FOR INPUT- AND THEN
THE BOARD IS ABLE TO TAKE THAT
INFORMATION. DIRECT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT THEY MAY WANT
AND- VOTE OF FIVE MAJORITY ON
THE APPROPRIATE ECONOMIC
INDICATOR FOR THE COST TARGET
SO I THINK IT'S A- GOOD MODEL
IN TERMS OF HAVING A STAFF
EXPERTISE. WITHIN GOVERNMENT
AND THEN ALSO HAVING THE
EXPERTISE ON THE BOARD WITH A
BROADER VIEW- AND. PUBLIC AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS. THERE WAS
SOMETHING IN THE CAR USE THE
ADVISER BOARD KEEP. TO AND-
ANYTIME ALSO THE LEGISLATURE
ARE EMPOWERING NEW NON ELECTED
BOARD IT'S- HARD. FOR US TO
HAVE THE TRUST AND FAITH- BUT
KNOWING YOU AND YOUR DEPARTMENT
ON MORE THAN ABLE AND WILLING
TO WORK WITH YOU AND BE
COLLABORATIVE TO MAKE SURE
IT'S- REFLECTIVE OF ALL OF OUR
VALUES. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT ROLE IS
BETTER DEFINED AND WE HAS THE
LEGISLATURE. DID NOT ABDICATE
OUR RESPONSIBILITY- BUT STILL-HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO INTERFACE
AND PARTICIPATE IN THOSE KEY
POLICY DECISIONS AS THEY'RE
COMING POINT. SO WHERE'S THE
KEEP POLICY DECISION WILL BE TO
SET THE COST TARGET ITSELF- BUT
OF COURSE THERE ARE MANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR. FOR
DISCUSSION WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND. AND WE WILL NOT. IF
QUESTION IF I CAN ANIMAL MOVE
ON. WITH THE AGENDA- YOU YOU
HAD SAID EARLIER IT'S A- NOT A
LOW COST LOW VALUE SYSTEM AND
IT DOES NOT COME AT THE EXPENSE
OF QUALITY. SOMEONE WHO SPENT
MOST OF THEIR LIFE FIGHTING FOR
HEALTH EQUITY. IT'S- I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS WE ARE
DEVELOPING A SYSTEM THAT WE ARE
NOT SPEAKING IN THE DISPARITIES
THAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT- POPULATIONS WHO
ARE VULNERABLE OR- THAT WERE
WORKING ON THEM AND WAS HOPING
THAT YOU COULD COMMENT ON THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
REGULARLY KNOW IF YOUR
COMMITMENT IN THIS AREA- IT'S
CERTAINLY ONE THAT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND I SHARE WITH
YOU AND SO I THINK. TO BE
PERFECTLY HONEST THIS IS AN
AREA THAT NEEDS MORE
DEVELOPMENT BUT I WANT TO STATE
AT THE OUTSET THE WERE VERY
COMMITTED TO NOT LOCKING IN
INEQUITIES AND SO I THINK YOU
KNOW AS YOU'VE HEARD ME TALK
ABOUT WERE VERY CLEAR THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE CRITICAL TO
MEASURE. QUALITY AND EQUITY
METRICS ALONG THE WAY SO AGAIN
WE'RE WE'RE NOT CONTRIBUTING TO
A RACE TO THE BOTTOM WHICH IS
THE LAST THING THAT WE WANT TO
DO- BUT WHAT WE HAVEN'T EXACTLY
FIGURED OUT IS HOW NOT TO TAKE
IT AND IN EQUITY RIGHT SO IF
YOU HAVE. A MEDICAL GROUP FOR
EXAMPLE THAT IS PROVIDING VERY
FISHING CARE- THEY SAID THEY
WON'T BE LIMITED BY BY THEIR
STARTING POINT AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO START LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT WAYS OF ADDRESSING
THAT AND VERY MUCH WELCOME.
STAKEHOLDER ANOTHER STAKEHOLDER
INPUT SPECIFIC STAKEHOLDER
INPUT ON HOW TO ADDRESS THAT-
WE THINK BECAUSE THERE IS SOME
ABILITY TO SET DIFFERENT
TARGETS BY GEOGRAPHIC AREA- AND
BY SECTOR ONE PICKED COULD
IMAGINE A SCENARIO WHERE
THERE'S A PARTICULAR GEOGRAPHIC
AREA THAT HASN'T BEEN HASN'T
HAD SUFFICIENT INVESTMENT- IN
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. AND WE
WOULD WANT FOR EXAMPLE TO ALLOW
ADDITIONAL GROWTH IN THAT AREA
FOR EXAMPLE BUT VERY OPEN TO
HAVING THIS ONGOING DISCUSSION
HEARING FOLKS SPECIFIC THOUGHTS
ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. YEAH I'D LOVE
TO FOLLOW UP YOU HAD SAID
QUALITY AND EQUITY WILL COME
THROUGH PERFORMANCE METRICS AND
SO WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH
WHAT SPECIFIC METRICS YOU ALL
ARE LOOKING AT- BUT WITH THAT I
WANT TO THANK THE DIRECTOR FOR-
PRESENTING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL AND- SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY FINAL. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH.
THANK YOU DR. I YOU AND I'M
LIST CLOSELY OBVIOUSLY BE WE'RE
WORK ON THIS. BILL WELL. I WAS
I NOTED YOU SAID YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WANT THE LEGISLATURE
INVOLVED IN POLICY. YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT POLICY
DECISIONS MADE SOMEWHERE ELSE-
MY KID. THE AND THE EXPERTISE
IN THE ANALYSIS THAT WILL
HAPPEN WITH THIS DEPARTMENT- IS
SIGNIFICANT AND THESE WILL
THESEGOALS WILL NOT BE ARRIVED
AT LIGHTLY SO THE ABILITY FOR
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ANALYZE THIS AT
THAT LEVEL IS VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE UNLESS THEY'RE
WORKING HAND IN HAND ON A DAILY
BASIS WITH THIS SO THE IDEA
THAT SOMEHOW WE WOULD NEGOTIATE
AS A LEGISLATURE THESE GOALS I
THINK WOULD BE A HUGE
DISSERVICE TO THE OFFICE AND
THE EXPERTISE OF THE PEOPLE
WORKING HERE. AND POTENTIALLY
POLITICIZED AS THIS
SIGNIFICANTLY AS INDIVIDUAL
ENTITIES MIGHT DECIDE THEY
DON'T LIKE THAT GOAL AND THEY
WANT TO ENGAGE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHO DON'T KNOW EVEN
HOW THE DATA WAS EN MASSE TO
PUT THIS TOGETHER SO WE HAVE TO
BE VERY CAREFUL THAT WE DON'T
WE DON'T TIP THE SCALES. IN A
POLITICAL WAY- TO BENEFIT
CERTAIN PLAYERS OR WHOEVER
MIGHT HAVE AN ISSUE WITH WHAT'S
GOING ON I THINK THE IMPORTANT
THING HERE TO NOTE ALSO IS THAT
THIS IS NOT MEANT TO BE
PUNITIVE AND I THINK IT'S BEING
PRESENTED BY BY SOME PEOPLE WHO
ARE WHO WHO OPPOSE WHAT WE'RE
DOING OR HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING. WE NEED
PEOPLE TO BEGIN TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY AND OPERATE
DIFFERENTLY AND IF WE WERE
GOING THAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
IT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED ALREADY-
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT WASTE AND
HEALTH CARE. HUGE AMOUNTS OF
WASTE AND HEALTH CARE WE KNOW
THAT JOURNAL OF AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION POINTED
THAT OUT VERY DIRECTLY- AND SO
IF WE CAN JUST GET PEOPLE. EVEN
JUST A FOCUS ON SOME OF THAT
BENDING THE HEALTHCARE COST
CURVE COULD BE SIGNIFICANT
THERE WE GOT TO START THINKING
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT THAT. AS FAR
AS INEQUITIES TRUST ME YOU AND
I HAVE VERY VERY CHALLENGING
DISTRICTS TO REPRESENT I AM THE
LAST PERSON IN THE WORLD JUST
AS YOU. WANT ME WERE BOTH THE
LAST TWO PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
WHO WANNA DO ANYTHING. THAT
EXACERBATES ALREADY EXISTING
EQUITIES IN IN CONTRAST WE WANT
TO DO JUST THE OPPOSITE. AND
THAT'S WHY ENHANCEMENTS ON.
PRIMARY CARE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
AND REGION ALITY OURS ARE SO
CRITICAL TO THIS PROCESS AND
SO. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE HERE AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
PROCESS. THANK YOU THE OTHER
FINAL COMMENTS. WITH THAT I
WILL THANK- THIS PANEL AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM THREE
WHICH IS WITH THE SAME PANEL
THAT'S NOW ON THE PROPOSAL TO
RECAST AND MODERNIZED AUSPICE
CAN WE PLEASE BEGIN WITH
DIRECTOR LANCE BURKE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR- AS
INDICATED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET OFFICE GROWING
PORTFOLIO MAKES THE TIME TO
RECAST OPTION AND IT'S THE
DEPARTMENT. AND WE'VE GIVEN
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION TO HOW TO
DO THAT AS WELL AS REVIEWED OUR
PROGRAMS FOR AREAS WHERE WE CAN
STRENGTHEN THEM SO WHEN I FIRST
GOT THE ARCH HEAD WE- SPEND A
LOT OF TIME REVIEWING THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION REPORT. L.
A. R. REPORTS AND OTHER
ACADEMIC AND POLICY REPORTS
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE.
THANK WE ALSO DIDN'T OF
STAKEHOLDER INTERVIEWS BOTH
INTERNALLY AND EXTERNAL. THE
HOLDERS AND ALL OF THOSE INPUTS
INFORMED THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE
BEFORE YOU TODAY. AS THE FIRST
STEP QUESTION REGARDING
ARTICLES WITH THE RECAST AFTER
THE OVER ARCHING GOALS ARE TO
IMPROVE ITS EFFECTIVENESS
PROVIDING THE DATA VISION AND
PROGRAMS DEVELOPED TO DEVELOP
THE STATE'S NEEDED HELP
WORKFORCE WHICH VERY MUCH MEANS
BOTH DIVERSIFYING OUR WORKFORCE
AND MAKING SURE WE HAVE
INCREASED WORKFORCE. IN UNDER A
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS
WERE ALSO LOOKING FOR. OUR DATA
SYSTEMS. A CLEAR VIEW ONE WORD
FROM THE STAKEHOLDER INTERVIEWS
OUR CONSULTANT CONDUCTED.
STAKEHOLDERS WANT TO SEE OFFICE
SERVING AS A CONVENER AND
THOUGHT LEADER ON HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN THAT
ROLE ON HEALTHCARE ACCESS THAT
INFORMATION. THEY'RE JUST GOING
THROUGH EACH OF THE SPECIFIC-
COMPONENTS OF OUR PROPOSAL THE
FIRST IS TO RECAST AND EXPAND
THE CURRENT HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE CLEARING HOUSE AS THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH WORKFORCE
RESEARCH AND DATA CENTER- WE
HAVE NOT HAD THE DATA THAT WE
NEED IT IN CALIFORNIA TO REALLY
ADEQUATELY ANALYZE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE THAT WAS NOTED AND-
UCSF- POLICY REPORT FOR
EXAMPLE- WE PROPOSE REQUIRING
ALL HEALTH LICENSING BOARDS. TO
COLLECT OF COURSE THAT A
FEDERALLY RECOMMENDED DATA
ELEMENTS FOR HEALTH WORKFORCE
ANALYSIS- WERE AWARE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TAKING HAS A
BILL WITH A SIMILAR CALL. THE
RESEARCH AND DATA CENTER WOULD
TAKE THAT DATA- AND OTHER DATA
INPUTS. TO PROVIDE TIMELIER AND
BETTER DATA AND ANALYSIS TO
INFORM STATE POLICY REGARDING
ISSUES OF WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
EQUITY AND DISTRIBUTION AS WELL
AS PROVIDING DATA TO THE NEW
OFFICE HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY
IF IT'S APPROVED AND H. P.
PROGRAM. THE RESOURCES
REQUESTED HERE WILL ALLOW US TO
PERFORM VALUABLE TESTING OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OSMAN'S
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS AND INFORM
POLICY. AND PROGRAMMATIC
DECISIONS. AND THEN TURNING
NECK TO THE MIDDLE OF ACTUAL
FOR- WE WOULD STREAMLINE. OUR
FROM AT INSTEAD A NEW SINGLE
STATEWIDE CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING COUNCIL IN LIEU OF OUR
CURRENT HEALTH PROFESSIONS
EDUCATION FOUNDATION. AND THE
SONG BROWN COMMISSION. SO WE'RE
SEEKING EFFICIENCY AND
OPERATING OUR PROGRAMS- BUT
PROGRAMS CURRENTLY RUN FIRE
FOUNDATION TO SWITCH TO RUNNING
THOSE PROGRAMS INTERNALLY WHILE
MAINTAINING THE LICENSING
REVENUE STREAMS BUT
DISCONTINUING THE NONPROFIT
FOUNDATION COMPONENTS. AND WE
ARE PROPOSING TO TRANSITION THE
CURRENT SONG BROWN COMMISSION
TO A NEW HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING COUNCIL.
THE COUNCIL WOULD PROVIDE
GUIDANCE ON STATEWIDE EDUCATION
AND HEALTH WORKFORCE TRAINING
NEEDS ACROSS KEY AREAS
INCLUDING GENERAL POSITION
EDUCATIONAL PRIMARY CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AND WOULD
ADVISE ON INCREASING THE SUPPLY
AND DIVERSITY OF BOTH PHYSICIAN
AND NON PHYSICIAN PROVIDERS AS
WELL AS THE PLACEMENT OF
PROVIDERS IN MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS. SO THIS
WOULD INCLUDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO NEW RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS AND MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE THE
STATE'S WORKFORCE PROGRAMS AND
I WANT TO KNOW THAT THIS WOULD
IMPLEMENT ONE OF THE TOP TEN
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA FUTURE
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION.
THE DEPARTMENT WILL CONSIDER
THE COUNCIL POLICY- DIRECTION
AS WE ADMINISTER OUR WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS. THE CURRENT BOARD AND
COMMISSION PROVIDE DIRECTION ON
A SUBSET OF OFFICE PROGRAMS
MEETING THAT TODAY NO ONE
ENTITY HAS BEEN ANALYZING-
ADVISING ON THE ENTIRE UNIVERSE
OF OUR PROGRAMS WERE
COORDINATING WITH OTHER STATE
ENTITIES. SO WE'RE EXCITED TO-
TO MAINTAIN ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS- BUT HAVE A NEW
UNIFIED ADVISORY BODY INSTEAD
OF THE CURRENT MORE FRACTURED
APPROACH. NEXT FOR PROPOSING TO
INTEGRATE THE STATE OFFICE OF
RURAL HEALTH AND THE J. ONE
VISA WAIVER PROGRAM INTO OFFICE
PRIMARY CARE OFFICE- THIS WOULD
PROVIDE A CENTRALIZED AND
BETTER BETTER TARGETED APPROACH
TO WORKING WITH RURAL
COMMUNITIES ON THEIR HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
NEEDS. AND WE WOULD DO SO WITH
FEWER STAFF BY LEVERAGING OUR
EXISTING PRIMARY CARE OFFICE
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN ADDITION OUR
EXPERTISE MAKES US WELL SUITED
TO ADMINISTER THE J. ONE VISA
PROGRAM WHICH ASSISTS DOCTORS
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES IN
OBTAINING A J. ONE VISA WAIVER
TO PRACTICE MEDICINE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE ALSO
PROPOSING TO STRENGTHEN SEVERAL
OF OUR DATA PROGRAMS- WE'RE
PROPOSING TO UPDATE OUR
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COST
TRANSPARENCY STATUE SB
SEVENTEEN. TO ADD DATA POINTS
THAT HELP IDENTIFY THE
THERAPEUTIC TYPE OF DRUG
FACTORS DESCRIBING THE REASON
FOR A PRICE INCREASE REASONS
FOR NOT DISCLOSING INFORMATION
AND CLEAR AUTHORITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO ASSESS REPORTING
FOR COMPLETENESS. WE'RE ALSO
PROPOSING TO IMPROVE DATA
QUALITY AND COMPLETENESS BY
CLARIFYING DEFINITIONS AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR REPORTING AND
ADDING INFORMATION TO SUPPORT
COMPARISONS OF BRAND VERSUS
GENERIC DRUGS- WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING TO AMEND THE STATUTES
PERTAINING TO CORONARY ARTERY
BYPASS GRAFT OUTCOMES.
REPORTING TO PROVIDE. US BETTER
AND THE NEW DEPARTMENT OF THE
FLEXIBILITY TO PERFORM OUTCOMES
REPORTING FOR NEW AND EMERGING
CARDIAC PROCEDURES SUCH AS
TRANSCATHETER AORTIC VALVE
REPLACEMENT. AND THEN LASTLY
WE'RE LOOKING TO UPDATE
STATUTES PERTAINING TO VITAL
STATISTICS TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING BIRTH AND DEATH DATA-
IN A TIMELY AND EFFICIENT
MANNER SO THAT WE CAN DO THE
PUBLIC REPORTING AND RESEARCH.
SUCH AS ANALYSIS OF MATERNAL
QUALITY OF CARE AND INPATIENT
MORTALITY. AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST FOR US- AS WE GRADUATE TO
THE DEPARTMENT WE PROPOSED A
NAME CHANGE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
INFORMATION. SO WE THINK WITH
THE ADDITION OF THE NEW DATA
PROGRAMS ARE EXPANSION OUR
WORKFORCE- THAT OUR CURRENT
NAME DOESN'T REFLECT OUR
MERGING HEALTH POLICY
LEADERSHIP ROLE. SO WE CAN BE
MORE DESCRIPTIVE NAMES IS THAT
PART OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
INFORMATION OR H. KAIT- THE
DEPARTMENT'S WORK INCENTIVIZE
ACTS WITH HEALTH CARE. ACCESS
TO SAFE HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
TO AN ADEQUATE WORKFORCE THAT
MEETS CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS TO
AFFORDABLE QUALITY CARE. TO
FINANCING FOR HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES AND COLLECTING AND
PROVIDING ACCESS TO IMPORTANT
INFORMATION ABOUT HEALTHCARE
OUTCOMES FACILITIES WORKFORCE
AND FINANCE. SO THAT'S THE
OVERVIEW. ARE WE CAN. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM CORY
HARSHA WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR REGULATORY ISSUE TO FROM
THE ILIO- WE JUST HAVE A FEW
BRIEF COMMENTS ON THIS PROPOSED
NEW DEPARTMENT- GENERALLY WE
DON'T HAVE MAJOR CONCERNS TO
RAISE WITH THE RECASTING OF OUR
SPEND JUST A FEW CONSIDERATIONS
TO BRING UP YOU KNOW WE FIND
THAT THE GOALS OF ESTABLISHING
NEW DEPARTMENT- WHICH ARE
GENERALLY TO ESTABLISH AN
APARTMENT WITH A STRONGER
CAPACITY FOR BOTH. RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION OF STATE HELP
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE USE AND
AFFORDABILITY CONCERNS MAKES
SENSE. ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
ADDITION OF THE PROPOSED OFFICE
OF AFFORDABILITY DISCUSSED
EARLIER- FURTHERMORE WE FIND AT
THIS OFFICE DOES PREVENT AND-
DOES PRESENT AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO. ALL THE
ADMINISTRATION MORE ACCOUNTABLE
ON ISSUES RELATED TO HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AFFORDABILITY IN
THE COLLECTION OF HEALTH
INFORMATION- THIS IS
PARTICULARLY THE CASE FOR
WORKFORCE RELATED ISSUES-
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT ENTITIES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- WHICH ALSO WORK
ON THESE ISSUES. I WHICH
INDICATE THAT THE PROPOSAL
WOULDN'T FULLY CONSOLIDATE THIS
RESPONSIBILITY INTO ONE
DEPARTMENT. WITH THIS RECASTING
THE NEW DEPARTMENT WOULD
PRESENT ITSELF AS A CENTRAL
POINT OF CONTACT TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THESE ISSUES
WHICH MAY HELP FACILITATE
ACCOUNTABILITY. ESPECIALLY IN
RECEIVING EVALUATION MATERIALS
FROM THE NEW DEPARTMENT-
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATURE MAY
ALSO WISH TO MONITOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS. NEW
DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE THAT IT
DOES- IN FACT- END UP HAVING
ACCESS TO. IMPROVED EVALUATION
MATERIALS- AS A RESULT OF THAT-
PROPOSED ADDITIONAL DATA
COLLECTION CAPABILITIES IN THIS
DEPARTMENT- THOSE ARE ALL OF
OUR OFFICES COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME AND HAPPY TO PROVIDE
FURTHER ASSISTANCE WHERE NEEDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH THAT I
WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. C. NON I WILL ASK IF
I CAN- DIRECTOR LANDSBERG I'M
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING COUNCIL
I'VE BEEN. VERY INTERESTED IN
TRACKING HOW THE DEPARTMENT
MEASURES OUTCOMES AND HEALTH%
CARE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. AND
I'M HOPING THAT YOU COULD
COMMENT ON HOW THIS CAN
ACTUALLY INCREASE OR DIVERSIFY
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALSO WON A CALL AND
KAREN MYSELF MY DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF WORK FORCE- TO ADD PIECES
CHáVEZ BUT I THINK THE FIRST
PIECE TO NOW IS THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE THE DATA THAT WE NEED
TODAY. TO DO THE EVALUATION DO
DO THE PROGRAMMATIC EVALUATION
THAT WE WANT TO DO- IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS NEED AT
EVERY LEVEL RIGHT WE NEED TO.
HELP OUR KIDS IN MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND HIGH SCHOOL GET THE
ADVANCED SCIENCE CLASSES THAT
THEY NEED TO GET INTERESTED IN
IN THE HEALTH CARE- PROFESSIONS
ALL THE WAY UP TO PROVIDING
SUPPORT FOR RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
BUT I DO WANT TO GIVE- GIVE ME
DIRECTOR. RIGHT NOW AN
OPPORTUNITY IT TO GET MORE A IN.
AS WELL. I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS KAREN RIGHT SO- IF YOU
DIRECTOR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION I SPENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AS
DIRECTOR LANDSBERG MENTIONED I
MEAN THIS THE- HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING COUNCIL
WAS ESTABLISHED TO. BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE GOVERNANCE AND
OVERSIGHT OVER THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE EDUCATION TRAINING-
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
ADVANCED PRACTICE SIX CENTER
AND ONE OF THE GOALS OF THE
COUNCIL IS REALLY TO EIGHT TO
LOOK AT DATA- THAT THAT- BIG
NEW- HELLO CAN HELP WORK FOR
RESEARCH DATA SAID WILL PROVIDE.
THAT WERE HELP THE THAT GOV
COUNCIL BE ABLE TO SET GOALS
AND AS WE LOOK AT DIVERSIFYING.
AND EXPANDING THE- THE SUPPLY
OF PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANSWER AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING ABLE TO
WORK WITH YOUR DEPARTMENT AS WE
ARE ENTERING INTO BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE COULD NOT
MANUFACTURE ENOUGH PROVIDERS TO
TAKE CARE OF US DURING THIS
CRISIS HADN'T REALLY LOOKED TO
YOUR DEPARTMENT TO HELP US TO
SOLVE THAT ISSUE AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATIONS WE
CAN HAVE OVER THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS. WITH THAT WE WILL. THANK
VERY MUCH THIS PANEL AND MOVE
ON TO PANEL FOR ON ANNUAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLAN HEALTH
EQUITY AND QALITY REVIEWS. WE
WILL HAVE SEVEN PRESENTERS ON
THIS PANEL INCLUDING MERRY
WATANABE AND SOUTHARD. THE
DIRECTOR AND CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE. AS WELL AS
WILL LIGHT BORN IN TRACY COOPER
WITH THE DIRECTOR AND STATE
MEDICAID DIRECTOR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. BEN JOHNSON WITH THE
L. A. O. DIANA DOUGLAS WITH
HEALTH ACCESS AND KERRY SANDERS
WITH C. PAN. CAN WE PLEASE
BEGAN WITH DIRECTOR WATANABE. A
GOOD AFTERNOON MERRY WATCH NOT
BE DIRECTOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK. YES MA'AM PLEASE
CONTINUE OKAY GREAT YES I'LL
I'LL GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
HERE AND WITH ME TODAY IS DANCE
OTHER CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR-
I'LL START WITH AN OVERVIEW OF
THE PROPOSAL- THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED
LONGSTANDING HEALTH INEQUITIES
SEEN AMONG PEOPLE OF COLOR. THE
PANDEMIC IS ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION THAT IT'S
CREATED SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND
HEALTH INEQUITIES GRINCH
CONTRIBUTING TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGHER
INFECTION AND MORTALITY RATES.
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING HEALTH INEQUITIES
AND IS PROPOSING STATUTORY
CHANGES TO AUTHORIZE THE DMH C.
TO ESTABLISH AND ENFORCE THE
PRIORITY SET OF HEALTH EQUITY
IN QUALITY MEASURES. INCLUDING
SETTING ANNUAL HEALTHEQUITY IN
QUALITY BENCHMARK STANDARDS AND
ENFORCING HEALTH PLAN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE
STANDARDS. THE PROPOSED
STRUCTURE CHANGES WOULD APPLY
TO FULL SERVICE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PLANS LICENSE BY THE DMH
CD. INCLUDING HEALTH PLANS THAT
CONTRACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES TO PRIVATE
TO PROVIDE HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
TO MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES. THE
PROPOSED OUT GEORGE. AB
FOLLOWING NUMBER. DO YOU MAKES
THE BOOK BE AND HOW EQUITY AND
QUALITY COMMITTEE IN THE FIRST
HALF OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. TO
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT ON A PRIORITY SET OF
STANDARD HEALTHEQUITY QUALITY
MEASURES AND ANNUAL BENCHMARKS.
EQUALITY COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
INCLUDE STATE DEPARTMENTS
PURCHASERS CONSUMER ADVOCATES
HEALTHCARE SERVICE PLAN
REPRESENTATIVES. PROVIDER
REPRESENTATIVES THOSE WITH
EXPERTISE IN QUALITY
MEASUREMENT AND EXPERTISE IN
HEALTH EQUITY AND DISPARITIES
IN HEALTH CARE DELIVERY AND
OTHER ENTITIES THAT'S
APPROPRIATE. THE GMC WILL
CONDUCT WITH AN EXTERNAL
CONSULTANT WITH EXPERTISE IN
THE SUBJECT AREA TO ASSIST THE
DEPARTMENT IN PLANNING
ORGANIZING AND FACILITATING THE
COMMITTEE MEETINGS. BASED ON
THE COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATIONS
THE DAMAGE HE WILL STOP WHAT
YOUR PRIORITIES SET OF QUALITY
MEASURES AND HEALTH EQUITY
QUALITY BENCHMARKS FOR OFFER A
FULL SERVICE AND BE ABLE HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLANS. THE PLANS
WILL ANNUALLY SUBMIT A REPORT
CONTAINING DATA AND INFORMATION
ON THE CAREER PRIORITY SET OF
MEASURES AN ANNUAL BENCHMARKS
TO THE DEPARTMENT BEGINNING A
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. FOUR
MEASUREMENT YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THE DAMAGE THEY WILL
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS AND
TAKE ENFORCEMENT ACTION WHEN
HEALTHEQUITY QUALITY BENCHMARKS
ARE NOT MET. THIS INCLUDES
MONITORING CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLANS AN IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS
WERE NEEDED AND TAKING
PROGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT ACTION
AGAINST NON COMPLIANT HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLANS AS
APPROPRIATE. THE DEPARTMENT
WILL PRODUCE AN ANNUAL HEALTH
EQUITY IN QUALITY COMPLIANCE
REPORT WITH INFORMATION ON
THOSE FINDINGS BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. WE'LL MAKE
CHANGES TO THE HEALTH ACCORDING
QUALITY MEASURES AN ANNUAL
BENCHMARKS UNTIL THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE CODIFIED
REGULATIONS. IN ADDITION THE
PLANTS AND THEIR SUBCONTRACTORS
HEALTH PLANS WILL BE REQUIRED
TO OBTAIN AND MAINTAIN NATIONAL
COMMITTEE FOR QUALITY ASSURANCE
OR NCQA ACCREDITATION BY
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. DH CS WILL COORDINATE WITH
THE MHD TO CONDUCT SIMILAR WORK
FOR COUNTY ORGANIZED HEALTH
SYSTEMS THAT ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO OBTAIN AN OX KING LICENSE.
WROTE THE DEVELOPMENT ND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROPOSAL
BUT YOU MIGHT SEE WILL
COLLABORATE WITH OUR SPIN DH CS
COVERED CALIFORNIA CALPERS AND
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. IN
ESTABLISHING A PER SET OF
STANDARD QUALITY MEASURES AND
BENCHMARKS. DMH THE REQUEST THE
FOLLOWING POSITIONS
EXPENDITURES ARE UP ALREADY
FROM THE MANAGED CARE FUND TO
ESTABLISH AND ENFORCE HEALTH
EQUITY QUALITY STANDARDS FOR
ALL DAMAGE THE LICENSE FULL
SERVICE AND BEHAVE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PLANS- THIS INCLUDES TWO
POSITIONS ARE NOT NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND AND FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. TWO
POSITIONS AND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY ONE THOUSAND FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
FIFTEEN POSITIONS AND THREE
MILLION FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR.
NINETEEN AND A HALF POSITIONS
IN APPROXIMATELY FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. AND
TWENTY FOUR TO HAVE POSITIONS
AN APPROXIMATE SIX MILLION IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
THIS REQUEST INCLUDES FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FOR
CONSULTANT SERVICES TO ASSIST
WITH THE PLANNING ORGANIZING
AND FACILITATING OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND PROVIDES THE
DEPARTMENT ON SETTING THE
MEASURES AND BENCHMARKS. THIS
ALSO INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FOR
CLINICAL CONSULTING SERVICES TO
ASSIST IN INTERPRETING DATA.
AND DETERMINING TRENDS RELATED
TO REDUCING HEALTH DISPARITIES
AND IMPROVING. THE QUALITY OF
CARE DELIVERED. AT MY- OVERVIEW
I DID KNOW IF YOU WANT TO GO IN
ADDRESS THE OTHER CAN REQUESTS
OR WEAKENED. TAKE QUESTIONS OF
PEPTIC QUESTIONS FIRST. WHAT
CONTINUE THROUGH THE PANEL AND
THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO THAT IF
WE CAN NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
DIRECTOR LIGHT BORN INTERESTED
COOPER. ALL AND THE- MATH
COOPER WILL LEAD FOR US ON THIS
ONE THE FUTURE. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE. COOPER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I'M SO THE MAIN PIECE
THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO
ADDRESS- IN THE HEARING TWO
DAYS ARE WALL REGARDING BE NON
COP KNOCKS KEEN LICENSE
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OVERSEES THE
COUNTY OPERATED HEALTH SYSTEM
FOR WITH THOSE PLANS WHICH ARE
NOT THAT KNOCKS KEEN LICENSE
HEALTH PLANS. WHICH HE DOES NOT
OVERSEE THE COAST PLANS THAT WE
WILL WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
MHC UP WITH REGARD TO THIS
POLICY PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT
IT IS ALSO APPLIED TO THE COAST
PLANS TO THE DEPARTMENT WILL
COORDINATE WITH YOU MAKES YOU
TO WORK WITH OPPOSE PLANS TO
CONNECT AND BE A CONSISTENT
WITH THIS POLICY WITH ALSO
INCLUDE ANY CONTRACT LANGUAGE
INTO THEIR CONTRACT TO BE
CONSISTENT ACROSS ALL AS WELL
AS WORK WITH THEN ON
IMPLEMENTING THE QUALITY
MEASURES THAT ARE DECIDED. AS
WELL AS ANY SUBSEQUENT ACTIONS
THAT WOULD BE INCLUDED AS
MENTIONED BY THE DIRECTOR OF
HER PREVIOUS COMMENTS AROUND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE INCENTIVES
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS OR
SANCTIONS THAT ARE ENFORCED
THROUGH THE DMX DECIDE WOULD
THAT BE DONE THROUGH THE DH CS
SIDE FOR THE CODES PLANS OF AND
HAPPY TO TAKE. ANY QUESTIONS
WHEN IT IS. THANK YOU MAX WE
WILL HEAR FROM JOHN WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ALL OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BEN JOBS WITH
THE L. A. O. WE SUPPORT THE
GOALS BUT THAT UNDERLIES THIS
SPEECH G. P. AND SPECIFICALLY
FIND THAT MEASURING REPORTING
AND HOLDING HEALTH PLANS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
PERFORMANCE AGAINST QUALITY IN
EQUITY STANDARDS CAN DRIVE.
FRIEDMAN IN THE SYSTEM. WOULD
NOTE QUICKLY THAT THERE THERE
ARE SYNERGIES BETWEEN THIS
PROPOSAL AND OTHER EFFORTS JOB
RECEIVING. LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION INCLUDING OTHER
PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION EXAMPLE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
CREATE AT HEALTHEQUITY
DASHBOARD AS WELL AS THE- THE-
DH YES IN- REFORM EFFORT IN
MEDIC CAL I'VE NOTICED CAL AIM.
IN SEPARATE REPORT ON ON CAL
AND WE DID RECOMMEND THAT-
REPORTING- AND COLLECTION OF A
NUMBER OF HEALTH OUTCOME
MEASURES THAT WOULD BE SPECIFIC
TO THE MEDIC CAL POPULATION IN
THAT INSTANCE BUT- COULD
POTENTIALLY BE A CONSIDERATION-
FOR BROADER COLLECTION. HELD
BACK HEALTHEQUITY AND-
PERFORMANCE MEASURE- COLLECTION
AND REPORTING- WE DO RECKON
BENEFACTOR REALLY THE SPECIFICS
OF THE BGP WE DO RECOGNIZE
THAT- THE CARRYING OUT THESE
ACTIVITIES WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT UNDERTAKING
ESPECIALLY AT THE IMAGE THE
WHICH HAVEN'T HISTORICALLY DONE
A LOT OF HELP- HELP QUALITY-
DATA COLLECTIONS UNTIL WE DON'T
HAVE CONCERNS- WITH THE- WITH
THE RESOURCE REQUEST OR THE
PROPOSED STATUTORY CHANGES AT
THIS TIME. WE JUST RECOMMEND
CONTINUES LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS
TO DEVELOP THE PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS AND THE PROPHECIES
THAT- OPEN AT THE ADOPTED TO
MONITOR REPORT AND ENFORCE THE
NEW. EQUITY QUALITY MEASURES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WE WILL HEAR DIANE DOUGLAS
WITH HEALTH ACCESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON DIANA DOUGLAS ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATEWIDE HEALTH
CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION HEALTH ACCESS
SUPPORTS THE CREATION OF A
STANDARDIZED SET OF QUALITY IN
EQUITY METRICS FOR HEALTH PLANS
IN BOTH THE COMMERCIAL AND
MEDIKAL MANAGED CARE MARKETS.
WE EE SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL TO
HOLDER HEALTH SYSTEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR MORE EQUITABLE
HEALTH OUTCOMES WITH THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE
STANDARDIZED MEASURES AS A
SPONSOR OF THE LEGISLATION THAT
CREATED THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE OVER TWO
DECADES AGO WE AGREE THAT
UPDATING DMH SEES MISSION TO
FOCUS NOT JUST ON ACCESS. TO
QUALITY AND EQUITY WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL CONSUMER ADVOCATES
HAVE WORKED IT TOUGH COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND MEDIC HOW TO
REQUIRE INDUSTRY IMPROVEMENTS
IN HEALTH OUTCOMES AND REDUCING
RACIAL AND ETHNIC. AND AS A
REGULATOR TO ENCOURAGE THIS
SYSTEM TRANSFORMATION. HOWEVER
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE
TBL AS WRITTEN WELL
INDIFFERENTLY FREEZE IN PLACE A
SET OF MEASURES RATHER THAN
ALLOWING FOR UPDATES OVER TIME
THE REGULATORY PROCESS OFTEN
TAKES A NUMBER OF YEARS AND
REGULATIONS ARE RARELY
REVISITED ONCE FINAL. THE FIELD
OF HEALTH QUALITY AND EQUITY
METRICS IS DYNAMIC AND CHANGING
AS SCIENCE FINDS NEW WAYS TO
BEST MEASURE HEALTH OUTCOMES
FOR TODAY WE MIGHT MEASURE
DIABETES MANAGEMENT OR CAME A
GLOBAL LEVELS BUT WILL THAT
REMAINS AND OR TWENTY YEARS
TIME. OUR HEALTH PRIORITIES AND
UNDER OF HEALTH EQUITY ALL
CHANGE MANY OF THE NEXT HE IS
RATHER LGBT COMMUNITY WHERE
RECKONED EVEN A JACKET A- AND
BLACK MATERNAL IN INFANT HEALTH
HAS BEEN VERY. AS WE CAN THE BY
WITHIN OUR HEALTH. ALSO NEW
CHALLENGES ONYX SUCH AS THAT
NINETY CONDEMNED THAT MAYBE
FUTURE MEASURES STUDY THE LONG
TERM. TO FACILITATE UPDATING
THE METRICS TIME WE SUGGEST THE
MEASURE MEASURES AFTER
APPEARING OF FIVE YEARS WITH
OUR YOU CAN UP ASSESSED OF THE
MEASURE PRIOR TO THIS. IN ORDER
TO SEE THEIR CAN. WE ALSO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL AMEND
SUGGEST FROM THE CAN AT THE CAN
TO ENSURE THE MEASURE IN THE BY
WHICH THEIR TERM. PRIORITIZE A
REFLECT THE NEEDS OF DIVERSE.
WE IN SUPPORT OF THE GOAL AND
OVER OF THE TV ELBIT YOU FEEL
THE CHANGES ARE WE ARE SUCH ARE
TO ENSURE THE MEASURES ARE
EFFECTIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
AND I'M HAPPY ANSWER ANY. THANK
YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
SANDERS WITH C. PAN. AFTERNOON
I. CARROTS AND ON BEHALF OF
THAT. PAN ETHNIC NETWORK. OF
THE STATE WIDE MORE. HELP OUT
THE OR- DATA. TO PROMOTING
HEALTH EQUITY TWO. COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. AND THE SPONSORED
BILLS I. BY ASSEMBLY. RAN AND
SENATOR. IMPROVE AND BEHAVIOR
HEALTH. IN A- FROM. BEEN WITH.
SUPPORT AND AGREE WITH THE OVER
APPROACH DID MANAGE. OF TO
ENSURE PROPER- OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNT. OVER HEALTH BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PLAN. FOR MEETING
QUALITY AND I PUT GOLD.
CALIFORNIA HAS STRONG CONSUMER.
IN STATE LAW. BUT WIDE
VARIATION. BETWEEN AND- THE.
DESPITE YEARS OF EFFORT HEALTH
NET PLAN INCORRECT MET OFTEN
CAN. MANY FALLS UNDER THE BAY
INCLUDING THE PREVENT OF
LANGUAGE THAT THE SERVICES.
ENSURING TIMELY SPECIALTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CARE. CENTER
QUALITY IN A MATCH ACROSS
ENTIRE STATE REGULATED COME
MARC. AND MEDICAL. THE CRITICAL
THAT THE COULD HELP IMPROVE IN
OF CARE FROM NINE OF CAL.
HOWEVER WE HAVE CONCERNS IN
RECOMMEND FROM TO THE TRAILER
BILL. THE CONFIG IMPROVE AND
FOR CONSUMER. WE ALONG WITH L.
ACCESS ANOTHER. THE PER FUNDS
OUT OF THE MEASURE AFTER PERIOD
OF YEARS. THIS IS NOTHING TO
ENSURE THE MEASURES. ARE INDEED
EQUITY INTO GOAL WHILE ALLOWING
ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY THE TO
REVIVE AND OR ADOPT A- MEASURES
OF THE FEEL OF QUALITY IN
EQUITY MEASURE. OF BECAUSE
MEDIC HELD THE CANNELLA ADDRESS
HEALTH. COMPLIANCE OF BOTH
COMMERCIAL AND PUBLIC PLAN
TODAY AT TO THE IT'S A REPORT.
WE'VE ADDITIONAL SUGGESTIONS TO
ENSURE PLAN TO ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSING THE CONTINUED
DISCRIMINATION IN POOR HEALTH
OUTCOMES. IF I CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
INCLUDING LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
TRANSGENDER AND QUEER
INDIVIDUALS. THANK YOU HEALTH
INDICATORS- BY- INCLUDING
ENSURING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIANS AND INCLUDE
EXPERTS RESEARCHERS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS MORE ENGAGED
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES. TO
MEASURING HEALTHEQUITY.
CONSUMER EXPERIENCE AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES. THE TAKE IN THE FACT
THAT ACCOUNT FACTORED SUCH AS
CO COMP. OF LETTERS THE
EXPOSURE TO DISCRIMINATE. AND
THE GROWING BODY OF RESEARCH
FROM THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY ON THE BENEFITS OF
SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
CONNECTEDNESS. AND THE IMPACT
ON HEALTH OUTCOME. ALTHOUGH OUR
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDE
ENSURING THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ADDRESS REAL DEFICIENCIES AND
HEALTH PLAN COLLECTION
REPORTING OF RACE ETHNICITY
LANGUAGE SEXUAL ORIENTATION
GENDER RIGHT IDENTITY DATA IN
ORDER TO PROPERLY IDENTIFY AND
ACT ON DISPARITIES FOR SMALLER
SUBPOPULATION INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO LGBTQ PLUS AN ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES.
FINALLY ENCOURAGING COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATION TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT MEASURES THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH SUCH AS
HOUSING SECURITY FOOD
INSECURITY AT CARE GIVING IN
OTHER AT NON MEDICAL
DETERMINANTS WHICH I'VE ALSO
BEEN SHOWN TO POSITIVELY IMPACT
HEALTH OUTCOMES. BETTER HEALTH
PLAN OVERSIGHT IS A
PRECONDITION FOR EFFECTIVE
INNOVATION AND HEALTH CARE
PAYMENT SYSTEM TRANSFORMATION
STRENGTHENING DAMAGES ACCORDING
TO REGULATE AND OVERSEE PLAN
COMPLIANCE WITH QUALITY IN
EQUITY GOLD IS A CRITICAL STEP
TOWARDS ENSURING CONSUMERS CAN
ACCESS QUALITY AFFORDABLE
HEALTH. AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WE SUPPORT THE
GOALS OF THE AN OVERALL
APPROACH TO THE TBL BUT BUILT
THE CHANGES ARE REQUIRED TO
ENSURE THE MEASURES ARE
EFFECTIVE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MISS AND BEFORE I GET TO
MEMBERS QUESTIONS I'M GONNA
ASK- THAT WE OPEN THE ROLE TO
THE ITEMS THAT WE HAD BROUGHT
UP BEFORE. AND JUST AS A
REMINDER OF CURRENTLY. ON PART
A OF THE AGENDA HAVE BATCH TO
ITEMS NUMBER TWENTY THREE SIXTY
THREE- CAN WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MATHIS FIVE. PATTERSON I.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
THE PART B. OF THE AGENDA WE'LL
GO TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
OF PART B. CAN WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MATHIS- PATTERSON NOT
VOTING. WE WILL FINALLY NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
THREE OF PART B. CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MATHIS NO.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING. THANK YOU
WITHOUT A WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK UP. SO ALL- ALL. THANK YOU
OUR FINAL VOTE WILL NOW BE ON
THE REMAINDER OF THE ITEMS FOR
PART B. WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
ITEMS TWENTY EIGHT AND THIRTY
THREE CAN WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MATHIS BY PATTERSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
WITH THAT WE WILL BRING IT BACK
UP TO THE DIESS FOR OUR PANEL
NUMBER FOUR AND SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. YOU SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS I WILL- TAKEN
OPPORTUNITY IF I CAN'T ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THEIR
POSITION ON THE SUNSET THAT IS
BEING RECOMMENDED BY MANY OF
THE CONSUMER ADVOCACY GROUPS.
HI THIS IS THIS IS MERRY
WATANABE- AGAIN DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE- I WILL SAY I THINK THAT
WE INITIALLY THOUGHT THAT WHAT
WAS BEING PROPOSED WAS THREE
YEARS WHICH GAVE US SOME
CONCERNS BECAUSE IT POTENTIALLY
WOULD HAVE BEEN- WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN BEEN RE EVALUATED THE
MEASURES WITH ONLY ONE YEAR
WORTH OF DATA- WERE SUPPORTER
BOTH OF THE- RECOMMENDATION
THAT WE HEARD TODAY FIVE YEARS-
THAT WILL GIVE US MORE TIME TO
EVALUATE THE DATA THAT'S COME
IN AND LOOK AT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND- I WILL SECCO THE NEED
FOR US TO MAKE SURE THAT ARE
MANAGED. MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANS ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS- BUT WITH THAT
I WILL THANK VERY MUCH PANEL
FOR WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PANEL FIVE ON TELEHEALTH. WE
WILL HAVE. EIGHT SPEAKERS ON
THIS PANEL INCLUDING WILL LIGHT
BORN IN JC COOPER WITH T. H. C.
S. COREY HOW SHEILA WITH THE L.
A. O. DOCTOR GANGA. HE MIGHT TO
LUCKY WITH THE UNITED HEALTH
CENTERS OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. ROBERT BARDIA WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD CALIFORNIA
CENTRAL COAST DAVID FORD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. AND. LET'S BEGIN
WITH DIRECTOR LET POINT. YEAH-
THE PETER COOPER'S QUICKLY DONE
THIS. FOR ALL. SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS PRESENTED OUR
TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL BROADLY TO
THIS GROUP- A FEW TIMES I'M NOT
GOING TO GO OVER THE ENTIRE
PROPOSAL AGAIN- BUT DO YOU
THINK THAT WE HAVE THE FOUR
DIVISIONS THAT INCLUDE
MODIFICATIONS AND OR EXPANSION
OF THE USE OF SYNCHRONOUS
TELEHEALTH ASYNCHRONOUS
TELEHEALTH TELEPHONIC AUDIO
ONLY OTHER VIRTUAL
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS AND TO
ADD REMOTE PATIENT MONITORING
TO THE GREATER. ALIGNING
STANDARDIZED ACROSS ALL OF OUR
DELIVERY SYSTEMS ARE WE HAVE
PUBLICLY PROVIDED A PRETTY
EXTENSIVE PROPOSAL AT THAT
PEOPLE COULD REFERENCE- IN
REGARDS TO STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS
WE DO KNOW THAT THE LARGEST
CONCERN THAT HAS BEEN RAISED TO
THE DEPARTMENT IS IN REGARDS TO
A LACK OF PAYMENT PARITY FOR
AUDIO ONLY SERVICES SO ARE
PROPOSAL DOES. THAT WE WERE
ALLOW FOR ONLY BE PROVIDED AND
DON AT U. H. C. A. R.
ENVIRONMENTS AT AN ALTERNATIVE
A FEE SCHEDULE I'M STILL NOT IN
PAYMENT CARRY WITH AN IN PERSON
VISIT- IN THAT WE HAVE ENGAGED
IN CONVERSATIONS AROUND-
ALTERNATIVES TO CONSIDER UP FOR
OUR FQHC PARTNERS OF THE THAT
IS THE MAIN. PIECE THAT HAS
KIND OF BEEN RAISED TO THE
DEPARTMENT AROUND PAYMENT
PARITY I THINK YOU KNOW AS A
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN HAVING A
LARGE NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS
WITH. BOTH YOU KNOW PHYSICIANS
FQHCS OF VARIOUS HEALTH SYSTEMS
WE'VE BEEN TAKING A LOT OF
FEEDBACK IN A TO EVALUATE THE
GIVEN THE UNDERLYING KIND OF
INTENT LEVEL OF CARE PROVIDED
VIA TELEPHONIC AUDIO ON THE
MODALITIES ON THERE ARE
LIMITATIONS ON THE TYPES OF
SERVICES AND THE QUALITY THAT
CAN BE ACHIEVED FOR YOUR AUDIO
ONLY SERVICES. ADDITIONALLY ARE
YOU ONLY SERVICES DO NOT
REQUIRE THE SAME LEVEL OF
RESOURCES TO MANAGE- THERE ARE-
NOT SPECIAL EQUIPMENT OR
BROADBAND AS WELL AS THE IT IS
LESS COSTLY THAN IN PERSON.
VISITS ON THAT IS NAY DID SO
THEREFORE THE- AS DOUBLE THAT
LOWER. RATES IS APPROACH FOR.
PROVIDED VIA TO IN AUDIO
SERVICES. ADDITIONALLY WE ARE I
YOU. TO LOOK AT- THE DATA THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WE DO
KNOW THE U. OF TELEPHONE- AND
ONLY A WELL AS JUST HOW HOW
WITH ITS- EXPANDED DURING THE
HEALTH EMERGENCY- ON AVERAGE WE
HAD ABOUT TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
TELEHEALTH VISITS PER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND BENEFICIARIES.
PER MONTH COMPARED TO LESS THAN
FOUR HUNDRED TELEHEALTH VISITS
PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
BENEFICIARIES PER MONTH IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN SO
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN REGARDS
TO THE USE OF TELEHEALTH.
DEPARTMENT IF KNOWLEDGE IS THE
BENEFITS OF AUDIO ALL THE AUDIO
ONLY SERVICES NO IT SHOULD BE
ONE OF THE OPTIONS. THAT IS
AVAILABLE FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
USE WITHIN- THE ACCESS POINTS
FOR BENEFICIARIES FOR REALLY
EMPATHIZING ALSO THE NEED TO
CONTINUE THAT IN PERSON CARE
WHICH IS SO CRITICAL FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE HIGH
QUALITY. OF OUTCOMES IN THE
TOUCHPOINTS WITH POSITIONS
WHICH IS CRITICAL THOUGHTS
ABOUT FINDING THAT BALANCE.
ADDITIONALLY ARE GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
TELEHEALTH VISITS WE CONTINUE
TO KIND OF LOOK AT OUR DATA UP
FROM MANY ANGLES AND LOOK FOR
TO CONVERSATIONS. WITH
INDIVIDUALS REGARDING NOT. I DO
WANT TO ADDRESS- OF. THE CALL.
A HOW THE IS LOOKING AT-
ACTUATES THE IN REGARD TO THE
RE. RATE AS IN IN THE PROPOSED-
CMS HAD GIVEN AT THE DEPARTMENT
CLEAR GUIDANCE- IF EIGHTY ARE
YOU ONLY A TO BE A LAW AND HAVE
TO SEE THE WOULD BE. BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE. OF THAT AT
THE FUTURE RATE- AND WE WERE
CONSIDER ALL- PAYMENT METHOD.
OF IS THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD
COMMERCE. THAT HAVE PUT OFF THE
TABLE- SOME OPTIONS FOR
ACCURACY THE ROLE HEALTH
CLINICS WE'VE ALSO BEEN
ENGAGING IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
YEAH THAT'S TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW. AND
WHAT WE COULD DO IN THE STATE
THE FOR NOT PAYING THE PPS-
HOWEVER WOULD JUST WANT TO
REINFORCE THAT THROUGH THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YEAH MATH.
OF DH CS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
PAY FQHCS AT PAYMENT PARITY FOR
TELEPHONIC AUDIO ONLY OUR
CURRENT AVERAGE OF READY IT'S
TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN. DOLLARS
PER VISIT. IF WE WERE TO
EXPLORE AN ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
METHODOLOGY WITH THE CLINICS
WHICH WE ARE EXPLORING THROUGH
THIS PROPOSAL- IT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THE CLINIC HE- YOU KNOW IN
AGREEMENT WITH US TO WAIVE
THEIR PPS SO. IN ORDER TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH AN ALTERNATE
PAYMENT WITH THAT HUGE SPEEDS
UP FOR AUDIO ONLY THAT CLINICS
WOULD HAVE TO AGREE THE
INDUSTRY WOULD HAVE TO BE
WILLING TO WAIVE PPS. AND IF
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO THAT THAT
WOULD ENGAGE IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE M. S. TO GET THAT
WAIVER APPROVAL AND TO HAVE AN
ALTERNATIVE HE MEANT. FOR AUDIO
ONLY. OF THE DEPARTMENT HAS
SHOWN OUR COMMITMENT TO
ENGAGING THERE WE HAVE RAISED
THAT IT MAY BE CONCERNED WITH
GETTING CMS APPROVAL ON THAT
FRONT. BUT STILL COMMITTED TO
FINDING AN ALTERNATIVE SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE CAN OFFER AUDIO ONLY
FOR NON FTC'S TO HAVE AN
ALTERNATE PAYMENT.
RECOMMENDATION IN REGARDS TO
THE COST ETIMATE- ON THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN. AB THIRTY
TWO WHAT I WOULD SAY THEY IS
THAT- THE IMPACT OF AB THIRTY
TWO IS. A AT THIS BUT WILL
FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH THE-
REGARDING THAT AND FUTURE. BUT
THE THING THAT. AND HAPPY TO
ANY. WE IT IS TIME. THANK YOU
CAN A NEXT WILL FROM. HOW SHE
DOES WITH THE L. THANK YOU DR
REGULAR ISSUE THAT WITH THE- L.
A. O. ON THIS ISSUE WE WOULD
JUST LIKE TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
PLANNING TO RELEASE A
MELODRAMATIC CAL TELEHEALTH
PUBLICATION IN THE COMING DAYS-
THIS THIS POST IS GENERALLY IN
RESPONSE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL- WHICH OF COURSE MAY
OR MAY NOT CHANGE AT ME REVISED
BUT WE INTEND FOR THIS PEACE
TO- ALSO PROVIDE OUR COMMENTARY
ON THE BROADER POLICY ISSUE
ESPECIALLY GIVEN- LEGISLATIVE
ACTIVITY IN THIS AREA. ON HOW
MANY CAL TELEHEALTH POLICY
SHOULD BE SET GOING FORWARD-
THE POST WILL HAVE SOME FURTHER
ANALYSIS BUT GENERALLY WE FIND
THAT THERE'S A LOT ABOUT
TELEHEALTH THAT IS NOT NOT WELL
UNDERSTOOD- WHILE THERE IS SOME
AVAILABLE RESEARCH ON THE
CLINICAL EFFECTIVENESS OF
TELEHEALTH SERVICES. THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF TELEHEALTH EXPANSIONS
AND- THE IMPACT OF TELEHEALTH
EXPANSIONSON ACCESS TO CARE
THESE REVIEWS ARE OFTEN
NARROWLY FOCUSED ON SPECIFIC
HEALTHCARE SERVICE TYPES OR THE
MODALITY THROUGH WHICH SERVICES
ARE PROVIDED- SUCH AS LIVE
VIDEO OR AUDIO ONLY. GIVEN THIS
IT'S DIFFICULT TO GENERALIZE
FINDINGS ABOUT TELEHEALTH
BROADLY- AND IN ADDITION
THERE'S A LOT WE STILL DON'T
KNOW ABOUT HOW TELEHEALTH
UTILIZATION- IS GOING TO BE
AFFECTED GOING FORWARD ONCE THE
COPING NINETEEN PANDEMIC ENDS-
WE HAVE SOME OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY THE
SETTING OF DIFFERENTIAL PAYMENT
RATES BY TELEHEALTH SERVICE- ON
A PERMANENT BASIS- THE PROPOSAL
TO MAKE CERTAIN. TELEHEALTH
SERVICES AVAILABLE FOR A
CERTAIN BENEFICIARIES BUT NOT
OTHERS DEPENING ON WHERE THE
AXIS CARE- SINCE CERTAIN
SERVICES WOULD NOT BE COVERED
AT HEALTH CENTERS- IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ASSUMPTION
THAT PUTS TELEHEALTH POLICY-
WOULD BE COST NEUTRAL GIVEN
POTENTIAL INCREASES IN ACCESS
TO CARE- AND HEALTH CARE
UTILIZATION- THOSE THOSE ARE
OFFICES COME WITH AT THIS TIME
BUT AGAIN WE HAVE AN UPCOMING
PUBLICATION THAT WILL PROVIDE
MORE ANALYSIS AND- WE'RE VERY
VERY CLOSE TO GETTING THAT OUT.
I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE. FURTHER
ASSISTANCE WHERE NEEDED. THANK
YOU VERY NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
DOCTOR WHO MENTAL IT. THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME AN OPPORTUNITY
MISTER CHECK OUT DR ARAMBULA
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME- MY NAME
IS GOING TO HIM WITHIN A COMMA
INTERNAL MEDICINE PHYSICIAN.
I'M CURRENTLY THE CHIEF MEDICAL%
OFFICER OF THE UNITED HEALTH
CENTERS IN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT- AFFECT
ANY QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER.
THAT PROVIDE UP TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND-
ANDROID- BOTH RURAL HI YOUR OWN
AS WELL AS A BUTTON-
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY- SO- I'VE
BEEN A PRIVATE ACCOUNT. FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS THANKS TO.
PROVIDE PRIMARY CARE TO MY- MY
PACE. ARE IN PAIN FOR THE YEAR
I'VE- DELIVER MIGHT PRIME CAP
TELEPHONICALLY SEEING- IN ALL
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY. MINUTES
A DAY AND WHEN I WOKE UP YEAH
FULL FULL FOR PATIENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN ON COMMITTEES DIFFICULTY
COMING IN DURING THE CALL TODAY.
NOT JUST TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT
OF HISTORY WHICH IS A TEENY BIT
IMPORTANT TO THE TOPIC. I CAME
TO THE UNITED HEALTH CENTERS
FROM THE US DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS PASSED. AT MY LAST JOB
I WAS THE CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER
WILL BE A NEWIN GOOD HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. WHIPPED BOAT EIGHT
TEACHING HOSPITALS IN SIX NEW
ENGLAND STATES AND- DURING THE
TIME. WE WERE EXTENSIVELY
UTILIZING TELEHEALTH- WE
STARTED USING TWENTY AT THE TWO
THOUSAND SIX IN THE VA. ARE
SPECIALLY NEW ENGLAND WITH THE
COLD WINTERS COME SO A LOT OF
GUYS DELIVERED BY TELEHEALTH TO
AVOID THAT THESE VETERANS FROM
DRIVING IN IN IN AND SNOW AND
ICE AND I. WAS ALSO AN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE
AT DARTMOUTH. WELL IN. A LOT OF
THE WORK IS DONE FOR HEALTH
EQUITY AND ATTEND HEALTH IS ONE
OF THE ONE OF THE AREAS WE HAVE
THE. HIGHLY HIGHLY ENCOURAGE.
NOW I TO- UNITED HEALTH SAID
DOES HE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND TO MY SURPRISE I FOUND.
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE
MEDICAL CENTERS OVER HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF. PATIENTS
SERVED WE HAVE. ABSOLUTELY
ZERO- ABSOLUTELY A NORTEL
HEALTH AT ALL AND I DID FIND
OUT WHY AND THE REASON IS
HAVING NO POLICIES PROCEEDING
AS- NO INCENTIVES NO FINDING
MORE STRUCTURE TO. IN A BILL
FOR THE SERVICE AS AN
ABSOLUTELY- NO REASON. FOR THE
AYE HEALTH CENTERS TO ENGAGE IN
GETTING AT NINETY ONE FALL
MENTAL HEALTH WHICH IS A SAD
SITUATION. SEOUL THANK IN
CORBY- AS SOON AS THE COLD WE'D
HATE. SUDDENLY WE- WE GOT THE
PERMISSION THE GREEN LIGHT TO
GO AHEAD AND DO TELEHEALTH
BECAUSE NOTHING ELSE. WILL WILL
BECOME AVAILABLE WITH WITH THE
FACE TO FACE ENCOMPASS- AND-
ESTABLISHED ENORMOUS THREAT.
OFF A SPREAD OF THE VIRUS AND
ALSO TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS. SO
WHAT DID WE DO. TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN B. BUG FOR A DAY OR TWO
THE RIGHT POLICIES PRESIDIO'S.
TREND OUR DOCTORS. OF THE WENT
IMMEDIATELY. TO COMPLETE.
TELEHEALTH AND PRIVATE
TELEPHONIC TECH. OUR AS YOU
KNOW MOST OF OUR PATIENTS THE
HAVE A MAX TO COME YOU KNOW THE
DON'T HAVE AG TO SMARTPHONES
THEY HAVE JUST SIMPLE FEAT
FORMS AND AN OLDER FASHION
FORMS OF PRETTY MUCH FORTY
ONLY. AND THEN MOST OF THESE
RURAL AREAS EVEN BETTER DOESN'T
WORK SO THEY THEY RELY ON THE
OLD YOUR COMMUNICATION. AND I
WOULD I WOULD I WOULD. I'M
HAPPY TO SAY. THE CHANGE WAS.
RECEIVED EXTREMELY WELL BY OUR
PATIENTS THAT I CAN TELL YOU AS
A MEDICAL PROVIDER SPECIALLY IN
PRIMARY CARE THE QUALITY WAS
MAINTAINED. I CAN TELL YOU MOST
OF THE TIME WE DON'T HAVE TO
EXAMINE THE PATIENT HAD TO
TALK. TO PROVIDE THE CARE THEY
NEED. WE HAVE SEEN THE PATIENT
BEFORE WE KNOW WHAT THEY HAVE
MOST OF THEM HAVE CHRONIC
PROBLEMS. YOU KNOW WE CAN
ADJUST THE MEDICATIONS WE CAN
GIVE THEM BLOOD PRESSURE METERS
AND HAVE THEM CHECKED ABOUT
PUSH APPLE. WE CAN DO A LOT OF
THINGS BY TALKING TO THEM CAN
FIFTEEN MINUTES. LISTENING TO
THEM FINDING OUT ADVISING.
THAT'S HOW THE TELEPHONIC
MEDICINE BOOKS. TELL. SO THE
KEY TO SUCCESS IN OUR IN OUR
PROVIDING ALTERNATIVE- MORE OF
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY WHICH IS
KIND A NOVEL TO THE- THE THAT
VERY QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS
BUT IT WAS NOT NOVEL TO THE VA
WAS OUR NEED TO HAVE POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES NEED TO HAVE
PROCESSORS AND NEED TO HAVE
INCENTIVES BUILT IN SEOUL WE
WOULD BE USING BEST TO IMPROVE
ACCESS OF. A CAT I CAN TELL YOU
FROM MY EXPERIENCE IN THE VA WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT IMPROVE
QUALITY OF CARE WE HAVE DONE A
LOT OF RESEARCH AND THAT'S
AVAILABLE IN THE LITERATURE
FROM THE MEDIA THE QUALITY OF
CARE HAS TREMENDOUSLY IMPROVED
WITH THE UTILIZATION OF
TELEPORT SYNCHRONOUS AUDIO
VIDEO AS WELL AS HIS THINKING
US AS WELL AS HOME TRYING TO
HELP. WE HAVE IMPROVED OUR COST
OF PL BY DECREASING THE
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS
DECREASING THE HOSPITAL
ADMISSIONS BY THE. USE OF
TELEHEALTH ALL FORMS OF. AND I
CAN TELL YOU IF YOU START. WHAT
THE IMPACT OF THE OF TELL
DURING THIS CALL PENDANT CAN
TELL YOU MY PERSONALLY.
TREMENDOUS COST SAVINGS BECAUSE
WE CALL THESE PATIENTS WHO GET
COOLEY POSITIVE PRETTY MUCH
DAILY SOMETIMES THAT'S MEANT
THAT MAY BE WHY THERE'S SO MANY
VISITS. TELEFONICA'S TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS. FINDING OUT
WHAT SYMPTOMS THEY HAVE.
PRESCRIBING TREATMENTS THAT
THEY NEED. REASSURING THAT SAW
THEY DON'T RUN TO THE EMERGENCY
ROOM HOSPITAL BECAUSE THIS
CANNOT. BE PREVENTED THE
SUBMISSIONS BY THE TELEFONICA'S
REPORT DISABLED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WHICH OTHERWISE SPENT
THIS HOSPICE WOULD HAVE BEEN
FILLED. AND THE PATIENTS WOULD
HAVE BEEN DEAD BECAUSE THEY HAD
NO HOSPITAL ACCESS. IF ALL
THESE VERSIONS RAN TO THE
HOSPITAL'S EMERGENCY ROOMS OF
THE PREVENT THAT THAT BECAUSE
WE USE THE TELEPHONIC SERVICE.
TO KEEP THESE PATIENTS HOOKED
ON TO ALL PROVIDERS SO DID WILL
GET THE CARE AND THE SYSTEM
THEY NEED ANYTIME THEY NEED.
SALT CALIFORNIA. YEAH AS WELL
AS ONE OF TALIA IS. TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO KIA NOT ALL AT THE OF.
BUT EVERY DAY AND THAT'S A
LESSON WE READ ME TO FROM
SIXTY. NOT THEREFORE I'M HERE
RESPECTIVE RESPECTFULLY URGING
COMMITTEE TO REJECT
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD DISCONTINUE THE AUDIO
ONLY A PAYMENT AFFECTS ABILITY.
FOR POST PANDEMIC ERA FOR THE
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS I THINK THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY UNFAIR NOT TO OUR
HIGHLY DESERVED. UNDERSERVED
PATIENTS. NOW READING UNITED
HEALTH CENTERS HAVE PROVIDED.
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND RECEIVED
DURING THE BAND. FINALLY I
WOULD SAY MORE THAN 900005%
NOTHING USING TELEPHONE ONLY
VISITS. HELLO MORE TENTATIVE IT
IS LOW ABOUT QUALITY OF GUYS
GOOD OFFICIALS ARE EXTREMELY
HAPPY AND WE SAVED IT FROM
RUNNING TO THE EMERGENCY ROOMS
AND HOSPITALS EVEN THOUGH TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF THE- BIG GET
CAUGHT. WE TESTED THEM WE WILL
SORT OF ACCIDENT AND MOST OF
THESE WITH ITS BUT DONE. BY
TELEPHONIC INTERACTIONS. I CAN
TELL YOU. MOST OF MY PATIENTS
NOW I WORK AT A CLINIC WITH YOU
ALL. WHICH IS ALMOST LIKE
NOWHERE. AND MOST OF MY
PATIENTS HAVE TREMENDOUS
DIFFICULTIES. IN TRANSPORTATION
THEY DON'T HAVE COSTS. THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE YOU KNOW. WHY
I'M INFORMS US. AND SOME OF
THEM BUT LONG HOURS INDOORS
PACKING HOUSE SERVICE IN THE IN
THE FARM FIELDS. MOST OF THE
TIME WHEN I CALL THEM FOR THE
OBVIOUS IT'S YES THEY ARE
WORKING THEY TAKE A BREAK AND
CALL YOU KNOW MAKE THE CALL AND
I YOU KNOW TAKE OUT THEIR
PROBLEMS THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
TO TAKE A DAY OFF FROM WORK.
THAT IS A TREMENDOUS VALUE BUT
THESE. WORKERS WHO ACTUALLY
DEPEND ON A SINGLE DAY HAS
BECOME BEFORE AS OF THIS BAY TO
COMPLICATE THE PROCEDURE. I'M
NOT SAYING THAT TELEMEDICINE IS
THE ANSWER FOR EVERYTHING.
HOWEVER KELLY MY THE OLD YOU
ONLY TELL ME HAS A HUGE ROLE.
IN BETWEEN. FACE TO FACE WITH
ITS WE CAN HAVE A FACE TO FACE
VISIT AND WE CAN NOW MULTIPLE
TELEPHONE WITH IT'S IN BETWEEN
THE CHECKOUT OF THE PATIENT'S
PROBLEMS. UNTIL WE DECIDE NOW
IT'S TIME TO SEE THE PATIENT
AGAIN. OKAY SO. TAKING BASED
MODEL OF CARE THAT WAS
AVAILABLE TO US AND HAD
TREMENDOUSLY HELP US IMPROVE
ACCESS AND QUALITY FOR THESE
PATIENTS. I CONSIDER A
TREMENDOUS INJUSTICE. BUT THE
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS AND RENTALS. ARE ALL
EXPERTS. SO I HOW ASK. AND I AM
PLEASED TO AT THIS POINT
REPRESENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES CALIFORNIA PRIMARY
CARE ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
REPRESENTATIVES ARE APARTMENTS
WITH THE AGENTS TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TO ADOPT SB THIRTY TWO
AS AN ALTERNATIVE TELL HER
PROPOSAL. AND PART OF THE
LEGISLATURE BUDGET PRIORITIES
BECAUSE. HELPING US CONTINUE.
THE TELEHEALTH THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ENJOYING IT NOW PATIENTS
HAVE BEEN DRIVING ON. WE WOULD
LIKE YOUR SUPPORT YOU BE WE
WOULD WANT YOU TO WRITE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN ANDWE WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE SURE. THAT WE WOULD BE
REIMBURSED APPROPRIATELY. SO WE
WILL NOT GO OUT OF BUSINESS
BASICALLY YOU KNOW. BECAUSE IF
NOT IF THERE ARE NO INCENTIVES
IT DOES NOT NORMALLY TO BUILD
THEM I CAN GUARANTEE YOU THAT
IT IS GOING TO STOP COMPLETELY
AND THAT IS THAT IS WHY IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
SUPPORT BABY DADDY TO SO I
THINK PEOPLE MIGHT MY AND MY
TIME AND I AM. READY GLANCE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR
ESPECIALLY FOR MENTIONING HURON
WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT AND-
CITY MODEL AS AND CORRESPONDING
VIA. THE HEART OF THE VALLEY I
APPRECIATE YOU MENTIONING IT-
NEXT WE WILL MOVE ON TO DR
HORTON. HELLO THERE YOU GO HI-
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS I DR
CLAIRE HORTON- AND I'M THE
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO HEALTH NETWORK-
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF NOT ONLY OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO HEALTH NETWORK BUT
ALSO THE TWENTY OTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- ALL OF WHOM HAVE
BENEFITTED GREATLY FROM. THE
TELEHEALTH AND- HAVE SOME
IMPORTANT FEEDBACK TODAY- ALSO
WANTED TO MENTION THAT OUR
STATE ASSOCIATION IS ALSO A
PROUD SPONSOR CO SPONSOR OF- AB
THIRTY TWO AS WELL. SO THE SAN
FRANCISCO HEALTH NETWORK IS THE
PART OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT PROVIDES ALL THE DELIVERY
SYSTEM- AS SUCH WE HAVE THE
MAJOR PUBLIC HOSPITAL THE MAJOR
PUBLIC NURSING HOME- IT. SAYS
EIGHT SIXTEEN- PRIMARY CARE
CLINICS ALSO SPECIALTY CLINICS-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES- AND
ST MADISON WI KC ESSENTIALLY
ALL PUBLICLY IN SHORTER
UNINSURED PATIENTS VERY VERY
VULNERABLE AND DIVERSE PATIENT
POPULATION. AND SINCE THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN WE'VE BEEN
SEEING ABOUT WE'VE BEEN DOING
ABOUT SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
TELEHEALTH VISITS A MONTH AND
THE MAJORITY OF THESE ARE ON
THE PHONE. SO WE'VE DISCOVERED
MANY OF THE SAME THINGS THAT-
DOCTOR HIM. TO LOCK HE WAS JUST
MENTIONING. WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT TELEHEALTH WAS IT ACTUALLY
IS A LIFE DURING- AND WE WERE.
VERY CONCERNED AND ALSO A THE
PRIME CARE FOR AND- LIKE MANY
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS AND
PHYSICIANS IN GENERAL IS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT PATIENTS LOSING
ACCESS TO. PREVENTIVE CARE
SERVICES DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND WE REALLY FELT THAT
TELEHEALTH WAS WAS A LIFELINE
SO MANY OF MY PATIENTS EVEN
WHEN WE WERE OFFERING IN PERSON
VISITS WERE AFRAID TO COME IN
AND WE'RE TRYING TO STAY
SOCIALLY DISPENSED. AND THIS
WAS THE ONE WHERE WE HAD TO
STAY IN TOUCH WITH THEM. TOO
AGAIN S. M. THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER MENTIONED TO COMPACT
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS- AND-
WE GOT VERY CREATIVE AS WELL WE
HAVE GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE CME
BLOOD PRESSURE MACHINES WHO ARE
WRITING DOWN THEIR BLOOD
SUGARS. WHO PHONE IN THAT
INFORMATION TO US. I'VE HAD
PATIENTS CALL AND- A FAMILY
MEMBER WHO WAS AT WORK- SO THAT
THEY COULD BE PART OF A JOINT
VISIT- IT'S ACTUALLY BEEN A
REALLY EYE OPENING EXPERIENCE
ABOUT THE POWER OF THIS. TYPE
OF IS IT SO IT'S NOT IDEAL FOR
EVERYONE MANY OF OUR PATIENTS.
LOOK FORWARD TO AND ARE NOW
COMING BACK FOR IN PERSON
VISITS AND FOR SOME SPECIFIC
THINGS THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- BUT WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT IT IS REALLY WORKS SO WELL
FOR SOME OF OUR PATIENTS- AND
IT IS. SOMETHING THAT THEY VERY
MUCH WANT TO CONTINUE- IN
PARTICULAR I FOUND THAT FOR MY
MARGINALLY HOUSED PATIENTS- WHO
MAY NOT BE RECEIVING THAT
LETTER TO REMIND OF THE IN
PERSON VISIT TO HAVE A PHONE-
I'VE REALLY BEEN ABLE TO KEEP
IN TOUCH WITH THEM MUCH BETTER.
DURING THIS TIME OF BY THE USE
OF THE PHONE VISITS- WE HAVE A
LOT OF PATIENTS WITH SUBSTANCE
USE OR MENTAL ILLNESS- AND-
THERE. HAVE A LOT OF COMPETING
PRIORITIES AND CAN BUILD
DISORGANIZED ABOUT MAKING IN
PERSON VISITS BUT- HARD WORK
CHAU RATE HAS GONE WAY UP WITH
TELEHEALTH VISITS I'M IN MUCH
BETTER TOUCH WITH THEM. I'VE
HAD PATIENTS WITH DIABETES COME
UNDER CONTROL FOR ALMOST THE
FIRST TIME BECAUSE I HAVE MUCH
MORE REGULAR. CONTACT WITH
THEM- AND THEN OF COURSE FOR
ELDERLY AND HOMEBOUND PATIENTS
IT'S BEEN. A REAL BLESSING AS
WELL- MANY OF THEM WANT TO CAN.
THIS AS- SO AT THE- SPEAKER
MENTIONED- THE PHONE REALLY
WORKS REALLY WELL FOR THIS
REALLY HIGHLY VULNERABLE
PATIENT POPULATION- ESSENTIALLY
ALL OF MY PATIENTS HAVE PHONES-
WE'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD
TO TRY AND GET THE MONSOON- OR
TO GET ON SOME KIND OF- YEAH.
VIDEO PLATFORM BUT IT'S BEEN
REALLY REALLY CHALLENGING WE
HAVE. WE'VE BEEN TRYING FOR
YEARS AND BACK TO TRY AND GET
THEM ON TO OUR- OUR WEB
COMMUNICATION SYSTEM WITH OUR
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD AND
HAVE VERY LOW UPTAKE. BECAUSE
FRANKLY A LOT OF THEM. DON'T
USUALLY USE EMAIL THERE'S A
HUGE TECH LITERACY GAP HERE-
WIFI IT CAN BE REALLY
CHALLENGING IN THE HOME- AND
FOR MANY OF THEM THEY LIVE IN
CONGREGATE SETTINGS ARE
THERE'S- MULTIPLE FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE SEVERAL FAMILIES
LIVING IN ONE HOUSE AND SO.
THERE'S PRIVACY CONCERNS WITH A
VIDEO VISIT THAT. DOES NOT
HAPPEN IF THEY CAN STOP YOU
KNOW SOMEWHERE WITH THEIR PHONE
OR STEP OUTSIDE FOR A MINUTE.
WE CAN DO THOSE PHONE VISITS
ANYWHERE- SO YOU KNOW FOR ALL
THOSE REASONS I'VE BEEN SO
THRILLED. TO THAT WE'VE HAD-
TELEHEALTH VISITS DURING THE
PANDEMIC- I STRONGLY FEEL AND
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OTHER
PUBLIC HEALTH. PRACTITIONERS
AND SYSTEMS AS WELL. THAT IT
WOULD BE A HUGE DISSERVICE TO
THIS VERY VULNERABLE PATIENT
POPULATION. IF WE WERE TO MOVE
FOR WITH ONLY ALLOWING VIDEO
VISITS. I REALLY THINK THAT
VIDEO VISITS YOU KNOW IT IS
REALLY ONLY AVAILABLE AS A AS
A- AS A- AS A MEDIUM. FOR A
CERTAIN SLICE OF THE POPULATION
AND FRANKLY THE- THAT'S THAT'S
GOING TO REALLY IMPACT YOU KNOW
HEALTH EQUITY AND IN TERMS OF
ACCESS TO THIS TYPE OF SERVICE-
SO I REALLY- BOTH AM VERY HAPPY
THAT THE STATE IS RECOGNIZING
THE IMPORTANCE. OF CONTINUING
TO SUPPORT. TELEHEALTH IN
GENERAL I THINK THAT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT ADVANCE FOR THE OUR
HEALTH SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE VERY
FOCUSED ON CONTINUING TO WORK
ON VIDEO PLATFORMS AND HELPING
OUR PATIENTS GET. THEIR- BUT
THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT THE YES-
AND- I'M A- THAT A- CUT OFF OF
ALL FUND FOR TELL. VISIT WOULD
REALLY DROPPED THE- OUT OF.
WHAT WHAT IS SET UP THEM NOW.
AND SO WELL I'D URGE CAN
SUPPORT. FOR TELEHEALTH IN
GENERAL I'M REALLY HOPING THAT
CONSIDERATION CAN BE GIVEN TO
CONTINUING TO. FINANCIALLY
SUPPORT PHONE VISITS AS WELL
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE. AND ALSO WORKING ON
OTHER ALTERNATE PAYMENT METHODS
THAT CAN. HELP US GET THERE IN
THE LONG RUN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR HORTON
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM ROBERT
BARDIA. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAMBERS
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME MY NAME
IS ROBERT BEGIN I AM THE GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE PATIENT
NAVIGATOR AND VIRTUAL HEALTH
CARE COORDINATOR FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD FOR THE CENTRAL
COAST- I WORK WITH PATIENTS ON
THE DAILY- WITH. TELEPHONE
VISITS OR EVEN VIRTUAL VISITS
AS WELL- MOST OF THE PATIENTS
THAT I DO WORK WITH- DO YOU
RECEIVE ARE. AND PTEROPURE OVER
CONSOLES- BUT WE ALSO DO NON
EMERGENT- VISITS LIKE BIRTH
CONTROL AND STUFF LIKE THAT FOR
PATIENTS WHO DON'T CAN GO INTO
THE CLINIC. THIS LAST YEAR HAS
DEFINITELY SHOWED US THAT THIS
IS A DEFINING MOMENT I'M SORRY
I CAN'T TALK. I DEFINITE NEED
FOR A LOT OF OUR PATIENTS WHO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO GET TO THE
CLINICS ESPECIALLY WITH KOBE
NINETEEN HAPPENING WITH SCHOOL
AND WORK AND SUCH THAT. THEY
HAVEN'T HAD THE TIME TO GO INTO
THE CLINIC WITH A CHALLENGE TO
FIND IN CLINIC VISIT AS WELL-
WHEN A PATIENT BECAUSE AN
APPOINTMENT THEY USUALLY TALK
TO MYSELF OR ONE OF MY CALL
CENTER AGENTS. AND WE CAN
DETERMINE BASED ON THEIR- NEEDS
THAT WAY. WHEN WE SHOULD SET
THEM UP WITH- WE'RE TRYING TO
DO VIDEO BECAUSE MOST OF THE
TIME BUT I KNOW THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
WIFI I. DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO A
SMARTPHONE SO THEY JUST USE A
PHONE CALL. AS WELL- SORRY.
THANKS A LOT FOR OF OURS. FOR
OUR GENDER FROM CARE SIR. ARE
HELLO THIS SIR. AND IT'S BEEN
CHANGING THEM BECAUSE THEY HAVE
THAT ONE ON. CHANCE TO TALK TO
PROVIDER. WELL BEING THE
COMPANY THEIR OWN HOME A LOT OF
THESE. NOT BEING. WITH A
CLINICAL SETTING HAVING
ANXIETY. I'M GOING INTO
CLINICAL STTING BECAUSE THEY
FEEL JUDGED OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT- START HERE LIKE I SAID I
HEAR BACK FROM A VACATION THAT
SAY THAT THIS SERVICE HAS
DEFINITELY HELPED AMOUNT- THEY
APPRECIATE THE TIME SAVED ME
THE TIME STABLE. SORRY I CAN'T
QUOTE THE TIME SAVING ENERGY
THEY HAVE ON THIS- SPECIALLY
WITH A LOT OF THEM GOING BACK
TO WORK AFTER NOT BEING A WORK
THE HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
WONDER LUNCH BREAK ON BEFORE
WORK OR AFTER WORK ON HAVING A
GOOD THIRTY FORTY MINUTE
CONCERT WITH OUR PROVIDER AND
INTAKE PERSON- I THINK I WAS
ABLE TO A PATIENT WHO EVEN
LIVED UP NORTH FROM OUR
AFFILIATE- AND- THEY HAVE THAT
TROUBLE ARE. GETTING AN
APPOINTMENT- BEAR. AND THEY
WEREN'T AWARE THAT WE PROVIDED
TELEHEALTH SERVICES UNTIL THEY
CALLED ME AND THEY EVEN THOUGHT
THAT THE CALL IS TO MAKE AN
APPOINTMENT FOR ANY CLINIC
VISIT. AND I TOLD THEM NO
LONGER INTAKE WILL GO AHEAD AND
DO YOUR- VISIT HOW THE PROVIDER
DO SO MAKE YOUR OWN-
MEDICATIONS TO THE PHARMACY THE
ELECTRONICALLY AND- SHE WAS SO
GRATEFUL BECAUSE SHE WAS TAKING
CARE OF A- FAMILY MEMBER THAT
WAS SICK. AND SHE WAS HAVING A
HARD TIME GETTING HER MEANT
THAT SHE NEEDED BY HAVING
TELEHEALTH. DEFINITELY HELPED
HER OUT AND SHE FOR THE SENSE
OF RELIEF AND APPRECIATION FOR
HAVING. THE SERVICE- AND NOT
ALL. OF TWENTY. HOW THE WITH
THE- AB. BUT THE PEACE. AND IF
ANONYMOUS SITUATION WE CAN
ALWAYS DO A CONSULTANT REALLY
EXPENSIVE ANALYZE THE PROVIDER
NEEDS IN KENYA IN CLINIC VISIT
THEY WILL HAVE THEM GOING TO
THE- VISIT AND ALSO AN
APPOINTMENT UP FOR THEM FOR
EASY TRANSFERRED OF CARE.
WITHIN OUR CLINICS- AFTER THE
HEARING WE'VE HAD TO WILL.
SERVICES IT'S BEEN LIFE
CHANGING BEEN GREAT SERVICE AND
I DEFINITELY THINK THIS IS
CONTINUED SERVICE FOR A LOT OF
OUR PATIENTS. SPECIALLY- STUDIO
AND- BURKE HE WORKS. ARE
WORKING IN THE- WHO DON'T HAVE
THE TIME TO GOING TO AND CLINIC
SAID. SO I DEFINITELY BILL THAT
IT'S AN TO GET THE FUNDING WE
NEED FOR OUR PATIENTS WITH THIS-
SERVICE CENTER CONTATO TICKLED
TO HAVE THIS. SERVICE GO ON ON.
JOBS THANK YOU FOR MAKE SURE
WHY THE FUNDING IS IMPORTANT
FROM A PATIENT PERSPECTIVE-
INCLUDING OUR PHONE SERVICES
ALBERTA HEALTH CARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM DAVID FORD WITH CMA. RIGHT
THANK YOU DR RANDALL MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE AGAIN I'M
DAVID FORD VICE PRESIDENT OF
HEALTH IT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK HERE
TODAY. IN GENERAL CMA STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE USE OF
TELEHEALTH IT'S A POWERFUL TOOL
THAT PATIENTS CAN USE TO
CONNECT WITH THEIR CHOSEN
POSITIONS. AND AS WE ALL KNOW
DURING THE PANDEMIC IT WAS A
LITERAL LIFELINE FOR BOTH
PATIENTS AND PHYSICIANS
PRACTICES. THAT BEING SAID WE
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE A VERY MIXED
REACTION TO THE TELEHEALTH
TRAILER. BILL LANGUAGE PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. ON THE
HAND WE VERY. OF THE- AT LEAST
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED TOOK PAN
PARITY RICK. FOR VIDEO TELL MAY
MANAGED CARE PLAN. WE BELIEVE
THIS RESULT IN GREATLY EXPANDED
OUR TO. FOR SOME PATIENTS AND
MANAGE CARE. AT THE SAME LIKE
THE- OTHER SPEECH BEFORE ME TOO
MANY MONSTROUS. OPPOSED
PROPOSAL CREATE A NEW AND LOWER
FEE SCHEDULE FOR PHONE ONLY
TELEHEALTH. THIS PROPOSAL IF
ENACTED THREATENS TO CUT OFF A
KEY TOOL THAT PHYSICIANS AND
PATIENTS CAN USE TO PRODUCTIVE
CAN ACCESS TO CARE. IT'S BUT TO
START OFF IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CLARIFY WITH CNN OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ACTUALLY ASKING
FOR THIS POLICY. ALL OF US WORK
KNOWLEDGE THAT SOME TREATMENTS
NAMELY ANYONE THAT REQUIRES A
PHYSICIAN TO LAY HANDS ON THE
PATIENT CANNOT BE PROVIDED
THROUGH TELEHEALTH. BUT WHEN A
PHYSICIAN PROVIDES A TREATMENT
IT SHOULD BE REIMBURSED THE
SAME REGARDLESS OF THE MODALITY
UNDER WHICH IT HAS PROVIDED- WE
OFTEN SAY THAT WE ARE YOU TALK
ABOT PAYING FOR TELEPHONE
WE'RE NOT PAYING FOR TELEPHONE
WE ARE PAYING FOR A SERVICE
THAT IS BEING PROVIDED. BY THE
TELEPHONE SYSTEM OR DOWDY UNDER
WHICH IT IS BEING DONE. I DO
ALSO FEEL NECESSARY TO ANSWER
ONE COMMENT MADE BY THE
DEPARTMENT MEDI CAL RATES AND
NOT F. Q. SETTINGS ARE NOT AND
NEVER HAVE BEEN BASED ON
PROVIDER COST. IF THEY WERE I
THINK MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU KNOW
FIRST HAND THEY WOULD BE MUCH
HIGHER ACROSS THE BOARD.
BOTTLENECK BUT FINALLY
CHARACTER IN PARTICULAR IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE MANY PATIENTS
AND ESPECIALLY IN THE MEDICAL
SPACE STILL DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO BROADBAND INTERNET
CONNECTIONS IT'S BUT SUPPORT
VIDEO TELEHEALTH. I NGUYEN CMA
SURVEYED OUR OWN MEMBERSHIP
LAST OCTOBER MORE THAN ONE
THIRD OF PHYSICIANS STATEWIDE
REPORTED THAT THEIR TOP
CHALLENGES IMPLEMENTING
TELEHEALTH IS LACK OF BROADBAND
ACCESS FOR THE PATIENT. THOSE
PATIENTS NEED TELEPHONE TO BE A
VIABLE OPTION. AND FURTHERMORE
WHEN LOWER INCOME PATIENTS TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
IT'S OFTEN THROUGH THEIR
SMARTPHONE. SMARTPHONE
DEPENDENT PATIENTS MAY BE
RELUCTANT TO HAVE A VIDEO VISIT
BECAUSE THEY MAY HAVE DATA CAPS
LIMITED CELLPHONE MINUTES OTHER
CONSTRAINTS THAT ARE ARTIFICIAL
BUT COME FROM THEIR PHONE
PLANS. AT A TIME WHEN THE STATE
IS RIGHTLY FOCUSED ON EXPANDING
HEALTHEQUITY THIS PROPOSAL
MOVES IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
IT WOULD CREATE A NEW CLASS OF
THE HOUSE AND HAVE NOTS IN
TELEHEALTH DEPENDING ON WHETHER
A PATIENT HAS ACCESS TO
BROADBAND INTERNET. SO AS THE
OTHERS SPEAKERS DOWN I'LL
ALKYLBENZENE I REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE REJECTED THIS
PROPOSAL AND INSTEAD EMBRACE
FULL PAYMENT PARITY FOR ALL
TELEHEALTH MODALITIES. AS A
PROPOSED ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TWO. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
JENNIFER STOLL WITH FORTUNE. I
THANK YOU CHAIR ARAMBULA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE RECORD I'M JENNIFER STOLE
IN THE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR
OCEAN AND THE CALIFORNIA
TELEHEALTH NETWORK. JIM LEADS
THE HEALTH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND ANALYTICS
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORTING OVER
THIRTY FOUR UNIQUE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS SERVING
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND HALF
OF THOSE PATIENTS. ARE
RECEIVING CARE UNDER MEDICARE
I'LL CALIFORNIA TELEHEALTH
NETWORK IS THE LEADING
CONSORTIUM OF ORGANIZATIONS
INCREASING ACCESS THROUGH
TELEHEALTH PLATFORMS AND
PROVIDING BROADBAND THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THROUGH ITS STATE
LEVEL AND FEDERAL LEVEL ARE
PROGRAMS MAKING AFFORDABLE. AND
WE ALSO RUN THEIR CURSOR FUNDED
CALIFORNIA TELEHEALTH THREE
CENTER RESOURCE CENTER WHICH
PROVIDES TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO THOSE- IMPLEMENTING
TELEHEALTH PLATFORMS- OCEANS
SUPPORTS THE DH CS TELEHEALTH
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO
EXPAND COVERAGE OF TELEHEALTH
SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIA UNDER
MEDICO. HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THE
TRAILER BILL AND THE PROPOSED
BUDGET DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH
TO ADDRESS STRUCTURAL
INEQUITIES THE DECISION NOT TO
COVER COULD NOT OFFER COVERAGE
INPAYMENT PARITY FOR AUDIO
ONLY TELEHEALTH SERVICES FOR
FQHCS IN ART SHE'S. WILL DRIVE
STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES WHICH IS
WHAT MR FOR JUSTREFERRED TO
YOU AND EXASPERATED HEALTH AND
DISPARITIES. FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES HARD. IN SECURITY
AND TRANSPORTATION BARRIERS AND
SINCE WE'RE A DATA ORGANIZATION
I WANTED TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE AGGREGATED DATA WE'RE
SEEING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO DURING 202037%
OF ALL THE ENCOUNTERS AT IN THE
OCEAN NETWORK WHICH WAS OVER
THREE MILLION PATIENT
ENCOUNTERS WERE CONDUCTED USING
TELEHEALTH. 46% OF THOSE
ENCOUNTERS IN TELEHEALTH WERE
DELIVERED IN A LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN ENGLISH THREE OUT OF FOUR
OF THOSE. OF THOSE TELEHEALTH
ENCOUNTERS WERE CONDUCTED IN
SPANISH. PATIENTS WHO STATED
THAT THEY NEEDED HOUSING OR
TRANSPORTATION SUPPORT WERE
FOURTEEN AND 17% MORE LIKELY TO
USE TELEHEALTH RESPECTIVELY. SO
WE WOULD ACTUALLY ARGUE THAT
TELEHEALTH ACT BOOK CLOSES
pBE IN PERSON HERE DELIVERS.
EVEN MORE INSTRUCTIVE TO THE
ANALYSIS OF DATA RELATED TO
AUDIO ONLY USE LAST YEAR ABOUT
26% OF THE PATIENTS SERVED BY-
JIM MEMBERS USED ONLY AUDIO
ONLY SERVICE IS. 51% OF AUDIO
ONLY ENCOUNTERS WORKING THAT
WERE IN THE LATIN NEXEN
HISPANIC POPULATION AND AGAIN
POPULATIONS THAT HAVE
STRUCTURAL CHALLENGES SUCH AS
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS RECEIVED GREATER CARE AN
AUDIO ONLY SERVICES HELPED
ACCESS THAT. I'M STILL LOOKING
TO THE FUTURE. WE ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGE THE- THIS COMMITTEE
TO. STRONG LOOK AT THIRTY TWO-
INSTEAD OF ADOPTING THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU FOR TAKING
MY TESTIMONY AND MOVING THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE FORWARD AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO HELP- YOU TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISSED ALL WITHOUT A WILL NOW
BRING IT UP TO THE DíAS FOR
MEMBERS QUESTIONS WE WILL BEGIN
WITH DOCTOR WOULD FOLLOWED BY
A- NUMBER OF. ACTUALLY MY LIFE
MORE COOPER COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS SO- SO I JUST WANT TO
EXPLAIN YOU KNOW MIGHT THAT
MIGHT MY THINKING ON THE ISSUE
A MEDIC CAL. A TELEHEALTH
COVERAGEAND PAYMENT PARITY.
ONE OF THE THINGS MANY THINGS
THAT CHANGE DURING THE PANDEMIC
IS HOW HEALTHCARE IS DELIVERED
IN GENERAL- HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS ARE NOW PROVIDING
CARES IN WAY IN NEW WAYS THAT
WE WOULD HAVE IMAGINED EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AGO- PRE COATED. WE'RE
NOT USING VIDEO AND PHONE CALLS
IN A WAY WE SIMPLY WEREN'T
DOING THAT- ONE OF THE WAY ONE
OF THE AREAS WE'VE SEEN. WHERE
WE'VE SEEN A SHIFT IN HOW CARE
IS DELIVERED AS IN FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES AND- WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT PATIENTS
HAVE GROWN ACCUSTOMED TO THIS.
AND IT CAN BE- IN MANY CASES
THEY ACTUALLY PREFERRED IT'S
MORE CONVENIENT. IT CAN ENSURE
PATIENT PRIVACY ELIMINATES
TRANSPORTATION TIME AND THE
NEED TO TAKE TIME OFF WORK.
THEY BRING SERVICES TO WHERE
THE PATIENT IS. WE'RE BUILDING
OFF OF A MEDICARE RATE
STRUCTURE THAT IN MANY CASES
BELOW COMMERCIAL PAYERS- PAY
FOR THE SAME SERVICES. SO I
THINK A PARITY REQUIREMENT
MEDICAL SERVICES FOR THESE-
SERVICES IS APPROPRIATE AND
NECESSARY. I ALSO THINK WE NEED
TO BE NOT MOVING TOWARDS
PAYMENT REFORM FOR FQHCS I KNOW
ANY TRANSITION IS HARD. BUT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF BANDAGES
TO AN ALTERNATIVE PATH PAYMENT
METHOD METHODOLOGY- AND NOT
JUST FOR TELEPHONE VISITS-
PAYMENT REFORM IS NOT JUST
ABOUT COVERAGE FOR TELEPHONE
CALLS. IT WILL ENABLE AN ABLE
ADVOCATE SEES TO- BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE TO SAME DAY MENTAL
HEALTH IS IT SOMETHING WE'VE
BEEN FIGHTING FOR IN THIS
LEGISLATURE FOR YEARS- USE NON
BILLABLE OF PROVIDERS. AND
PROVIDE SERVICES OUTSIDE THE
FOUR WALLS OF THE HEALTH
CENTER. THE AMENDMENTS TO- TO
AB THIRTY TWO AND I WHAT I WANT
TO SAY WE WORKED EXTENSIVELY
WITH- STAKEHOLDERS AND- AND-
THE AUTHOR- MOVED ACCURACIES IN
THAT DIRECTION. WHILE PROVIDING
CONTINUE COVERAGE FOR TELEPHONE
BUSINESS AND TELL ACCURACIES
CAN TAKE THE NEXT STEP. AS A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER MYSELF WHO
DELIVERED A SERVICES ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY IN PERSON IT'S
TAKEN ME TIME TO GET MY HEAD
AROUND WHAT'S THE NEW NORMAL-
WE PUT A LOT OF TIME AND EFFORT
INTO AB THIRTY TWO. I THINK THE
WORK I PUT INTO THE BILL BY THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS REPRESENTS
A REASONABLE COMPROMISE. THAT
PROTECTS PATIENT ACCESS AND
TAKES A BIG STEP TOWARDS AN
ALTERNATE PAID PAYMENT
METHODOLOGY. WRECKAGE IF
CHRISSY'S THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I MYSELF HAVE HEARD FROM-
HEALTH CENTERS ON. A FAMILY
PLANNING PROVIDERS AS WELL- AND
IT- OBVIOUSLY HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT DH. CS NOT EXTENDING
TELEHEALTH. FLEXIBILITIES IF
THE PANDEMIC HAS TAUGHT US
ANYTHING IS THAT. WE CAN KEEP
DOING BUSINESS LIKE WE HAVE
DONE BEFORE WE'VE SEEN THE
INEQUITIES. I HAVE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF. GOING TO YOUR
COMMUNITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND THE DIFFERENCES ARE
STARK BETWEEN L. A. COUNTY
WHICH I REPRESENT- AND ACROSS
THE STATE. AND YOU KNOW I COULD
BE VERY HAPPY WITH WHAT I HAVE
IN L. A. COUNTY BUT MY JOB IS
TO REPRESENT MY DISTRICT FIRST
BUT TO ALSO REPRESENT ALL. OF
CALIFORNIA AND- WE ALL KNOW
THAT BUSINESSES USUAL THE NOT
WORK THE PAST- WE HAVE TO START
GET OUT OF OUR COMFORT ZONE AND
I THINK THAT- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TO EXTEND FLEXIBILITY AS WE
HAVE TO BE. CONFIDENT THAT
ABOUT THE DIFFERENCES IN. THE
WAY THAT WE OFFER SERVICES AND
I LIKE FELT THAT SOMEBODY SAID
IT'S NOT A TELEPHONE CALL IT'S
PROVIDING SERVICES. WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A TELEPHONE CALL
WILL CALL THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PROVIDING SERVICES. TO
THOSE FOLKS THAT CANNOT- HAD
BEEN DO NOT TRYING TO DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO A SMARTPHONE OR
TO. TO THE BROADBAND AND IN
TERMS OF BROADBAND I'M A CO
SPONSOR OF A CO AUTHOR OF. AB
THIRTY TWO BECAUSE I TO BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE EQUITY. OF
UP AND DOWN THE STATE THAT IS
ONE WAY OF DOING IT THE OTHER
WAY OF DOING IT IS OVER THE
PHONE SOME OF OUR FOLKS CANNOT
AFFORD THE SMARTPHONES OR- EVEN
IF WE HAVE BROADBAND. THEY
DON'T KNOW HOW TO ACCESS THAT I
HAVE MY DAD IS EIGHTY MY MOM
IS. AT SEVENTY FIVE AND THEY
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO ACCESS- YOU
KNOW- THE BUDDHISM. BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW SO WE CAN
EXPECT THAT- YOU KNOW A
GENERATION THAT HAS NOT.
TRADITIONALLY YOU USED THE
COMPUTER TO ALL OF ALL OF A
SUDDEN TO BE USING THE COMPUTER
I REPRESENT A COMMUNITY. OF A
LOT OF- LATINOS ARE SPANISH
SPEAKERS ASIAN- SPEAKERS AND-
AND QUITE FRANKLY OLDER.
AMERICANS THAT. ARE NOT JUST
GOING TO TRANSITION FROM ONE TO
THE OTHER BUT THEY DO KNOW HOW
TO USE THE PHONE. AND IF WE CAN
GIVE THEM ACCESS TO THE PHONE
THAT WE HAVE TO BE- FLEXIBLE IN
WHAT WE DO AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE OFFER EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
BUT- MAKE THE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS HOLE. FOR THE
SERVICES THAT THEY ARE
PROVIDING SO I REALLY STRONGLY
URGE THAT WE CONTINUE. TO OR AT
LEAST GIVE SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
THOSE PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE TO.
PROVIDE SERVICES OVER THE PHONE
SOLD THANK YOU- MISTER. MISTER
JACK. AND NEXT WE WILL HEAR US.
RUNS THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. ECHOING- MANY OF THIS.
SOMETHING HAVE BEEN SET. OVER
IT'S GREAT TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND TELL HEALTH CARE
BUT- WE'RE GONNA MAKE WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
ADDRESSING ALL ON THE NEEDS OF
THOSE THAT ARE- SEEKING.
MEDICAL CARE. AND WE KNOW
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC AND WE
KNOW THAT BROADBAND INTERNET
ACCESS HAS BEEN SPOTTY TO SAY
THE LEAST. AND MANY-
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR INCLUDING-
INDIAN RESERVATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND SO WHEN WE START
TO TALK ABOUT MOVING IN THE
DISCUSSION OF THOSE GOING INTO
STRONGER. TELE HEALTH NET WERE
INTERNET IS NEEDED. WE HAVE TO-
ALSO. TALK ABOUT. THE PRICE OF
THE SERVICES PROVIDED BY THOSE
STILL USING- THE PHONES THE
AUDIO PHONES OF TELEPHONES
THOSE THINGS THAT STILL. ARE
PART OF AN AND INFRASTRUCTURAL.
NEEDS IN MANY OF OUR COMMUNITY.
SO WHEN WE START TO LOOK AT
THAT- WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
BRING UP THE QUESTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP IN
COMMENTS. ARE WE TRULY LOOKING
AT THAT AS WE'RE TRYING TO
INVOLVE THE HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE WE LOOKING AT
EVOLVING HEALTH CARE FOR ALL.
THOSE THAT THAT. HAVE INTERNET.
BUT THOSE THAT DON'T AND THOSE
THAT DON'T HAVE THAT ACCESS ARE
THE HIGH AREAS THAT WE'VE SEEN.
WITH UNDERLYING CONDITIONS THAT
ONE PANDEMICS DO COM WE SEEN
THEM SOME COME. TO THE
PANDEMICS AT HIGHER RATES SO
AND WE DO KNOW. THAT ALSO
PREVENTIVE MEDICINE IS THE
FIRST STEP. SO ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS TALKED ABOUT. HOW THEY
WERE ABLE TO TALK TO SOMEBODY.
ON ON A PHONE OR OR CONVERSE
WITH THEM. TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH OR ELSE
THEY WOULD END UP IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM. BACKING UP THE
BEDROOM LAYS IN THOSE TYPE OF
THINGS SO PRETTY. OP MET A
MATTER. IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE. BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE POPULATIONS THAT ARE
THERE AND SO SPEAKING UP. ON
THE THAT SIDE OF AUDIO-
TELEPHONES NON SMARTPHONES NOT
EVERYBODY IS A QUIPPED STILL IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S
AREAS. THAT STILL DON'T HAVE
TELEPHONE LINES RUNNING TO THEM
SO WE'RE NOT AS FAR YOU BOB AS
WE THINK AND THE MORE THAT WE
MOVE FORWARD AND FAILED TO
ADDRESS THOSE AREAS. BECOMES
EVEN MORE GREATER CONCERN. BUT
I DO HAVE A QUESTION AS FAR AS
THE- MINIMIZING OF
REIMBURSEMENTS DO WE HAVE ANY
STATISTICS DO WE HAVE ANY DATA.
THAT SHOWS THAT WE LOWER THOSE
REIMBURSEMENT COST WHAT WILL
THAT EFFECT BE ON THE PROVIDING
OF THE HEALTH CARE FOR THOSE-
UNDERPRIVILEGED COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING TO
GET THOSE SERVICES THERE. WELL
NOW WE LOWER THOSE THOSE
REIMBURSEMENT PAYMENTS WILL
THERE BE EVEN HARDER FOR THOSE
TO GET THE SERVICES THEY NEED
WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
HAVE JUST ADDRESSED. MISS
COOPER I BELIEVE THE QUESTION
WAS ADDRESSED TO YOU. SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE IS
TRACKING FOR THE VARIOUS PARTS
OF THE PROPOSAL- THE
DEPARTMENT- GREATLY EXPANDED-
OUR TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITIES
AND PROVISIONS ARE WITHIN OUR
PROPOSAL FROM WHAT WE HAVE
PRIOR TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY FAR BEYOND WHAT. WE
WERE DOING EVEN BEYOND WHAT WE
ARE PROVIDING AND PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AND I JUST THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT AND MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE IS. THIS IS FOLLOWING
THOSE NUANCES AND THAT INCLUDES
THAT PROVISION FOR US TO EXTEND
IT AND ALLOW FOR AUDIO ONLY
SERVICES TO BE PROVIDED- FOR
NON ACTUATES THE OUR PROVIDERS
JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT I'LL
GET TO THAT POINT A SECOND-
JUST ADDED. PAYMENT UP THE
SCHEDULE SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE BECAUSE THERE'S SOME
COMMENTS AT CLEARING HOUSE THAT
BUT SOME COMMENTS DID NOT AND I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE
TO ENSURE- WE ALSO. NOT JUST
THE IDEA ONLY GREATLY EXPANDED
OUR OUR FOOTPRINT IN THIS BASIC
KNOWLEDGE BEING THE LESSONS
LEARNED THROUGH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY THE ROLE THAT
IT PLAYED IN WHAT WE DO THINK
WILL IMPROVE. QUALITY AND
ACCESS TO CARE AND SERVICES.
I'M IN THE LONG RUN SO I THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT THING TO YOU
WE HIGHLIGHT MAKE SURE- IS A
SAID AGAIN. IN REGARDS TO THE
FQHCS AN AUDIO ONLY SERVICES
WHICH IS THE ONLY PLACE IN
WHICH THE PROPOSAL WHERE WE
HAVE. RESTRICTED ACCESS TO- THE
FLEXIBILITIES THAT WERE
AFFORDED DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. AS I
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY WE ARE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO ENGAGE. WITH
FQHCS IN REGARDS TO NOT ONLY
THE BUILDING OF THE LARGER
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
METHODOLOGY- I'D MENTIONED. AS
WE HAVE ALREADY BEGAN THAT KICK
OFF WE ARE HAVING EXTENSIVE IN
GREAT CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FQHCS TO
ENGAGE IN THAT EIGHT PM. R.
WHICH WE THINK IS CRITICAL I TO
MOVE THE NEEDLE IN REGARDS TO
HOW. THEY PROVIDE CARE IN THE
COMMUNITY IN THE ROLE THAT THEY
CAN HAVE A MEDIC CAL TO IMPROVE
QUALITY AND ACCESS TO CARE-
WHICH HAS A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES INCLUDING THE USE
OF AUDIO ONLY AND OTHER-
TELEHEALTH OPTIONS THAT YOU CAN
SEE M. S. CURRENTLY DOESN'T
ALLOW. A FEW WEEKS THESE TO
PROVIDE. I THINK THE GIVEN THE
CURRENT FEDERAL REGULATIONS IN
PLACE FOR FQHCS WE FIND
OURSELVES IN SOMEWHAT OF A
BIND- IN REGARDS TO MAKING IT
EQUAL TO THE NON ACCURACY
PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD BY THE
DEPARTMENT- HOWEVER. AGAIN IF.
YOU KNOW. THE ACCURACY CLINICS
ARE WILLING TO- TO WAVE AT TGS.
OF FOR THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
AUDIO ONLY SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENT IS WILLING AND ABLE
TO ENGAGE WITH THEM AND THEN
THE ALTERNATIVE OF RATE FOR
THOSE AUDIO. ONLY SERVICES I'M
TO BE EQUAL TO WHAT WE WOULD BE
PROPOSING- YOU KNOW IT'S
SIMILAR RATE FOR. AND THEN I
FQHCS. ARE JUST WANTED
HIGHLIGHT CALM AND HELP THAT IS
HELP TO ADDRESS THE COMMON MADE.
THANK YOU I'M GOING TO STAY
WITH YOU COOPER I CAN I FIRST
WANNA- UPLIFT AND ECHO THE
COMMENTS THAT TELEHEALTH HAS
BEEN AN ABSOLUTE ESSENTIAL
LIFELINE DURING THIS PANDEMIC
AND- ALSO SHARE THE CONCERNS
THAT THE PROPOSAL BEFORE US HAS
THE- POTENTIAL TO DRIVE
STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE SYSTEM. AND
I'M GROUNDING MYSELF AND SURE
ON WHICH WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
TODAY. AND REMINDING MYSELF OF
THE PEOPLE OF THE CITY AND HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS FOR THEM. IN A
POOR CITY TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO BOTH INTERNET OR
SMARTPHONES AND- THE STRUGGLE
THAT THAT COMMUNITY WILL HAVE
WITH THIS CURRENT PROPOSAL.
THAT I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
FROM YOU IF I CAN. THAT IT
SEEMED AS IF YOUR COMMENT WAS
THAT WE NEEDED A LOWER
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR AUDIO
VERSUS VIDEO AND IN PERSON. AND
YOUR CURRENT STRATEGY HAS BEEN
TO. PENALIZE THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE TELEPHONE. RATHER THAN TO
INCENTIVIZE. THOSE WHO ARE
DOING IN PERSON OR VIDEO. AND
I'M WONDERING IF YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THAT. FROM WHAT I
WOULD SAY THAT WOULDN'T BE IT
ADDS. UP YOU KNOW I THINK THEM
FOR AUDIO ONLY- BY ACKNOWLEDGE
THE COMMENTS THAT I MADE
EARLIER BY A FEMALE IN REGARDS
TO BETTER CALIBRATE. BUT I
WOULD SAY IS THAT IN HEALTHCARE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SERVICES IS
REFLECTIVE OF COSTS WHICH IS
WHY WE PAY MORE FOR A HOSPITAL
BED THAT THAT WE DO FOR AN
OUTPATIENT VISIT. AND WE
STRONGLY FELT THAT
REIMBURSEMENT SHOULD REFLECT
THE OVERALL TYPE OF SERVICE AND
COST OF THE SERVICE BEING
PROVIDED WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
ALIGNING OUR PROPOSAL- TO
SERVICES IN THAT WAY- AND THAT
IS THE DEPARTMENT YOU KNOW
CURRENT PROPOSAL- AND WE
UNDERSTAND. THE VALUE THAT IT
BRINGS WHICH IS WHY WE INCLUDED
IT IN THE PROPOSAL AND IT'S
ALSO WHY WE'RE WILLING TO
ENGAGE WITH A FEW ISSUES IN
REGARDS TO. WHAT WE CAN GET
THAT MOVING FORWARD- WITH THE
RATE THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
DO IT NOW MIND YOU WE LACK SOME
OF THE- I'M CONCERNED CMS HAS
IN REGARDS TO THAT BECAUSE OF
FEDERAL REGULATIONS. BUT I
THINK THE DEPARTMENT IS FULLY
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE A BROAD ACCESS TO
TELEHEALTH SERVICES INCLUDING
AUDIO ONLY IN THE FUTURE WHEN
APPROPRIATE. BUT I WOULD ALSO
RAISE THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE HAD
PEOPLE HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
US AROUND EQUITY FROM THE OTHER
SIDE. MAKING SURE THAT ALL
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ACCESS TO IN
PERSON CARE AND FOR QUALITY
CARE OF AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
BALANCE THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
WITH ALL OF THIS AND I THINK.
EARLIER DAVID SAID IT WELL IT'S
ABOUT THAT FORMULA WHEN IN
PERSON VERSUS AUDIO ONLY IS
AVAILABLE OF COURSE DURING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY SOME
PLACES ONLY HAVE ACCESS TO
AUDIO ONLY BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE TELEHEALTH EQUIPMENT AND
OFFICES WERE CLOSED AND THAT
WAS APPROPRIATE DURING. A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY OF THE
NATURE THAT WE JUST CROSSED BUT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND LOOK AT
WHAT OUR POLICY SHOULD BE IN
NEEDS TO FIND A BALANCE BETWEEN
THOSE THINGS TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS DO YOU HAVE ACCESS.
TO REALLY YOUR HIGH QUALITY
PREVENTATIVE SERVICES WHICH
DOES INCLUDE BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELEHEALTH. SERVICES INCLUDING
AUDIO ONLY SO I THINK THE WHERE
THE TO. IS TO FIND THAT I TAKE
A THE COM TODAY. YOU KNOW WE
ARE AT IT FROM MANY ANGLES AND
HOPEFULLY THAT'S HELPFUL IN
REGARDS TO WHERE WE ARE ON. ON
THE RATE THAT WE'RE PUTTING.
AND I HOPE YOU'RE HEARING FROM
MANY OF US IN THE LEGISLATURE
THE WORK TRYING TO ALSO FIND
THAT BALANCE. AND ARE CONCERNED
THAT THERE MAY BE. A DECREASE
ACCESS TO PREVENTATIVE
SERVICES- WITH. WHAT WE'RE
SPEAKING ABOUT AND JUST REALLY
HOPE WE CAN FIND A BALANCE THAT
MAKE SURE WERE- HAVING. A LENDS
TOWARDS EQUITY HAS WELL AND I
JUST. I APPRECIATE THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THIS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO. THANK
YOU I JUST WOULD LIKE TO. MAKE
A COMMENT YOU JUST STATED THAT
YOU'RE HEARING FROM THE OTHER
SIDE ABOUT BALANCE I DON'T SEE
HOW- A. I. TELEPHONIC- VISIT UP
TAKES AWAY FROM IN PERSON THERE
THAT I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THAT
COMMENT- AND NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO- I'M A FORMER TEACHER AND
WE ALSO WOULD HAPPEN WITH THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM WHERE WE'RE
PROVIDING. SERVICES JUST
BECAUSE WE WERE PROVIDING ZOOM
AS EDUCATION DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THE TEACHERS WERE PAID IN THE
LAST TEN IN THIS CASE JUST
BECAUSE WITH THE DOCTORS WERE
PROVIDING SERVICES OVER THE
PHONE DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE
DOCTORS WERE ANY LESS
QUALIFIED. OVER THE PHONE THAN
THEY ARE IN PERSON SO I REALLY
DON'T UNDERSTAND THOSE
COMMENTS- YOU KNOW IF ANYTHING
WE SHOULD BE- YOU KNOW.
CELEBRATING BECAUSE THAT WE ALL
KNOW THAT AFTER THIS PANDEMIC
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A SHORT A
SHORTAGE OF HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS BECAUSE OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING SO AGAIN I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THOSE TWO COMMENTS
AND- FIRST HOW IS IT THAT. BY
PROVIDING- OF PHONE- SERVICES
DECREASES THAT SERVICES FOR
THOSE IN PERSON SERVICES- AND
SO I MEAN AGAIN YOU KNOW I
THINK WE'RE LOOKING WE'RE ALL
LOOKING FOR EQUITY AND IF
THAT'S THE ARGUMENT I DON'T SEE
HOW IT'S VALID- ESPECIALLY
WHEN. YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO
DO THE BEST THAT WE CAN WITH
WHAT WE HAVE IN AGAIN FOR THE
PROVIDERS DOING. TELEPHONE
PROVIDING SERVICES BY TELEPHONE
DOESN'T DIMINISH DIMINISH IN
THE M. THE SERVICE IN MY
OPINION IT DIDN'T DIMINISH IT-
FOR TEACHERS AND YES WE ALL HAD
PROBLEMS- YOU KNOW TRYING TO
FIGURE IT OUT. BUT THE TEACHERS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE PAID LESS
BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING ZOOM-
EDUCATION AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT YOU KNOW THE SERVICE IS
PROVIDED BY MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS SHOULD BE LAST
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE DOING OVER
THE PHONE SO IF YOU CAN. HELP
ME UNDERSTAND THAT COMMENT
ABOUT HOW. ONE BIG ONE
DECREASES THE OTHER. CHART BE
TO. SO I THINK WHAT I
MENTIONING IS THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN VISITS ADMISSION BY
MANY OF THE SPEAKERS PREVIOUS
TO ME- AT THAT SHOULD BE DONE
IN PERSON. RESIDENTS ARE YOU
ONLY AS I MENTIONED IN MY
COMMENTS THERE IS. A PERFECT
ROLE FOR AUDIO ONLY SERVICES I
THINK PART OF THE CARE BEING
PROVIDED TO SOMEBODY. OF THAT
THERE ARE VISITS THAT DO NEED
TO TAKE PLACE IN PERSON-
ADDRESS MENTIONED BY BY MANY
SPEAKERS AND MOST PHYSICIANS IN
REGARDS TO WHEN THEY'RE
PRESENTING THIS PIECE AND SO.
THAT'S WHAT MY COMMENT WAS IN
REGARDS I CAN GIVE YOU SOME
EXAMPLES. DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY MAJORITY OF-
VISITS WERE BEING PROVIDED VIA
EITHER TELEHEALTH IN ORDER
AUDIO ONLY VISIT. HOWEVER WE
HAD A SIGNIFICANT DECREASE IN
REGARDS TO THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN RECEIVING
IMMUNIZATIONS- DURING THE LAST
YEAR WE HAD A SIGNIFICANT DIP
DECREASE. IN REGARDS TO THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN- WHO WERE
GETTING THEIR WELL CHILD VISITS
WHICH REQUIRE CERTAIN PIECES.
OF THOSE VISITS THE IN PERSON
SO MY COMMENTS WERE REALLY MORE
AROUND THE FORMULA AND I FEED
BY THAT I MEAN A COMBINATION
OF. IN PERSON VISITS AND AUDIO
ONLY BEING AVAILABLE TO
INDIVIDUALS AS THERE'S A CLEAR
NEED. TO ENSURE THAT PATIENTS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SEE THEIR
PROVIDER IN PERSON. AND TO BE
ABLE TO GET SOME OF THE TYPES
OF CARE THAT CAN'T BE PROVIDED
VIA AUDIO ONLY. VERY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE FACT THAT
IT IS ALSO COMPLEMENTARY FOM
AN ACCESS POINT BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY NOT SOMETHING THAT
CAN ONLY BE PROVIDED IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT WE IMPROV. AND
HAVE GOOD QUALITY OUTCOMES FOR
CERTAIN SCREENINGS AND SERVICES
THAT MEET THE NEEDS TO BE DONE
IN PERSON SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT
MY COMMENT WAS REGARDING. JUST
MAKING SURE IT'S A PART OF THE
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED BUT NOT
BE ON THE MODALITIES AVAILABLE
TO PEOPLE. AFFECTED BY
CONFLICT. WHAT ABOUT RIGHT BUT
BUT I THINK THE COMMENTS- IF I.
MADE THE COMMENT THAT WE'RE
MAKING IS NOT SPECIFICALLY TO
PROVIDE ONLY TELEPHONIC- VISITS
I THINK. THIS IS WHAT WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE. A VARIETY OF WAYS
TO BE MAKE SURE THAT. SOME
FOLKS ACCESS AND OF COURSE I
AND- THAT THAT ARE NOT GOING TO
BE. OVER THE PHONE. AND SO I
DON'T. UNDERSTAND THAT COMMENT
EITHER- AND I DON'T THINK THAT-
A PROVIDER OVER THE PHONE IS
GOING TO. FADE TO OUR PATIENTS-
DON'T BRING YOUR KIDS AND LET'S
JUST DO THIS OVER THE PHONE. SO
I DID SO JUST SO THAT WE DON'T
GET INTO KIND OF THAT. BACK AND
FORTH- THIS IS NOT ABOUT A GUY
BIG BUT WE'RE ALL TRYING TO DO
IS MAKE SURE THAT WERE
EQUITABLE IN THE SERVICE
PROVIDED IN SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ONLY HAVE. ACCESS
TO WHEN THEY ARE ABLE TO GO
THEY CAN GO BUT A LOT OF TIMES
ARE NOT ABLE TO GOAL THE WORK
LONG HOURS. AND IF THIS IS THE
WAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE AT
LEAST- BEGIN TO OFFER SOME KIND
OF HEALTH. SOME SOME KIND OF-
SERVICES AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THAT. IT'S NOT
ONE VERSUS THE OTHER AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
A BALANCE. BUT AGAIN THE
PROVIDERS ARE NOT. ANY LESS
THEY'RE NOT PROVIDING ANY LESS-
CARE. IF THEY'RE DOING IT OVER
THE PHONE AND SO FOR ME THE
EQUITY IS- FOR THE COMMUNITY
BUT ALSO FOR THE PROVIDERS THAT
ARE. ARE ARE DOING THIS AND SO.
I THINK WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THIS
IT WE SHOULDN'T TALK ABOUT IT-
OF ONE VERSUS THE OTHER. AND I
THAT'S WHAT I HEARD I KNOW IF
I. HEARD THAT INCORRECTLY- THEN
THEN. I THEN I YEAH I WOULD
MAKE SURE NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF
MY COMMENTS- BUT I WITH I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT IT'S NOT ONE VERSUS THE
OTHER AND- YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
GETTING INTO THAT I THINK WHAT
WE'RE SAYING OR AT LEAST WHAT
I'M SAYING AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES ARE SAYING IS THAT
WE HAVE TO HAVE EVERYTHING
AVAILABLE SO THAT FOLKS THAT
NOW HAVE LEARNED THAT THEY CAN
ACCESS HEALTH CARE- ARE STILL
ABLE TO DO IT NOT JUST IN L. A.
COUNTY MY COMMUNITY BY THE UP
AND DOWN THE STATE. AND M
ARAMBULA COMMUNITY DOCTOR WITH
COULD DOCTOR REGULAR DOCTOR
WORDS COMMUNITIES AND OF MR
BOMBS OF COMMUNITIES ARE ARE
YOU KNOW ONES THAT ARE OF THE
HIGHEST NEED AND IF WE CAN
PROVIDE SOME KIND OF SERVICES
FOR THEM THEN LET'S DO IT I
THINK THAT WERE IN A POINT
WHERE WE HAVE TO LOOK FORWARD
WE CAN'T KEEP GOING BACK TO THE
THINGS THAT WE USED TO DO ALL
BECAUSE THIS IS HOW WE'VE
ALWAYS DONE IT THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY IN AGAIN IF THE
PANDEMIC HAS TAUGHT US ANYTHING
IS THAT. WE NEED TO LOOK FOR
ADDITIONAL OPTIONS NOT TAKE
AWAY WHAT WE'VE ALREADY DONE
JUST BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC IS
GOING TO BE OVER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO THANK VERY MUCH THE ENTIRE
PANEL ON ISSUE NUMBER FIVE WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO PANEL SIX.
ON THE OFFICE OF MEDICARE
INNOVATION AND INTEGRATION. WE
WILL HAVE TO SPEAKERS ON THIS
PANEL WILL LIGHT BORN IN JC
COOPER. PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
HOME DR RANDALL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I'LL BE PRESENTING
THIS ITEM WILDLIFE MORE DIRECT
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES- GOOD APARTMENT IS
REQUESTING A MORE PERMANENT
POSITIONS ON THE SIX HUNDRED
AND TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND FOR ESTABLISHING
YOU OFFICE OF MEDICARE
INNOVATION AND INTEGRATION. ALL
WITHIN THE DIRECTOR'S OFFICE TO
PROVIDE FOCUSED LEADERSHIP
EXPERTISE ON INNOVATIVE MODELS
AND STRATEGIES FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES IN CALIFORNIA ALL
THE OFFICE WOULD FOCUS ON
PROGRAM AND BENEFIT
IMPROVEMENTS AND MORE
INTEGRATED CARE FOR DUAL
ELIGIBLE MEDICARE AND MEDI CAL
AND. MEDICARE ONLY BENEFICIAL.
ALL THIS PER IS PART BECAUSE
MASK PLAN FOR AGING IS RELEASED
IN JANUARY. OUR CALIFORNIA WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SIX POINT SIX
MILLION MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
ALL ONE POINT SIX MILLION OF
THEM ARE DUAL ELIGIBLES ON THE
ELIGIBLES IS HAVING ALL
GENERALLY WORSE HEALTH
CONDITIONS THAT ARE MOVING OUT
OF. THE MEDICARE ONLY
POPULATION- WORTH NOTING OF
COURSE APPROPRIATE HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR MANY OF WHOM ARE THE
DOLLS- PONTOPPIDAN EXISTING
HEALTH DISPARITIES. SO THIS
OFFICE WOULD JOIN. THE WORK
UNDERWAY ACROSS ALL DEPARTMENTS
HEALTHCARE SERVICES DEPARTMENT
AGING PUBLIC HEALTH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH CARE
PARTICULARLY FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. ON SOME OF THE
POLICY OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
SEE ALL AVAILABLE ALL OF THE
LOCALITY HAS DEVELOPED A
COMPONENT FOR INTEGRATED
SERVICES. DELIVERY FOR DAHLE
ALL PEOPLE POPULATIONS ALL WE
WANT TO BUILD ON THOSE PROBLEMS
EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS MATERNAL
PERMISSIBLE IN MEDICARE
ADVANTAGE PLANS. BUT ARE NOT
YET A WIDELY USED IN CALIFORNIA
PLEASE INCLUDE THE SORTS OF ALL
NON DISEASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES
THAT CAN HELP PEOPLE REMAIN
INDEPENDENT LIVING AT HOME. ALL
BIG OFFER OPPORTUNITIES TO.
SUPPORT TO A- THE GRADUATION
ALL TIME ME TO MY- ALL
CROWDSTRIKE TO SUPPORT KELLER.
ALL DOGS BROADLY THE APPROACH
TO LAW TERM SO AND SUPPORTS.
ALL FOR MEDICARE INDIVIDUALS
WHO AREN'T ELIGIBLE FOR.
MEDICAID ALL. LTSS OUR MEMBERS
THERE SEVERAL QUESTIONS POSED
BY STAFF ALL. FIRST WAS WHY WE
HAVE NOT PROPOSED TO CHRYSLER
BUILT FROM FRANKLIN. SPONSORS
THAT ALL WE DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC
OFFICES WITHIN THE FCS OR
DIVISION SOLVER STRUCTURES
NAMES AND STATUTE OF OUR WE'RE
COMMITTED TO ESTABLISHING THIS
OFFICE PROVIDING FOCUSED
LEADERSHIP MEDICARE ISSUES BOB
AND STATUTORY AUTHORITY IS NOT
NECESSARY. ADULT RESPECTFULLY
AND OF COURSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE- DEPARTMENT
TO MAINTAIN SOME DEGREE OF
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW WE DEPLOY
AND USE RESOURCES OVER TIME.
AND HOW WE INTEGRATE DIFFERENT
ASPECTS. ALL THE- QUESTION FOR
OPPOSED TO BOTH LESSONS LEARN
FROM CAL. ALL A FUNDAMENTALLY
BAKER ONE OF COURSE WAS THAT IT
WAS VERY HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN TERMS OF ALIGNING
ALL INTEGRATING SERVICES BY
ALIGNING WITH MEDICARE AND MEDI
CAL PAYMENT STRUCTURES AND THIS
REPRESENTS LOTS OF SORT OF
PARTICULAR SCALE THE YOUNG LADY
CAL MEDICAMENT. COUNTIES WHEN
THEY WENT CALVET CONNECT AND
ALL THE OFFICE WILL WORK ACROSS
MULTIPLE TEAMS IN THE CS AND
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS ARE TO
ALSO. BE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF WOULD BE STEP
UP. PROGRAMS LEVEL- IT'LL
PARTNER CLOSELY WITH. THE
DIMENSIONAL MEDIC CONNECT
BROUGHT GOAL THE OF THEIR ALL
MY BOTH OBSERVED IN K. CAN
STRONG AND OF HAVING PLANS
INVOLVED AND THESE CRIMES FROM
AND CARE TO COMMUNITY SO THESE
ARE THE SORTS OF ALL WAYS IN
WHICH I FORESEE A BUILDING ON
TOP OF THE ON. THE COUNT MANY
CONNECT IT ALSO COMMENTED
CONNECT VERY MUCH FROM STRONG
STRONG FORECLOSURE WITH CMS ALL
AND WE'RE SORT OF MAINTAINING.
WEEKLY CADENCE OF MEETINGS.
WITH CMS AND WE'RE- I THIS
POINT. AT A POINT WHERE WE KNOW
WE ARE ALL WORK WITH THE-
FEDERAL. NOT SURE OF THE LAW OF
OUR ARMED GOAL FOR INTEGRATED
CARE- AND THEN TURNS OF THE
METRICS AND OUTCOMES THAT WILL
BE LOOKING TO. ALL ESPECIALLY
THE PRIMARY ONE COURSES TO MAKE
HEADWAY IN THIS AREA HOME BUILD
THE PROGRESSION ACTIVITIES WORK
WITH ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS-
KEEP EVERYONE INVOLVED MAKE
PROGRESS ON THE MASTER PLAN
FOR. HAS GROWN A LOT IN GAUGE
AFFECT LATE WITH THE HEALTH
MEDICARE ADVANTAGE PROVIDERS
ALONG AND DEVELOPING NO
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS SO. OFTEN
OPTIONS SO- WOULD BATTLE SPOKE.
HAPPY TO ANSWERING. FOR THE
COMMITTEE HAS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DIRECTOR I WILL IT BACK UP
TO THE DENTIST SEE IF MY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE I'D
LIKE TO DIG INTO THAT LAST
RESPONSE IF I COULD REGARDING
HOW WE DETERMINE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE OFFICE I.
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT- WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DETERMINE IF
THIS WAS A GOOD INVESTMENT AND-
HOPING THAT- YOU CAN COMMENT ON
HOW THE LEGISLATURE CONTRACT
AND- MAKE SURE THE MONEY WE
SPENT WAS SPENT. WHAT I THINK
WHAT I WOULD ALMOST SAY IS THAT
WE FULLY EXPECT TO BE SORT OF
COMING BACK BEFORE YOU CAN MOVE
BUDGET HEARINGS AND SUBSEQUENT
YOURS UPDATING YOU ON THE
PROGRESS THAT THE OFFICE OF
INNOVATION PROGRESSIONS THE
MOBILE TO MAKE ALL AND I. THANK
I HOPE WE'LL BE ABLE TO SORT OF
ALSO DEMONSTRATE THROUGH THE
ENGAGEMENT AND SATISFACTION
FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO
HELPED DEVELOP THE BEST PLAN ON
AGING- THEY'RE ALL PERCEPTION.
OF REALIZED THE REALIZATION OF
THE GOALS. THIS OUT ALL. I
THINK THAT'S THE PRIMARY WAY
THAT PEOPLE KEEP. THE
LEGISLATURE ALL INFORMED. ON
THE PROGRESS BEING MADE.
WITHOUT I WILL THANK THE PANEL
MOVING TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
WITH THE SAME PANEL ON THE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
MEDICAL BILLING OPTION ALSO
KNOWN AS ELLIE T. A. B. O. P.
PROGRAM EXPANSION AGAIN OUR
SPEAKERS ON THIS PANEL OR WILL
LIGHT BORN AND CASEY COOPER.
CAN WE PLEASE BEGIN. ASSEMBLY
THANK YOU. SO HERE THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING EIGHT
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND TO
LIMITED TERM CONTRACTS WITH
EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN THE YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
FORWARD THE RESOURCES BOTH
SUPPORT THE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES MEDICARE BILLING
OPTION PROGRAM OR WHAT'S
REFERRED TO AS A LIAISON.
SPECIFICALLY THE POSITIONS AND
CONTRACT FUNDING WILL HELP
SUPPORT A NUMBER OF INITIATIVES
INCLUDING AN EXTENSIVE OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN TO NON PARTICIPATING
ELEAZAR WE DO SEE SIGNIFICANT
VALUE IN IN REGARDS TO
PROVIDING THESE SERVICES IN
SCHOOLS AND SO WE DO WANT TO
ENCOURAGE ALIENS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING TO JOIN THE
PROGRAM AND SO RESOURCES WOULD
BE FOCUSED ON THAT ALSO WE
WOULD HAVE THE VENDOR HELP US
DEVELOP A TRANSITION PLAN FOR
THE LONG TERM OUR REGION
TRAINING ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD
BE OF THE. STAFF WOULD BE
ENGAGING IN AS WELL.
ADDITIONALLY AS WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF TEMPLE ONE OF THE
STATE PLAN AMENDMENT THAT WAS
APPROVED LAST YEAR FOR THE L.
A. BACH PROGRAM. OF THE STAFF
WOULD BE HELPING TO- CLEAR FINE
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
LEDS IN REGARDS TO FIX BENEFIT
BENEFITS FOR THAT ACCOUNT WHICH
WILL STUDENTS WITH THE CARE
PLAN. AS WELL AS THE ALLOWABLE
PROVIDER TYPES AND SO PROVIDING
THAT TECHNICAL. ENSURE THAT WE
ARE SUCCESSFUL. I'M SO WE DID
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS WHICH I
WANT TO MAKE SURE TO ADDRESS UP
FOR YOU ALL ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS HAD TO DO WITH
SIGNET- WHETHER IT'S SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES. OF THE DEPARTMENT
DOES BELIEVE THAT OUR REQUEST
IS SUFFICIENT IN ORDER TO HELP
MEET THE NEEDS OF ELEAZAR TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM. AND
I DO THINK THAT IT WOULD SERVE
ALL OF OUR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
NEEDS TO KIND OF HAVE THAT
GROWTH OVER TIME TO BRING ON
NEW ELLIE EIGHT. AND
INDIVIDUALS INTO THE PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE- IN
REGARDS TO YOU ARE YOU KEYS.
ARE AND WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE NEW INDIVIDUALIZED
PLAN- AS AND THE IDPS FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS SO.
I EAT. I EAT PEAS SORRY- OUR
SEGMENTS WHICH ARE PERFORMED TO
DETERMINE IF YOU DIDN'T
ELIGIBILITY FOR SERVICES UNDER
FEDERAL. INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES EDUCATION ACT OR
THE IDEA. THAT INDIVIDUAL CARE
PLANS ARE BROADER IN NATURE AND
ARE USED BY THE LTA AS A
MEDICAL MANAGEMENT TOOL FOR
PROVIDING MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
DIRECT HEALTHCARE SERVICES TO A
STUDENT IN A SCHOOL SETTING
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
STUDENT QUALIFIES. FOR SERVICES
UNDER THE IDEA- STUDENTS I DO
NOT NEED TO RECEIVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES TO HAVE AN
INDIVIDUALIZED PLAN. THIS
CHANGE HAS EXPANDED THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS THAT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE L. A. BOX WITH
HIS EX. IT IS GREATLY EXPANDED
FROM WHAT WAS AVAILABLE BEFORE.
HOWEVER IN ORDER TO- BILL FOR
THOSE. BOB SERVICES AGAIN YOU
HAVE TO HAVE IT WITH IN THE-
INDIVIDUALIZED PLANS TO JUST
NOTATING THAT. PART IS IT'S
STILL A REQUIREMENT THERE. AND
THEN WE THEIR V. INDIVIDUAL HOW
OF THE PLAN A MATTER MANAGED
TOOL FOR. THOSE MEDICALLY.
SERVICES AS I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY IN THE SCHOOL
SETTING UP AND THAT PLAN MUST
BE DEVELOPED BY A REGISTERED
CREDENTIALED SCHOOL NURSE OR A
QUALIFIED MEDICAL PRACTITIONER
ACTING WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE PARENT OR GUARDIAN. IF
APPROPRIATE- THE STUDENTS AS
WELL. IT'S NOT BE ENROLLED IN
MEDICARE ALL ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL FUNDS UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY TWO YEARS I'M ATTENDING
A PUBLIC SCHOOL REQUIRE MEDICAL
NECESSITY OF THE HEALTH
SERVICES BEING OFFERED. AND
HAVE AN INDIVIDUALIZED OF
PLANTS RECEIVED THE L. A. BACH
SERVICES SO HOPEFULLY THAT
HELPS CLARIFY AT THE NEW
REQUIREMENT THAT WAS APPROVED
IN THE STATE PLAN. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU. THANK
YOU WITHOUT IT WILL BRING IT UP
TO THE DíAS TO SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS. SINAN
I'D LIKE TO- DAY AND A LITTLE
BIT I- AND- I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BUT IT SEEMS AS IF
THIS PROGRAM IS ON. NOT
FUNCTIONED VERY WELL FOR A FEW
YEARS- THEREBY LEAVING A LOT OF
FEDERAL DOLLARS AND LIMITING
OUR ABILITY FOR OUR SCHOOLS TO
HELP PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. AND I'M TOLD
THAT THE PROGRAM HAS
EXPERIENCED UP 275% OF FEDERAL
DISALLOWANCE IS- FOR CLAIMS AND
MANY ELEAZER CHOOSE NOT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM DUE
TO ITS COMPLEXITY. GIVEN THIS
IS THIS PROPOSAL INTENDED AND
ENVISIONED TO BE MEANINGFUL
REFORM SUFFICIENT FOR THIS
PROGRAM TO REACH ITS FULL
POTENTIAL. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- I WOULD SAY THAT-
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME HISTORICAL
CLAWBACKS TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL RULES THE STATE PLAN
AMENDMENT THAT WAS APPROVED
RECENTLY BY CMS IN TWENTY
TWENTY- WAS SUBMITTED A VERY
LONG TIME AGO AND IT TOOK A
LONG TIME FOR US TO NEGOTIATE
WITH CMS AND GET THAT APPROVAL.
I'M WHICH HAS RESULTED IN SOME
CHALLENGES AS WELL AS
HISTORICAL COMPLAINTS IN THIS
PROGRAM HOWEVER THE CURRENT
TEAM WHO IS LEADING THE L. A.
BACH PROGRAM HAS BEEN DOING NO
MEN'S WORK I TO ENGAGE WITH A
LIAISON TO- TO DO EXTENSIVE
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION THEY'RE
CREATING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TOOLS. I'M IN REALLY ALL OF
THAT IS TO AID IN REGARDS TO
GETTING MORE INFORMATION OUT
THERE AROUND ON HOW WE CAN
EXPAND THE SERVICES IN SCHOOLS
HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE ELEAZAR
UNDERSTANDING THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND RULES AND
SIMPLIFYING WHERE WE POSSIBLY
CAN. I WERE EVEN GIVING IT A
DEEP DIVE IN REGARDS TO YOU-
WHEELS THAT MAKING SURE THAT
IT'S NOT JUST THE FEDERAL RULES
WORKING FINE BUT THERE HAVEN'T
BEEN HISTORICAL STATE RULES
THAT WERE PUT IN PLACE IS THAT
WE ARE DOING THOSE EVALUATIONS
AS WELL. SO WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS VERY
COMMITTED YOU ARE MAXIMIZING
OUR FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR
SERVICES IN SCHOOLS- AND
PROVIDING THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ELEAZAR INCLUDING
GETTING NEW ALLEY IF YOU
HAVEN'T HISTORICALLY
PARTICIPATED TO PARTICIPATE.
THAT'S ALSO WHY YOU HAVE THAT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IN SCHOOLS
FOR FOOTBALL ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR
CONSIDERATION TO- HAVE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES ARE
PROVIDING SERVICES INSTALLED IN
DRYING DOWN THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS
I. TO MAKE SURE STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT SIR. I'M I'M
REALLY ENCOURAGED HEAR YOU
DOING OUTREACH THE NONPARTISAN.
L. A. AND WOULD. INTO YOU TO DO
AS MUCH TRAINING AND GUIDANCE
AS WE CAN TO ARE ONLY AS TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE- DOING ALL WE
CAN TO PUBLISH FEDERAL DOLLARS
TO- WITH THAT I WILL THANK VERY
MUCH PANEL SEVEN WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO PANEL EIGHT ON THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM. WE WILL
HAVE THREE SPEAKERS ON THIS
PANEL WILL LIFE BORN TRACY
COOPER MICHELLE CABRERA. WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION PLEASE
BEGIN. SO I'LL TAKE THE
COMMENTS FOR THE DEPARTMENT ON
THIS ONE. I'M THIRTY EIGHT YES
IS REQUESTING NINE HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS- AND
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
THOUSAND- TOTAL FUNDS OF FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
TO SUPPORT THE EQUIVALENT OF
THREE POSITIONS. IN CONTRACT
RESOURCES TO ADMINISTER THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM- IN THE
PROPOSAL WE DO RECOMMEND THAT A
FOURTEEN MILLION PEOPLE
PAYMENTS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND TO ALL COUNTIES FOR
START UP COSTS AND THEN
ADDITIONAL. ON SEVEN POINT
SEVEN FIVE MILLION IN A
CONVENIENT CENTER PROGRAMS.
EITHER METHODOLOGY FOR
IMPLEMENTING THAT THE H. Q. I.
P. ON THE ADDITIONAL INTERVIEWS
CHIU AP WILL ASSIST COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANS AND
COUNTY JEFF MEDICARE PLANS
PREPARE FOR. OF THE VAST
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN CALLING.
THE DOLLARS ARE SPECIFIC TO
INCENTIVIZING PAYMENTS IN
SYSTEMS FOR BOTH. DECIDE TO
HAVE THE COUNTIES BE READY. IT
WOULD INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
CONVERTING THE COUNTY LEVEL
BUILDING ON TO A AT WHAT'S
CALLED THE HECTIC LEVEL ONE
CODE. ON AS WELL AS UPDATING
COUNTY IT SYSTEMS FOR THE
CHANGES BEING PROPOSED IN THE
MEDICALLY NECESSITY
DETERMINATION AND STANDARDIZED
FORMS THAT ARE WITHIN CALLING.
IT WOULD INCORPORATE MANAGED
CARE AND OTHER UTILIZATION DATA
FROM DH CS. TO BE INCORPORATED
INTO THE COUNTIES AND SYSTEMS
OF CARE. FOR EXAMPLE A TO KNOW
WITH A PRESCRIPTION HAS BEEN
FILLED BY A BENEFICIARY AND
HAVING THAT INFORMATION GO BACK.
INTO THEIR SYSTEM. DATA
INTERFACE TO IN THE THAT CARE
THE BEING PROVIDED. AND THE
LAST THING DEFINITELY LEAST A
MANY OF THIS THE- ARE CHANGES
WOULD BE ALSO FOR TO EVENTUALLY
CALL BETTER- DATA OUR TOWN
PARTNER. TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
QUALITY OUR PROGRAMS AND
DASHBOARDS WITHIN THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SPACE. ON THE
DEPARTMENT HAS WORKED CLOSELY
WITH ON TV HDA IN THE COUNTIES
IN REGARDS TO THE P. H. Q. I.
P. I'M INCLUDING- ARE PROPOSED
METHODOLOGY FOR THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE FUNDS- AND
MANY OF THE CHANGES THAT WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING ULTIMATELY I
BENEFIT THE COUNTIES IN TERMS
OF STREAMLINING OPERATIONS
IMPROVING EFFICIENCIES.
DECREASING WASTE IMPROVING OUR
REIMBURSEMENT THROUGH THE
PAYMENT REFORM THAT'S PROPOSING
CALLING AND HELPING PROVIDERS
USE MORE OF THEIR TYPE OF-PATIENT CARE ALL OF WHICH
IMPROVE ON THE COUNTIES ARE
PART OF MIND IN IMPROVEMENTS
STUFF. HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
WHEN IT IS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM A SHELL COMPANY.
WITH C. B. H. T. F. C. SHE MAY
BE HAVING. DIFFICULTIES HAS NOT
LOGGED ON AT THIS MOMENT. DR
ARAMBULA I'M GONNA APOLOGIZE ON
THE SHOW CAPITA CAP SHE WAS
UNFORTUNATELY UNAVOIDABLY
PULLED AWAY AND I'M GONNA BE
STEPPING IN TO RESPOND TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE OUTLINED IN
THE IN THE AGENDA. YESTERDAY I
THOUGHT THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR CBH DA-
I'M HOPING THAT THAT'S OKAY FOR
ME TO CONTINUE. I PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
ACTUALLY CASEY DID A WONDERFUL
JOB OF EXPLAINING EXACTLY THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE'VE BEEN
UNDERGOING OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS FROM THE U. H. QUIPPED-
IT'S ESSENTIAL FUNDING FOR ALL
TO SUPPORT THE EXTENSIVE
OPERATIONAL SYSTEM CHANGES THE
CHARACTER HERE ARE HEALTH PLANS
ARE GOING TO BE UNDERTAKING
FOR. REFORM THE MEDICAL
NECESSITY CHANGES ANOTHER
CALLIE PROPOSAL'S INCENTIVE
FUNDING WILL BE ALLOCATED BASED
ON THE RECOMMENDATION OF
MILESTONES THAT COUNTIESARE
EXPECTED. TO ACHIEVE TO RECEIVE
THE FUNDS WE SUPPORT YOU THINK.
EACH QUICK. FUNDS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE IT WILL. ALLEN CHANGES
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
EACH CHANGES GOING TO REQUIRE
EXTENSIVE TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
COUNTY. FIGHTERS AS WELL AS
CHANGES THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS AND OTHER
OPERATIONS HAS MANAGED CARE.
LANCE COUNTY OR WELL POSITIONED
TO DETERMINE WHERE FUNDS ARE
MOST NEEDED LOCALLY DIRECTLY
THE QUESTION TO WITH- WITH MUCH-OF THE THEFT. BUT STILL UNDER
DEVELOPMENT IT'S A BIT
DIFFICULT FOR US TO REALLY BE
ABLE TO RESPOND ABOUT WHETHER
THE FUNDS ALLOCATED INSTANTIATE
EFFORTS ARE GOING TO BE
ADEQUATE ARE YOU CONSIDERING
THE MAGNITUDE THE CHANGES
NEEDED C. B. H. T. F.
DEFINITELY DOES SUPPORT THE
MULTI YEAR- INCENTIVE FRAMEWORK
OUTLINED BY THE ACS AND SO FAR
THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE'VE HAD.
THE FREE MARKET'S GONNA PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES AT DIFFERENT
STAGES FOR COUNTIES TO BEGIN.
TO MEET THE MILESTONES AND THEN
AT THOSE POINTS EVALUATE THE
ADEQUACY OF BOTH THE T.
AFTERWARDS AND THE FUNDS
APPROPRIATED FOR THE PURPOSE
SO- AGAIN WE THANK I'M HERE YES.
FOR THE PARTNERSHIP ON THIS
EFFORT. HI THANK YOU WITHOUT I
WILL BRING BACK UP TO THE DIE
TO SEE IF WE ARE ANY NUMBER
QUESTIONS. SCENE NONDA I WILL
THANK THIS PANEL VERY MUCH AND
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NINE. ON TO DH CS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROPOSALS. THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM AND
INCREASED ACCESS TO STUDENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. WE
WILL HAVE FOUR SPEAKERS ON THIS%
PANEL WILL LIGHT BORN TRACY
COOPER TOBY EWING AND- ELIADE
GUY YARD. SO CAN WE PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU OF ALL START
WITH THE COMMENTS BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT- SO APPLE'S FIRST
WILL KIND OF GO OVER SOME OF
OUR REQUEST ON THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUING
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS THE
OVERARCHING I'M REQUEST ON THE
STUDENT BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES IN REGARDS TO OUR P.
C. P. REQUEST AND THEN I WILL-
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS THERE IS A
HANDFUL OF THEM ARE AT. FOR THE
FOR THE COMMITTEE HERE THE DH
CS IS REQUESTING- TWO POINT TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
TWO POINT ONE FIVE FIVE GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TO
SUPPORT EQUIPMENT UP FOR
POSITIONS IN CONTRACT RESOURCES
TO ADMINISTER THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM THE FUNDING WOULD BE
SHIFTED FROM THE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION NE TIME
GENERAL FUND AND LOCAL SYSTEMS
PROPOSED THAT OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE
RESOURCES WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
THE COMMUNICATIONS THE FEEDBACK
MECHANISMS BETWEEN ACCOUNTING
AND TRAVEL PARTNERS IN REGARDS
TO THE AVAILABLE FUNDS-
INCLUDING INFORMATION NOTICES
WEAPON ARE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WOULD BE NEEDED
ADDITIONALLY THE RESOURCES WITH
MONSTER THAT WOULD MONITOR THE
VARIOUS GRANTS THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDED THROUGH THE EHAVIORAL
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE CONTINUUM
WE ARE ANTICIPATING A LARGE
NUMBER OF GRANTEES AMEND THE
RESOURCES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
MANAGE ALL OF THOSE GRANTEES-
ITEMS. THAT ALSO WOULD INCLUDE
GRANT YOU PROGRESS REPORTS AS
WELL AS A CREATING A PROCESS TO
MONITOR THE ACTIVITIES- UNDER
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL. FOR
THE INCREASE TO. HEALTH
SERVICES ON THE GOVERNOR'S
AGENDA BUDGET PROPOSAL DHC IS
RICK. ELEVEN TOTAL FUNDS OF
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT LIMITED RESOURCES
EQUIVALENT TO TWELVE POSITIONS
AVAILABLE OVER FOUR YEARS. SO
NOW GO INTO THE VARIOUS
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED
REGARDING BOTH OF THE
PROPOSALS- THE FIRST ONE REALLY
IS IN REGARDS TO THE STATE'S
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES GAP- IN FEAR
THE DEPARTMENT OF SAY YES. A DH
IS THE STARTING THE WORK ON THE
GAP ANALYSIS FOR THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- CONTINUING
INFRASTRUCTURE- WE HAVE SECURED
A CONTRACTOR WHO WOULD BE
HELPING US OUT WITH THAT AND WE
HAVE STARTED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE VHD EIGHT. IN REGARDS TO
THAT GAP ANALYSIS WE ARE
ANTICIPATING THAT THAT GAP
ANALYSIS WOULD BE COMPLETED BY
THE END OF THIS ARE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CALENDAR YEAR TO
INFORM OF THE GRANTS THAT WOULD
BE AVAILABLE THROUGH THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
CONTINUE. ON OPPORTUNITY. I'M
ALSO WE WOULD KNOW HE THAT
THERE HUSBANDS FEEDBACK BY- FTA
YOU REGARDING REQUESTS FOR.
CHANGES TO BOTH PROPOSALS ALL
GO BACK. THROUGH THE RESPONSES
HERE. TO SPECIFIC TO THE
BEHAVIORAL ONSTAR THE STUDENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
PROPOSAL AT THE ARE YOU IS
REQUESTING DOLLARS TO FLOW
DIRECTLY TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS. A DH CS DOES NOT BELIEVE
THAT THAT STRUCTURE WILL BE AS
EFFECTIVE AS INCENTIVES THROUGH
THE MANAGED CARE PLANS. UNDER
REALIGNMENT CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY HAS- YOU KNOW BOTH
OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
BETWEEN OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS.
ARE NOT SPECIAL THESE SERVICES
AND MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
PROFESSIONALS- SERVICES UP AND
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SPECIAL
SPECIALTY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES. ARE BEING PROVIDED-
INSTALLERS WERE TARGETED IN
REGARDS TO MAKING SURE WE ARE
FOCUSED ON THE UPSTREAM
PREVENTATIVE EARLY
INTERVENTION. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO COMPLEMENT A LOT OF
THE GREAT WORK THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN DONE- BUT ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT OUR SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS IN COUNTY
PARTNERS. ARE AT THE TABLE WITH
OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. ON THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM PAID THROUGH THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS CAN BE
DESIGNED TO INCLUDE BROADER
SERVICES AVAILABLE IT ALSO
ALLOWS US TO DRAW DOWN THE
FEDERAL MATCH OF THOSE
SERVICES. UNTIL YOU LEAVE WITH
THE V. BEING ARE APPROXIMATE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ON
THE TABLE BY MAKING THAT
RECOMMENDED CHANGES. AT THE
GIVEN AS WE DO OUR RECOMMENDS
THE PATH THAT WE HAVE
RECOMMENDED IN OUR. PROPOSAL- A
DAY. AND WE'RE- TO ARE ONCE.
THINLY REFORM IS IN FULL. I
WOULDN'T HAVE OF INSTEAD CAME
TO BE PAID COUNTIES ARE
QUALIFIED- FOR FEDERAL MATCHING
SO HERE WE JUST LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT- THE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS THE WAY THAT THEY ARE
STRUCTURED IN THIS PROPOSAL AND
IN GENERAL- IS ONLY AVAILABLE
UNDER FEDERAL REGULATIONS FOR
AT. RISK CAPITATED PLANS SO OUR
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS.
ARE RISK BEARING PLANS ON AND-
THE MANAGER OF THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PARTNERS THEY WOULD NOT
BE RISK BEARING EVEN AFTER
PAYMENT REFORM- HOWEVER- THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES AS WE ENGAGE
ON AFTER PAYMENT WERE HEART
REFORM WITHOUT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. I'M COLLEAGUES TO BE
ABLE TO- INSURE THAT INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS THAT DO GO TO THEM
AREN'T CAUGHT UP IN THE COST
RECONCILIATION PROCESS AS THEY
ARE RIGHT NOW- AND SO THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO PARTNER WITH OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARTNERS IN
THE FUTURE. WITH INCENTIVE
PLANS BUT DIFFERENT IN REGARDS
TO THE DRAWING DOWN OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDS IN THE WAY THAT
WE ARE IN OUR- SCHOOL PROPOSAL
TO JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
SEPARATING THOSE TWO. PIECES AT
NEXT QUESTION THE COMMITTEE HOW
FOR THE DEPARTMENT HAS TO DO
WITH. A THE REASON- YOU KNOW
FOR WHAT REASONS ARE SCHOOL
BASED INCENTIVE PAYMENTS
LIMITED TO K. THROUGH TWELVE.
OF THE NOT OFF THE PROPOSED FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION. I'M HERE WE
WOULD SAY YOU KNOW THE
CONSEQUENCES OF NOT PROVIDING
TITLE AND AN ADOLESCENT MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS OFTEN EXTEND
INTO ADULTHOOD. ACCORDING TO
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
HALF OF ALL MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS START BY EACH OF
FOURTEEN. ANOTHER AND MOST
CASES ARE UNDETECTED OR
UNTREATED AND MOST SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS ALSO START IN
ADOLESCENCE. OF THE WITH THE
INCREASE IN CHILDHOOD AND
ADOLESCENT MENTAL HEALTH
HOSPITALIZATIONS SUICIDE RATES
OF OVERDOSE DEATHS. IN THE LAST
DECADE. WE HAVE REALLY DECIDED
TO FOCUS WITHIN THIS PROPOSAL-
WITH. YOU KNOW FOR YOU FIX
ANYTHING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CRISIS THESE. ADDITIONALLY A DH
YES WE USES APPROPRIATE TO
FOCUS INVESTMENT HERE- YOU KNOW
INCLUDING HIGHER ED WOULD BE
IMPORTANCE HOWEVER GIVEN THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION WE DON'T THINK
THAT WOULD BE SUFFICIENT. TO
INCENTIVIZE MEANINGFUL CHANGE
NOT BROAD. OF THE GROUP BUT-
VERY VALUABLE AND AN IMPORTANT
SERVICES FOR US TO BE
CONSIDERING IN THE IN THE
FUTURE TO EXPAND ONTO HIGHER
AGES IN REGARDS TO
COMPREHENSIVE. ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES I
JUST. WANTED TO MAKE SURE
WINNER KATE THAT. ON THE NEXT
QUESTION HOW TO DO WITH IT
MINUTES. JERRY ON THE AND- FOR
INTER THE PROPOSAL INTO
INVESTMENTS THE STATE HAS
ALREADY MADE INTO THE MENTAL
HEALTH. OF STUDENTS SERVICES
ACTION IN AN IMPORTANT QUESTION
SO THE ADMINISTRATION YOU KNOW
REALLY ENVISIONS A FUTURE WHERE
ALL CHILDREN AND YOUTH ARE ABLE
TO RECEIVE COMPASSIONATE
LINGUISTICALLY AND CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. I'M FROM SCREENING
AND PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION TO CLINICAL
SERVICES WITHOUT BEER YEARS- OR
WITHOUT DELAY. YOUNG PEOPLE DO
ARE NOT TYPICALLY SEEK HELP ARE
WHEN THEY START FEELING
DISTRESSED ARE THEY WAITING TO
HELP CRISIS- AND WE BELIEVE
SERVICES SHOULD COME TO WHERE
YOUNG PEOPLE SPEND THEIR TIME
THAT SCHOOLS ARE PLACES
AFFILIATED WITH SCHOOLS.
BECAUSE BUILDING THE NEW
SERVICES AND COMPLEX ENDEAVOR
WE BELIEVE THE PROPOSAL MUST
BUILD ON THE EXTENT OF WORK
ALREADY DONE BY THE MENTAL
HEALTH STUDENT SERVICES AFTER
IN THE WORK THAT THE MENTAL
HEALTH ARMED SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
HAS DONE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
MANY COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS OF REALLY LOOKING
TO LIFT UP THOSE LESSONS
LEARNED PARTNERSHIPS ARE YOU
ENGAGE YOUR MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS TO EUROPE
ADDITIONALLY OFFERS SOME OF THE
EARLIER INTERVENTION. OF
PREVENTION AND- NON SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN. AND YOUTH IN SCHOOLS.
WHEN IT COMES ACCOUNT. MEASURES
A BEING BUILT INTO THE SCHOOL
BASED PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT
THE MANAGED CARE PLANS UTILIZED
THE FUNDS TO ADDRESS
APPROPRIATE AND EFFECTIVE
SCHOOL BASED NEEDS- DCS.
INTENDS TO DESIGN THE INCENTIVE
MILESTONES AND THAT CAN ONLY BE
ACHIEVED BY COORDINATING WITH
THE SCHOOL OR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
OR COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
AS WELL AS PARTNERING WITH- THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. I'M SO THEY WOULD
HAVE TO ENGAGE IN THOSE
ENVIRONMENTS TO DRAWDOWN
INCENTIVE THAT BE A REQUIREMENT
OF. OF GETTING THOSE
INCENTIVES. WERE ACTUALLY- ALSO
ENGAGING IN LARGE CONVERSATIONS
I WAS SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
ADVOCATES AND MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
PLAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS. YOU CAN
BE BACK ON WHAT THOSE
INCENTIVES SHOULD LOOK LIKE
WHAT ARE THE MILESTONES BUT BUT
A LOT. OF THE MANAGED CARE PLAN
THAT DRIVE DOWN THOSE FUNDS IN
WHO SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS. I'M IN SO
LOOKING FORWARD TO YOU-
ADDITIONAL DETAILS THE
DEPARTMENT DID RELEASE AN
UPDATED OUR PROPOSAL ON THIS.
ITEM WHERE WE GAVE SOME
EXAMPLES OF THINGS THAT WE
HAVE- HEARD FROM OTHERS IN
REGRESSION NEEDING TO BE IN
THERE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER ENGAGE WITH REGARDS TO
FINE TUNING THE INCENTIVE.
PROGRAM THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE.
I DO. OTHER NEXT COURSE HOUSE
DO WITH- AT WHICH PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUT TO BE.
UNBELIEVABLE SIGNIFICANTLY SEEK
TO MAKE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES MARK FESTIVAL- TO THE
HOMELESS POPULATION- SO I WILL
SPEAK IN REGARDS TO YOU AS- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OUTSIDE OF
WHAT DH CS- OVERSEAS DIFFER TO
THOSE AREAS. HOWEVER AS YOU
KNOW TERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL
PROPOSALS THAT AIM TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. I'M CALTRAIN
BEING ONE OF THE CORNERSTONES
OF RECOMMENDATIONS THERE WILL
BE HARD THE PROPOSAL FOR
ENHANCED YOUR MANAGEMENT ONE OF
THE TARGET FOR OUR POPULATIONS
OF FOCUS ARE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS- WITHIN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM. AS WELL AS A
COMPREHENSIVE. OFFERING OF THE
FLU OF SERVICES FOR HOUSING.
INCLUDING NAVIGATION SERVICES
AS SECURITY DEPOSITS- BA'S ON
SERVICES ONCE SOMEONE'S HOUSE
AS WELL AS RETRIBUTIVE CARE- IN
OTHER OPTIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE HOMELESS. ADDITIONALLY
THERE HAVE BEEN EXTENSIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSALS PUT
FORWARD BY THE GOVERNOR IN A
NUMBER OF AREAS. INCLUDING ON
THE OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU THAT WE ARE DISCUSSING
TODAY TO REALLY HELP ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. OF THESE PROGRAMS
WILL HELP PROVIDE CARE FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND MENTAL ILLNESS
OR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS I'M
AND THEN USE THESE EPISODES THE
CHARACTER AND NOT. THE HOUSING
SERVICES THE REALLY THINK THAT
THERE ARE GREAT OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN THE- GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL. ADDITIONALLY WE DO
KNOW THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS. MADE ARE MADE
THROUGH OTHER AGENCIES AS WELL
AS OUR DFS CALLING. UP AND WE
HAVE BEEN PARTNERING TO ENSURE
THOSE SERVICES TOGETHER TO YOU
ADDRESS. THE NEXT QUESTION HAS
TO DO WITH- AND THEY JUST SAY
I'M IN THE STATE MANDATES FOR
COUNTY. IMAGE OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS FUNDING
ON FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIP. OF
WHICH WERE THE IN MORE THAN
NINE MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY-
SO THE- HERE IS ARE COUNTIES
CONSISTENT FOLLOWING THIS
EXPENDITURE. AND HOW WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL LEVERAGE THE-
INVESTMENT. SO HERE WHAT WE
WOULD SAY IS THAT THE COUNTIES
ARE UTILIZING THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS FUNDS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED IN BOTH START UP.
PARTNERSHIPS IN THE LAST
PUBLICLY REPORTED. YEAR WHICH
IS EIGHTEEN. IN REGARDS TO WHAT
POSTED 88% OF THE COMMUNITY
SERVICE SUPPORTS FUNDING WAS
SPENT ON FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP. IDEAS THE IS NOT
RECEIVED. ALL OF THE DAY. OF
FOR THE NAY EXPAND REPORT. OF
THE NINETEEN TWENTY HOWEVER-
AND YOU TO SOME THIS LABOR. OUT
WE HAVE NO. FINISHED ARE NOW-
HOW WE DO INTO THE THAT THE- I
OUR- TO USE THOSE ON THOSE BY
TO PROVIDE SERVICE TO FOR THIRD
SERVICE PARTNERS IN THE-
HOUSING HERE. LIKE THE PROPOSED
IN THE IN. PROPOSAL
ADDITIONALLY A WHICH IS NO BIG
CAN ALSO LEVERAGE PROPOSED
FUNDS THAT THE IMAGE OF CAP
FACILITY. NEEDS FOR. AND
BUILDING PURCHASES. AS OF THIS
END MIKE AT. HOW IN ANY. BUT IT
IS A. UNDERSTANDING THE
CONTINUE OF CARE THAT WE HAVE
AND THE GAPS IN THAT SYSTEM.
AND BEGINNING TO PUT IN PLACE
THE RIGHT LEVEL OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SUPPORT.
THAT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THESE
KINDS OF PROPOSALS WE REALLY
START WITH THE PREMISE THAT WE
NEED TO PROVIDE. ACCESS TO CARE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED
THEM THROUGH A RANGE OF
STRATEGIES SO WITH REGARD TO
THE SCHOOLS PROPOSAL. AND THE
QUESTION ABOUT MEDICARE
MEDICARE PLANS. AS WITH
COMMENTED ON- IN THE STATE HAS
MADE A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
AMOUNT HOSTED SERVICES ACTIVE
AN ONGOING INVESTMENT. AND A
NUMBER OF COUNTIES HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN THE PROCESS OF BUILDING
OUT ROBUST PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THEIR SCHOOLS AND WE'RE HOPING
THROUGH. FULL SUPPORT MORE THAN
HAS BEEN SERVICES ACT THAT WE
CAN EXPAND THE SIMILAR GRANT
FUNDING TO ALL COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
BUILD UPON THAT FOUNDATION IN
WAYS THAT ALSO ALLOWS US TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS WHO ARE SERVED
THROUGH MANAGED CARE PLANS BUT
EVEN COMMERCIAL PLANES. STONE
THANK YOUNG THE COMMISSION
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO
STRENGTHEN EXISTING
PARTNERSHIPS BUILD UP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE'RE
MAKING AN ON AN ONGOING
INVESTMENT IN. EXPAND ADDED WE
HOPE OVER TIME WE CAN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SCHOOLS WITH
MEDICARE PLANS AND OTHERS BEGIN
TO DESIGN A SYSTEM THAT IS
REALLY DRIVEN BY THE NEEDS OF
THE STUDENTS WERE SERVING.
RATHER THAN STARTING WITH THE
FUNDING THE DESIGN OF THE
FUNDING THAT WE BRING TO THE
TABLE. I DO WANT TO COMMENT-
BASED ON ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
IN THE ANALYSIS OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR EARLIEST CHILDREN
OUR EARLIEST LEARNERS AND SO
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS NEED IN
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
AND HEALTHCARE ENVIRONMENT AS
WELL. TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT YOUNG CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES PARTICULARLY
THROUGH A PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION LANDS. AND ON AND
ON THAT POINT THE SAME IS TRUE
FOR HIGHER AT I WAS IN A
MEETING TODAY WITH THE UC
REGENTS THEY COMMENTED THAT
ABOUT 10% SLIGHTLY UNDER TEN
PERCENT. OF THE UC STUDENTS ARE
ENROLLED IN MEDICARE. WITH
ANTICIPATE THAT BECAUSE OF THE
SIZE OF THE CSU SYSTEM AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM THAT THOSE NUMBERS WOULD
BE HIGHER IN TERMS OF A MEDIC
CAL ENROLLEES- BUT I. DO WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH THE
SCHOOLS AS A PATHWAY TO SUPPORT
BEHAVIOR HEALTH NEEDS AGAIN DO
A PREVENTION ANDINTERVENTION
STRATEGY IS THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR EARLY
LEARNERS AS WELL AS OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS. SO ALTHOUGH
THAT'S NOT ON THE TABLE AT THE
MOMENT WE JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE VERY.
SIMILAR CONCERNS AND WE SEE.
TREMENDOUS COOPER. FOR PAR BUT
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS ARE COLLEGE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES AND EARLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT CAN REALLY
STRENGTHEN THE SYSTEM OF CARE.
IN CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CAN
DESIGN CARE- THAT IS RESPONSIVE
RESPONSIVE ACROSS THE LIFESPAN
TODAY WE'RE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE BACK IN OUR-
IN OUR WORLD WE REALLY THINK
ABOUT ACROSS THE LIFESPAN. IN
IN TERMS OF- YEAH THE BROADER
INVESTMENT AROUND MEDICAL
OPPORTUNITIES THE QUESTION THAT
I WAS ASKED IS WHAT ELSE WHAT
ELSE COULD WE BE DOING HERE-
CHILDREN HAVE A VERY
SIGNIFICANT ENTITLEMENT UNDER
MEDICARE FOR SCREENING
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT AND WE
TALKED DURING THE EARLIER ITEM
AROUND BETTER USING DATA IN
PROCESS AYE PREVENTION THIS IS
AN AREA WHERE WE ALSO NEED TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND. HOW WHAT
KIND OF INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE AROUND WHO IS
ACCESSING CARE WHO'S NOT
ACCESSING CARE AND THE GAP
FIFTY THIRTY IN OUR SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM IT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
NEEDS ARE OUT THERE WHAT NEEDS
ARE BEING MET SO THAT WE CAN
BEGIN TO PUT IN PLACE A
STRATEGY TO CLOSE THAT GAP. M.
WE WANT THAT TO BE DONE THROUGH
AN UPSTREAM PUBLIC HEALTH MODEL
PREVENTION STRATEGY AS WE CAN
IMAGINE. THAT REALLY WOULD
ALLOW US TO BOTH IF WE
UNDERSTOOD THOSE GAPS IF WE
UNDERSTOOD THE PATHWAYS THAT
PEOPLE ARE PURSUING TO SEE CARE
IT WOULD ALLOW US TO STRENGTHEN
OUR MEDIC CAL. IN RELATED
ACCESS STRATEGIES. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS IN THE ANALYSIS FOR
MANY YEARS AROUND MOBILE AND
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND MOBILE. I
THINK YOU KNOW IN OUR SOCIETY
WE HAVE MOVED TOWARDS MOBILE
BUT WE ALSO MOVE TOWARDS
DIGITAL ART AS PART OF THE
CONVERSATION YOU HAD EARLIER
TODAY AROUND REIMBURSEMENTS FOR
VIRTUAL CARE. AND I THINK THE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM HAS NOT
BEEN AS NIMBLE IN MOVING
TOWARDS MOBILE AND VIRTUAL AS
WE COULD BE I THINK THAT'S TRUE
ACROSS EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE
DOING IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR NOT
NOT UNIQUE TO HEALTHCARE IN
SOME WAYS IT'S MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT AND HEALTH CARE AS
EVIDENCED BY THE CONVERSATIONS
YOU HAD. EARLIER IN THE AGENDA.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
REALLY ARE EXCITED ABOUT IN
TERMS OF THE MOVEMENT TOWARDS
MOBILE BASED CARE. AND WE WOULD
ARGUE THAT IT'S ESSENTIAL FOR
CRISIS BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE
LIMITED TO CRISIS RESPONSE
PARTICULARLY. IF WE WANT TO
ADDRESS ACCESS CHALLENGES IF WE
WAT TO ADDRESS INEQUITY ISSUES
OR DISPARITIES ISSUES. MOBILE
ALLOWS US TO ACTUALLY RESPOND
THE NEEDS WITHIN INDIVIDUALS
WERE SERVING RATHER THAN ASKING
PEOPLE TO ADAPT THERE NEEDS TO
THE SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE. AND SO
WE WOULD HOPE THAT THE STATE
WOULD MAKE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN MOBILE
STRATEGIES IN PARTNERSHIPS WITH
pIS THAT ARE ALREADY MOVING IN
THIS DIRECTION. SO WE THINK
THIS SHIFT TOWARDS MOBILE IS
IMPORTANT NEEDS TO BE AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT. OF A BROADER
CONVERSATION AROUND HOW WE CAN
BETTER RESPOND. TO THE NEEDS
ACROSS ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY. IT
TURNS OUT THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THE BROADER
COMMENT ABOUT WHAT OF THESE
OPPORTUNITIES HERE I JUST WANT
TO ADD A COUPLE OF. POINTS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION ONE IS- IN
TERMS OF THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
RAPIDLY RESPOND TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE SEEING
ACROSS OUR COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC AND ALL OF ITS
RELATED. ISSUES IS THE MEDICAL
SERVICES STUDENT SERVICES ACT
INCLUDES TWENTY COUNTIES THAT
ARE WHAT WE CALL SHOVEL READY.
THEY'RE READY TO GO. WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO FIND THEM BECAUSE
LIMITS IN THE ALLOCATION OF THE
COMMISSION RECEIVED. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO BE ABLE TO PUSH
THOSE DOLLARS OUT IN SIXTY DAYS
OR LESS TO THE EXTENT THAT
COUNTIES CAN RECEIVE THEM THAT
BATH WILL BE ABLE TO DO THAT
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN.
THAT COUNTIES WILL BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP SCHOOL BASED STRATEGIES
IN TIME FOR THE BEGINNING OF
THE NEW SCHOOL YEAR IN THE
FALL. BUT IT MEANS THAT WE
WOULD AT LEAST HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR COUNTY SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIPS TO BE ABLE TO.
ENGAGE IN TIME FOR. KNOWS THAT
DOESN'T. SCHOOL STARTS. HE WILL
BE IN TECH ASSIST WILL BE.
IMPORTANT IN THIS EFFORT SO
THAT WE CAN SUPPORT THE
LEARNING THAT THAT SCHOOLS AND
COUNTIES AND I WOULD ADD WE
HOPE MANAGED CARE PLANS WILL GO
THROUGH AS THEY BEGIN. TO BUILD
OUT THESE PARTNERSHIPS. AND
SIMILARLY CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
TREMENDOUS STRIDES IN BUILDING
OUT THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM WHICH IS A MOBILE SYSTEM
TO RESPOND. TO CHILDREN
INVOLVED WITH THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM WE THINK THAT THAT'S A
MODEL. THAT THE STATE SHOULD
LOOK AT A BUILDING UPON THEM
FOR NO OTHER REASON THAN
BECAUSE IT'S AVAILABLE. AND IT
WOULD ALLOW US TO RAMP UP
RELATIVELY QUICKLY RELATIVE TO
OTHER KINDS OF APPROACHES.
THERE ARE OTHER MODELS OUT
THERE WE ARE COUNTIES HAVE
REALLY BEEN LEADING THE WAY. IN
STEPPING INTO THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THAT THE AC TO SERVE THEIR
THEIR ROUND MENTAL HEALTH-
NEEDS SONOMA COUNTY IN
PARTICULAR HAS A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DISASTER RESPONSE
STRATEGY THAT WAS BUILT FROM
THE UNFORTUNATE EXPERIENCE. OF
MULTIPLE DISASTERS IN A VERY
SHORT TIME FRAME USING FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT REALLY IS CENTERED
ON UNIVERSAL BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SCREENS FOR ALL OF THE STUDENTS
IN THAT COUNTY. AND THEN
FOLLOWING UP WITH TRAUMA
FOCUSED- A RESPONSIVE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. SO WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S SOME
INCREDIBLE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE. IN CALIFORNIA SOME OF
THAT IS ON THE AGENDA FOR YOU
TODAY SOME OF IT IS HAPPENING
ACROSS THE STATE. YOU ARE
COUNTY PARTNERS AND WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT AS THE STATE
THINKS ABOUT. MAKING
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE.
OUR CAN WE LEVERAGE THE
EXPERTISE OF THE EXISTING
PARTNERS THAT WE HAVE
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT ARE
ABLE TO MOVE QUICKLY. IN
RESPONSE TO THE NEEDS THAT YOU
CAN'T WAIT UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE THAT WILL ENTERTAIN ARE
HITTING US TODAY. AND THAT IN
MANY WAYS WILL BE- MORE SEVERE
AS WE AS WE CONTINUE TO RE OPEN
AND PEOPLE COME TO TERMS WITH.
THE IMPACT THE PANDEMIC HAS HAD
ON THEIR FAMILIES AND THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT THEY CARED
ABOUT. I ALSO WANT TO MENTION
THAT THE STATE HAS MADE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IN TERMS OF
ITS CAL HOPE COMMUNICATIONS
EFFORTS IT'S WARM LINES- ARE
VIRTUAL AND DIGITAL MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AND SUPPORT MOST
READ PARTNERSHIPS WERE
MENTIONED. THESE ARE ALL AREAS
WHERE ASKED THE STATE THINKS
ABOUT EXPANDING ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE. HOW CAN WE
LEVERAGE THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WE'RE MAKING TODAY THAT THAT IN
MANY WAYS LIKE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS. AS WAS COMMENTED
IT'S OVER NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR IN COUNTY
INVESTMENT. THAT'S A TREMENDOUS
INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO IGNORE THE
TYPICALLY IF WE CAN BUILD UPON
AND STRENGTHEN THAT FUNDING
STREAMS ALLOW US. TO SUSTAIN
OUR EFFORTS OVER TIME. I'M THAT
MY RESPONSES TO THE QUESTION IN
THE- BUT I'D BE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AND I
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE. TO TALK
WITH YOU TODAY ON THIS
CHALLENGE. THANK YOU MISTER
EWING WILL NEXT HEAR FROM
PHILLY OKAY ARE TO. THANK YOU.
RIGHT INTO THE FIRST QUESTION%
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES FACING
COUNTIES AT ALL SOME OF THE
BUDGET THAT ADDRESSES
CHALLENGES IN FUNDING WOULD BE
OUR OUR GREATEST CHALLENGE IN
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM I'M I WANT TO
MENTION NOTABLY IN THE MEDICARE
SYSTEM WAS SPECIFICALLY WITH
REALIGNMENT I THINK THE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
MENTAL HEALTH REVENUES FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO ARE ACTUALLY LESS
THAN THE REVENUES THAT WE
RECEIVED IN FISCAL YEAR FOUR OH
FIVE. AND. TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT THE COUNT REVENUES.
TWENTY TWO COVER FOX THE 65% OF
THE REQUIRED STATE AND LOCAL
MATCH FOR MEDICAL SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH E. PSEG SERVICES
AND DRUG MEDI CAL SERVICES WITH
THE WITH OTHER COUNTY AND STATE
FUNDING BEING USED TO. FILL
THAT GAP IN PARTICULAR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE. THE NAME OF
NAME TO A LITTLE BIT. IN THE
DIALOGUE HALF OF THAT THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ARGUES AS NON
FEDERAL SHARE TO MATCH FOR
MEDICAL SERVICES. THE
ADMINISTRATION HOW THEY'RE
ADDRESSING- SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES. REALLY PROPOSED.
THING IS AN UNPRECEDENTED LAST
MINUTE MAYBE HERE HEALTH
SYSTEMS MUST READ THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLAR- ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY IN
PART ADDITIONALLY THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS EXPRESSED
ITS COMMITMENT TO SECURE AND I
IN THE WAIVER WHICH WILL BE
VERY VERY BENEFICIAL TO YOU
COUNTY HEALTH AND OF COURSE
KELLY PAYMENT REFORMS TODAY THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO ANNOUNCED A
TWO POINT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
INITIATIVE SEEKING TO TRANCE
WARMED THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR CHILDREN
ACROSS ALL PAYERS. IT'S
HEARTENING THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
GONNA INCLUDE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION MORE FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE TARGETING
SPECIFICALLY CHILDREN YOUTH
AMONG OTHER SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS WE CONTINUE TO BE
EXCITED TO SEE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
BE FEDERAL HEALTH AND LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
DETAILS ON THIS NEW IMPORTANT
INITIATIVE YES YES IS ALSO
PROPOSED REVISIONS TO COVERAGE
TO COVERAGE AND PAYMENT
CRITERIA ESPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH I'M INCLUDING THE
ELIMINATION INCLUDE INCLUDING
THE CHILDREN EIGHT INCLUDED
DIAGNOSIS OR AT THE PRETTY
WHACKED REQUISITE FOR SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. IN
ADDITION TO GET YES PROPOSES
THAT CHILDREN WITH HISTORY. OF
TRAUMA AMONG. ONLY ONE BALL BUT
WHICH CHILD. I ALEX THE CLEAR
FOR. FINALLY PROPOSED UPDATES
TO THE DRUG MAY CAL WORK
DELIVERY SYSTEM SPECIFIED YOU
NEED FOR A TWENTY GAUGER
SUBSTANCE USE ARE EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES AS PART
OF THE FEDERAL HE PSTG MANDATE
AND THAT ADULTS MAY RECEIVE
REIMBURSABLE SUV SERVICES
DURING THE ASSESSMENT PERIOD
EVEN IF ULTIMATELY THEY'RE
DETERMINED NOT TO MEET
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA. AB EIGHT
STATES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THESE CHANGES TO IMPROVE ACCESS
TO BE HERE ALL SERVICES
DRAMATIC HELP I ALSO WANTED TO
BRIEFLY MENTION ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE CURRENTLY
ON FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT TO
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANS
IS STRICTLY LIMITED TO THE
COSTS TO PROVIDE EACH MEDICAL
SERVICE LIMITING OUR ABILITY-
FOR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TO
INVEST IN SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT
EFFORTS THE ADMINISTRATION AS
IT HAS BEEN DISCUSSED. IS
PROPOSING WITH CBH CBH THE
ASTRON SUPPORT TO IMPLEMENT
PAYMENT REFORM INCLUDING
TRANSITIONING FROM WHAT WE
CURRENTLY USE OUR CERTIFIED
PUBLIC EXPENDITURE AND THE
CURRENT COPY SYSTEM TO
INTERGOVERNMENTAL TRANSFERS-
IDT'S WE BELIEVE AS J. C.
MENTIONED THAT THIS WILL LEAD
TO GREATER EFFICIENCY AND THE
ABILITY TO INVEST IN OUR
SYSTEM. I'M QUESTION TO ASK
ABOUT INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
MISSING AND THE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- WE WOULD
IDENTIFY THE UNIQUE AND COMPLEX
NEEDS I THINK THE TOOLS WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS CHILDREN
AND YOUTH WITH SERIOUS
EMOTIONAL DISTURBANCE AND THOSE
WITH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
ARE SUVS REQUIRING THAT
REQUIRING BECAUSE OF THEIR
NEEDS TARGETED INTERVENTIONS.
WHICH IS STILL MORE TRUE.
DOUBLES THAT ARE EXPERT HOME.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS SIX.
COMMITTED TO CONFRONT THE F
HOMELESSNESS IN THE- HOWEVER.
THOSE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
THAT ALSO HAVE THE HIT RUN
HEALTH NEEDS ARE SPECIFICALLY
TARGETED WITH- WITH CHECK WITH-
ISSUE THE PROPOSAL SUCH AS
SATISFIED. MANY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WILL REMAIN
UNSERVED THE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS NECESSARY
TO STABLY HOUSE AN INDIVIDUAL
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS.
ARE OFTEN ABSENT FROM
INITIATIVES TO ADDRESS THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WE'RE
HOPEFUL WITH THE RECENT
ANNOUNCEMENT OF ADDITIONAL
EFFORTS BY THE ADMINISTRATION
TO SUPPORT THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS HOMELESSNESS THAT
THOSE ADDITIONAL EFFORTS WILL
INCLUDE. POTENTIALLY SOME SET
ASIDE FOR TARGETED EFFORTS AT
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF OUR
POPULATION. WE WOULD ALSO
IDENTIFY- BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS AS
POTENTIALLY SOMETHING THAT'S
MISSING MISSING THE
MINISTRATION HASN'T MADE A
PRIOR FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
COMMITMENT TO WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TO
BENEFIT THE PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE WELCOME AND
MUCH NEEDED. SIMILAR EFFORTS.
WHAT WORK NEEDS TO SERVE THOSE
WITH SUBSTANCE THAT. ALSO THE
HERBAL AGENCIES WILL BE PAYING
COST FOR MEDIC CAL CERTIFIED
PEER SUPPORT SPECIALIST AS A
COUNTY OPTIONAL BENEFITS THIS
VALUABLE WORK. FORCE MERIT A
STATEWIDE IMPLEMENTATION WHICH
CAN ONLY BE. EIGHT INVESTMENT
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES IDENTIFIED
BY UCSF HEALTH CARE CENTER
RAISES ADDITIONAL PROFESSIONAL
PROFESSIONS THAT NEED A STATE
INVESTMENT TO BE HERE HELP
DELIVER SYSTEMS CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING SHORTAGES WHICH
WILL CONTINUE TO GROW WITHOUT
INVESTMENT INCLUDING AN
ESTIMATED 41% FEWER
PSYCHIATRIST. NEEDED IN
CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE INITIATIVE ANNOUNCED
TODAY MAY INCLUDE SOME
WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO LOOK AT THE
LOOKING AFTER. I'M MOVING TO
QUESTION THREE THAT URGENT AND
IMMEDIATE INTERVENTION THAT THE
STATE SHOULD CONSIDER I ALSO
WANTED TO COVER THAT THE KIDS
ISSUE AND WORKFORCE. FROM THE
ORDER OF THE. FULL FUNDING OF
WHAT I'M- DR YOU INTO AS SHOP
READY A MENTAL HEALTH STUDENTS.
ACT I'M PROGRAMS WERE TRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF THE STATE'S
MANAGE UNDERSTANDABLE HEALTH- I
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO GET YOUR GRIP
AND FEDERATION YOUR APPROVING
OF ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS INC
IN COUNTY SERVICES SCHOOL BASED
PARTNERSHIPS AND SERVICES AND
MOBILE CRISIS SERVICES. CREEK
WHAT. OF THE USER RECEIVE
TREATMENT AT SCHOOL INCLUDING
ONE THIRD ABOUT RECEIVE
SERVICES FOR BOTH SOME OF THE
SEARCH RESTED BY THE PANDEMIC
AND ITS CHILDREN RICK RETURNED
TO SCHOOL THEIR ABILITY TO
ACCESS THE SERVICES WILL BE
MORE CRITICAL THAN EVER PRE AND
POST THEM PANDEMIC COUNTY HERE
WILL HELP PLANTS HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
SPECIAL TV APRIL HEALTH
SERVICES TO ALL CHILDREN A
MEDIC CAL CONSISTENT WITH THE
E. P. STT ENTITLEMENT. GIVEN
THE FACT THAT OVER HALF OF ALL
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL
COUNTIES REALIZE THAT SCHOOLS
ARE THE PERFECT PLACE FOR
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TO
IDENTIFY AND OUTREACH TO
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN PARTNERING FOR OVER A
DECADE WITH LOCAL SCHOOL
SYSTEMS. TO ENSURE THE
PROVISION OF PREVENTION. AND
TREAT SERVICES IT WASN'T IN
JANUARY. IF THE TV HD SURVEY
NUMBER AND FOUND THAT 80% OF
THAT PROVIDE MEDICAL. THE ON
SPOKANE. AT FORT AND AT THE-
RISK OF DEATH WHICH IS 96% OF
ALL MEMBERS FOR OVER. IT ADDED
THAT FOR EIGHTY. AND SCHOOL
CAMPUSES IN THEIR COUNTY. WE'VE
BEEN IN SCHOOLS PROVIDE. AND WE
WILL TAKE YOU TO ON ARCTIC IF
THE PRINCIPLES THAT KEEP
EVERYTHING PARTNERS HAVE OF THE
CAN RISK. 50% OF JOHN VIDAK
APARTMENTS SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES ON CAMPUS
TODAY'S AT UT SERVICES ARE SO
IMPORTANT IN A- YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS. A CO OCCURRING
HEALTH AND SO FOR IT ALL A- GET
READY OUR EFFORTS. IN SCHOOLS.
IF YOU NEEDS BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF STATED OF THE MOTHER IF
THE LET TURN THE IMAGE FOR THE
ACROSS SERVICE AS CHILDREN
LET'S GO SERVICE THE- MISS WE
ARE NOW ON THE URGENT ABOUT IN
THE NOW HI I MAY YOU TO TURN
THE VIDEO IF WE'RE HAVING SOME-
FEEDBACK AND SO LET'S SEE IF
THAT. HELPS TO IMPROVE HELP. DO
YOU. AT AND I WAS ON I WOULD
LIKE ON MY VERY LAST BUT THE
WAY- SO WE TRY URGE INVESTMENT
IN THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM IS A CRITICALLY KEY
INVESTMENT. APOLOGIES FOR THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES AB. NO
WORRIES ZERO ON THE NEXT PANEL
SO I JUST WANTED TO GET IT.
CORRECT SO THAT WERE- PREPARED
FOR THAT- WITHOUT A WILL NOW
BRING IT UP TO THE DICE AND SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE I DO
WANNA ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON THIS
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- ON THE-
BE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- CONTINUE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM TRAVEL-
ENTITIES ARE PROVIDED GRANTS
FOR ASSISTING WITH STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH. HOW CAN WE
ENSURE THAT TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE ACTIVE PARTICIPANTS IN THIS
PROGRAM AND COUNT HOW CAN WE
ENSURE A PROPER AMOUNT OF
FINANCING GOES TO SUPPORT
TRIBAL STUDENTS. ALONG THE WAY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AND
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER IT SO- WE
HAVE FULL INTENTIONS OF FULLY
ENGAGING WITH OUR TRAVEL
PARTNERS IN REGARDS TO- THE
AVAILABLE FUNDS- AND WILL
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
ENSURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND HOW
THOSE GRANTS WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE- AND- THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WOULDN'T JUST BE FOR
THE COUNTIES- PROVIDED DIRECTLY
WITH OUR TRAVEL PARTNERS AS
WELL. WITH WITH THAT THAT ALSO
INCLUDES A DISCUSSION AND
FUNDING THAT- CENTERS AROUND-
SERVICES FOR CRISIS
STABILIZATION AND CRISIS
RESPONSE ALSO. WITHIN THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE. THAT IS
CORRECT SO FOR THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AND INFRASTRUCTURE
CONTINUE ON DOLLARS. I'LL E
FULLY PLAN ON ENGAGING WITH OUR
TRAVEL PARTNERS SO THAT THEY
COULD HAVE. BEEN BILLED THOSE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES AVAILABLE
TO- TO THEIR MEMBERS. THANK
THANK YOU MISTER TRANSPLANT YOU
FOR THAT MA'AM AND IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT I CAN DO TO HELP
FACILITATE ANY OF THOSE ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS. PLEASE DON'T
HESITATE TO REACH OUT TO MY
OFFICE. THANK THANK YOU UP
BEFORE I BEGIN I DO WANNA SAY
HOW EXCITED I AM ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH REFORM
SPECIFICALLY THE INVESTMENTS
THAT WERE ANNOUNCED TODAY THAT
WILL. ALLOW FOR US TO DO EARLY
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND-
OFTENTIMES DOES NOT GO SAID
ENOUGH HOW MUCH THE
ADMINISTRATION IS LEADING IN
THIS TIME AND- JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO MAKE SURE TO
APPRECIATE YOU. I DO WANT TO
ECHO WHAT TOBY EWING SAID THE
WITCHES I'M NOT SURE WE CAN
WAIT UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE
AS- MANY OF THE PROBLEMS WILL
BE MORE SEVERE IF WE DO THAT.
AND SO I'M HOPING IF I COULD TO
FOLLOW UP ABOUT. HOW WE MAKE
SURE THAT THESE INVESTMENTS
ARE. APPLYING TO ALL OF OR
CHILDREN. SPECIFICALLY I WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ON TOBY YOUNG'S
COMMENT REGARDING FIRST WHICH
IS ONLY APPLIED TO OUR FOSTER
KIDS. ARE THESE MOBILE CRISIS
SERVICES POTENTIALLY AVAILABLE
IS IT SOMETHING WE IS THE-
LEGISLATURE CAN ENGAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION ON TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE CRISIS SERVICES.
COULD POTENTIALLY BE AVAILABLE
FOR ALL. SO THAT COMES WITH A
AROUND- THE MOBILE CRISIS I
THINK THAT THERE ARE THERE ARE
A LARGE NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES
BEFORE US- THAT FOR EXAMPLE
EVEN WITHIN. THE R. P. ACT
AVAILABLE WE'D BE ABLE TO DRAW
DOWN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS.
OF UP 285% OF FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
MOBILE CRISIS SERVICES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION IS. AN
ANTICIPATING AND WAITING FOR
CMS GUIDANCE IN REGARDS TO THE
MOBILE CRISIS OPPORTUNITIES
THAT WOULD BE A ACROSS BOTH
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TO BE CLEAR THAT WOULD
INCLUDE BOTH CHILDREN AND
ADULTS SO I THINK THERE. WILL
BE OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO
EXPAND OUR MOBILE CRISIS
SERVICES IN THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SPACE IN CALIFORNIA- IN
THE FUTURE INTENDING THAT CMS
GUIDANCE WE'D BE HAPPY TO
ENGAGE WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
REGARDS TO. THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE FUTURE- NOW MIND YOU IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY ADDRESS
YOUR COMMENT OF WHAT WE DO
TODAY. A BECAUSE THOSE FUNDS
ARE AVAILABLE STARTING IN NEXT
YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO ABOUT
WHAT WE PLAN ON DOING WHATEVER
WE CAN TO EXPAND OUR SERVICES
TO CHILDREN AND ADULTS AND THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH RISKS
INCLUDING. A MOBILE CRISIS AND
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
FUTURE CONVERSATIONS. AND THEN
WE JUST NOTE- YOU KNOW ABOUT
NOT AT CURRENTLY ARE ON THE
AGENDA TODAY THAT DEPARTMENT-
AND AGENCY I REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDS TO THE
BROADER- CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROPOSAL THAT
WAS MENTIONED. GIVEN THAT IT IS
FOR ALL CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
NOT JUST FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES THAT ALL CHILDREN
AND YOUTH UP TO THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE AND SO. HOPEFULLY
WILL ALLOW FOR AN EXTENSIVE
INVESTMENTS IN THE FUTURE. I
BELIEVE FOR US TO GET UP AND
RUNNING AS FAST AS POSSIBLE
IT'S BETTER FOR US TO BUILD
WITHIN THE PROGRAMS WE
CURRENTLY HAVE UP AND RUNNING
THAN TRYING TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL AND- THUS LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS.
I'M I DO WANT TO- FOLLOW UP ON
THE GAP ANALYSIS WHICH IS
CURRENTLY IN CONVERSATIONS WITH.
C. PHD A I WOULD- A PRECIADO IF
WHEN THEY IS COME. AT THE OF
THIS YEAR. MY OFFICE IS A TO
SEE GAP ANALYSIS ON. TRYING TO
UNDER. THE CAN- AND WHERE ARE
GAPS ARE. AND MAKING SURE THAT
THIS INVESTMENT IS SUFFICIENT
TO MEET THE NEEDS AND- AND SO
JUST WOULD APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THAT AS IT'S
COMING OUT. BUT I DO WANT TO
FOLLOW UP IF I COULD ON ONE OF
C. B. H. D. A.'S COMMENTS WHICH
IS- THESE INFRASTRUCTURE
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO HELP TO
BUILD NEW BRICK AND MORTAR NEW.
FACILITIES BUT- WHO'S GONNA
WORK AT THOSE FACILITIES AND
HOW ARE WE- HELPING TO STAFF UP
THOSE FACILITIES I WAS HOPING
YOU COULD COMMENT ON. FOR
OBSERVE THAT IS CORRECTING THE
DOLLARS WITHIN THIS PARTICULAR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL R. FOR- THAT THE
FACILITIES WHETHER THAT'S NEW
CONSTRUCTION OR ACQUISITION OR
OTHER MODELING OF FACILITIES TO
MEET THOSE NEEDS- AND WHAT I
WOULD SAY IT'S WITHIN THE- THE-
CHILDREN'S AND YOUTH AT LEAST
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROPOSAL THAT
THE BOARD WE ALSO ARE
EXPANDING. ON DOLLARS FOR
WORKFORCE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDS ABOUT
PROPOSAL AND THE WORKFORCE
DOLLARS THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR US
TO INCREASE SOME OF OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE.
I'M AS WELL BUT I THINK IT'S A
IT'S A VERY VALID POINT IN
REGARDS YOU OF THE NEED TO
INCREASE THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA AND I
THINK THAT IF THE
ADMINISTRATION VERY COMMITTED.
TO THE THAT. YOU WILL FIND A
VERY WILLING PARTNER IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE INVESTMENTS
INTO OUR WORKFORCE EARLIER WE
MENTIONED WE CAN REPLICATE THEM
OR MANUFACTURE THEM AND- REALLY
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO GROOM OUR
OWN. REALLY HAVE ENJOYED HELL
YOU HAVE- ADVANCED PEER
CERTIFICATION AS A MODEL FOR US
AND I JUST AGAIN WANT TO THANK
THE. ADMINISTRATION FOR ITS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. WITH.
THAT WE WILL. ISSUE NOT OKAY.
RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
JUST HAD A HEAD OF A NEW
THOUGHT- WHEN WE LOOK AT.
PISSED ALL THE MONEY THAT HAVE
BEEN SPENT IN BEHAVIOR. OF
WORLD UNTIL HEALTH AND ONE NINE
HAS THERE BEEN ANY KIND OF. IT
IS TRY. PERFORMANCE WITHOUT.
WITH MY SPENT. WHERE WE'VE HAD
PEOPLE THAT HAVE ACTUALLY WE'VE
MADE THE INVESTMENTS WE'VE
GOTTEN THEM ON ON TRACK. FOR
YOU KNOW BASICALLY IS THERE AN
EXPENDITURE EMPLOYEE OF PLAN IN
PLACE THEN IT ALSO TRACKS
OUTCOMES AND WITH WHAT YOU'VE
DONE THIS YEAR AND WITH THE
ADDITIONAL MONIES THAT YOU'RE
GONNA GET NEXT YEAR. YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A COMPOST THIS
MUCH MORE YOU'VE SERVICED AND
HELPED. THIS MANY MORE PEOPLE
DO WE HAVE THAT. SO WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS THAT-
HISTORICALLY- WE HAVE NOT DONE
AS GOOD AS I THINK WE SHOULD IN
REGARDS TO YOU- BOTH
UTILIZATION DATA ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN MEDIC CAL.
AS WELL AS QUALITY AND OUTCOME
MEASURES- SO THE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY RECENTLY JUST HIRED A
CHIEF QUALITY OFFICER WE ARE
VERY EXCITED TO HAVE HER COME
ON BOARD IN ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT SHE WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR IS FIRST COMING UP WITH IN
REVAMPING. THE DEPARTMENT'S
COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY STRATEGY
ARE IN ONE OF THE CORE
COMPONENTS OF THAT QUALITY
STRATEGY IS TO REALLY LIFT UP
OUR- OVERSIGHT IN REALLY MORE
THAT KIND OF- YOU KNOW QUALITY
AND ACCESS AND- OUTCOMES. OF
OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM
ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD PAYMER FORM AND THE
ABILITY TO GET ADDITIONAL DATA
AND- DETAILED INFORMATION FROM
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS. A REAL
LOOKING TO LEVERAGE THAT IN THE
FUTURE SO WE HAVE SOME REPORTS
WHICH WE HAVE ONLINE BE HAPPY
TO SEND YOU A LINK TO THAT
INFORMATION. HOWEVER WE ARE
REALLY STARTING TO DO INITIAL
PLANNING FOR WHAT THAT WOULD
LOOK LIKE IN THE FUTURE AND HOW
WE CAN HAVE MORE ACCESS TO DATA
OUTCOMES AND QUALITY OUTPUT FOR
OUR MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER- SAID. I WOULD SAY
THOUGH WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF-
AT YOU KNOW THE DALLAS EITHER
EVALUATIONS ON SOME OF OUR
BLOCK GRANT- AT PROGRAMS THAT
ARE OPIOID WORK WE'D BE HAPPY
TO SHARE ANY OF THAT REFERENCED
INFORMATION WITH US WELL. KNOWN
APPRECIATE THAT BUT WHAT I'M
SAYING YOU IS WITH A BUSINESS
PLAN IN PLACE THE SHOWS. WHAT
WAS IT ANTICIPATED OUTCOMES
WITH. WHAT OUTCOMES WORK
ACCOMPLISHED. IT HELPS US.
EXPAND ON THE INVESTMENT YOU
SHOW US THAT THE AGE. HAS BEEN.
AT THIS LEVEL AND WHEN WE'VE
MADE THIS MUCH OF AN INVESTMENT
WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED THIS. AND WE
CAN GO FOR FURTHER WITH REAL
GOOD. SOLID DATA TO BACK UP
THE- ADDITIONAL MONEY THAT.
WOULD BE NEEDED. BUT I MEAN
THAT'S HOW I MEAN THAT'S HOW
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW WHICH WAY I FEEL RIGHT
NOW IN MY COUNTY SOLANO COUNTY
MY UNDERSTANDING IS WE STILL
DON'T HAVE. PEDIATRIC CRISIS
CRISIS BEDS. AND I'VE BEEN.
CALLING FOR THAT FOR NINE YEARS
NOW THAT I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND AGAIN. THE
CRISIS BUT HAPPENS TO BE
JUVENILE HALL. IN AN SWELLED
COUNTY SO WHAT I'M SAYING IS IF
WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE
QUANTIFIABLE. DATA THAT IT WILL
YOU WILL YOU HAVE. OUTSTANDING
OUTCOMES WITH THIS WITH
INVESTMENT WE CAN WE CAN BE A
BIGGER PROPONENT OF FOR FURTHER
INVESTMENT THAT'S WHAT I'M
HOPING FOR. YEAH THANK YOU WE
FOR- WE WILL DEFINITELY LOOK TO
BUILD THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO ARTICULATE
THE OUTCOMES OF THESE
INVESTMENTS IN SELF WE'LL TAKE
THAT BACK AND AGREE WITH YOU
THERE ARE MANY COUNTIES
UNFORTUNATELY IN CALIFORNIA
DON'T HAVEPEDIATRIC CRISIS-
ACCESS TO SERVICES AND THAT IS
ONE OF THE CORNERSTONES OF WHAT
WE'RE HOPING THIS INVESTMENT
WILL HELP US- CLOSE THE GAP ON.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. IT
THE FUND MANAGER BRING AND TELL
YOU IN FOR A COMMENT ON THIS.
QUESTION THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO
RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION IT'S
IN THAT CONVERSATION WE'VE BEEN
HAVING THE LAST FEW YEARS- YOU
KNOW I AM SURE THAT THE
COMMISSION STRATEGY PART OF OUR
OVERALL ACCOUNTABILITY
STRATEGY. IS TO HAVE A CLEAR
AND UNDERSTANDABLE WAY TO
REFLECT FIRST SPENDING YOUR THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING
AND WE THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THE ENTIRE MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM. THE COMMISSION AND
START WITH THEM AND TO SAY
FUNDS BAD PART OF OUR STRATEGY
IS TO RECOGNIZE THAT IF W WANT
TO UNDERSTAND THE BROADER
PUBLIC INVESTMENT WE NEED TO
PUT SOME NUMBERS OUT THERE AND
MONITOR THOSE. THE SECOND PIECE
IS IN THIS GETS TO PREVENT
FRAZIER COMMENT HERE'S WHAT WE
SPENDING THESE DOLLARS ON AND
SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING TO
REFLECT. THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING FUNDED WITH. THE DOLLARS
THAT ARE MADE AVAILABLE. FROM
FROM OUR TAX PAYER. AND THE
THIRD. OF THAT DISCUSSION IS
WHAT OUTCOMES BEING AND- THIS
IS A M. IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO IT IS VERY DIFFICULT WE
DON'T HAVE GOOD MODELS. IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR IN SOME WAYS WE
HAVE MADE MORE PROGRESS IN
MENTAL HEALTH. AND IT'S TRUE IN
OTHER SECTORS IN CALIFORNIA OR
ANY OTHER PLACE IN THE COUNTRY.
WE CAN'T. WITH IN A VERY
LIMITED STANDS. POINT OUT THAT
WE CAN WE CAN SHOW THAT FOR
BOTH SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
ARE SERVING INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE CRIMINAL JUSTICE HISTORY.
THAT WHEN THEY ENTER THESE
PROGRAMS. AND UPON GRADUATION
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT DECLINE.
IN RE ARREST RATES AND EVEN
OVER TIME AS PEOPLE LEAVE THESE
PROGRAMS WILL WE SEE A
REDUCTION AS HIGH AS 69% 59%
REDUCTION CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT. FOLLOWING
PARTICIPATION IN THESE
PROGRAMS. PART OF THE REASON
THAT WE CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT
THE VALUE A FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP. FIRST AND OVER
NINE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IT
IS A TREMENDOUS INVESTMENT THAT
IS THAT WE ARE MAKING ANNUALLY.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
INVESTMENT IS HAVING THE IMPACT
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR. WE
DON'T KNOW I'M A LITTLE IN THE
DATA THAT I JUST SHARED ABOUT
HOW FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS
ARE HELPING PEOPLE AVOID THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. ONE OF
THE THINGS WE DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHICH WE THINK IS ESSENTIAL.
FOR IN CALIFORNIA IS WHAT IS
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
PARTICIPATION IN A FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP OR LACK OF
PARTICIPATION IN THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT SOMEONE BECOMES. ENOUGH
LANDS IN THE STATE HOSPITAL
WITH AN INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL DESIGNATION BECAUSE OF A
FELONY CHARGE. WE NEED TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
TRAJECTORY OF HOW PEOPLE WHO DO
OR DO NOT RECEIVE A SET A RANGE
OF SERVICES. END UP IN A VERY
EXPENSIVE STATE FUNDED PROGRAM
OR THEY AVOID THAT VERY
EXPENSIVE STATE FUNDED PROGRAM.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT
RELATIONSHIP THE COMMISSION HAS
BEEN WORKING TO BUILD. OUT
EARLY PSYCHOSIS PROGRAMMING. WE
WANT TO WRECK. THAT THE
GENERATE BE AVERAGE DURATION OF
UNFIT PSYCHOSIS IN THE UNITED
STATES. IS ABOUT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS WE DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE
THE DATA FOR SPECIFIC TO
CALIFORNIA. AND THE NATIONAL
STANDARDS. INDICATE THAT THAT
REALLY SHOULD BE TWO TO FOUR
WEEKS. IN THE UK STANDARD IS
TWO WEEKS. AND SO WE WANT TO
UNDERSTAND IF WE IMPROVE ACCESS
EARLY ACCESS TO. PSYCHOSIS
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING THEIR FIRST
PSYCHOTIC EPISODE CANNOT REDUCE
RELIANCE ON A VERY EXPENSIVE
COMMUNITY BASED FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP. AND CAN FALL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS REDUCE
RELIANCE ON EVEN MORE EXPENSIVE
HOSPITAL BASED CARE. THERE'S A
NUMBER OF STUDENT COBBLED
CHAINS ARE LINKED SERVICES IN
OUR BEHAVIOR HEALTH SYSTEM
WHERE WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
TRACK INVESTMENTS. RECOGNIZE
THE KINDS OF SERVICES THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING BE ABLE TO DO
THE ANALYSIS TO DEMONSTRATE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
EFFECTIVE. AND THEN DO THE MATH
AROUND THE IMPACT THAT WE'RE
HAVING ON OUR BOTTOM LINE. ON
THE OUTCOMES THAT WERE
ACHIEVING FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES. I WILL SHARE WITH
YOU THAT OUR ANALYSIS INDICATES
THAT ONLY ABOUT FORTY PERCENT.
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE IN OUR
HIGHEST LEVEL OF COMMUNITY
BASED CARE WHICH IS A FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIP. ARE THERE
WITH A PSYCHOSIS BAGNAIA
DIAGNOSIS WHICH SUGGESTS WE MAY
NOT BE USING THAT RESOURCE AS
STRATEGICALLY. AS AS IS
NECESSARY SO WE ARE COULD. TELL
MEMBER FRAZIER WE ARE COMMITTED
TO THAT THE VISION THAT YOU
HAVE ARTICULATED- IT IS VERY
CHALLENGING. THERE'S LOTS OF
STEPS TO GET THAT DONE I THINK
WE'VE DEMONSTRATED THAT IT
CAN'T BE DONE BUT WE NEED TO
EXPAND THAT WORK DRAMATICALLY.
SO THAT YOU AND THE PUBLIC HAVE
THE INFORMATION YOU NEED TO
MAKE BETTER DECISIONS ABOUT
INVESTING IN EXPANDED CARE. THE
TYPE OF CARE WE INVEST IN AND
OPPORTUNITIES IDEALLY OR HIGHLY.
EFFECTIVE PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION. THANK YOU MISTER
EWING MAY BRING IN- MISS K. RD.
AFRICAN ON SUBJECT MISTER. IT'S
ACTUALLY UNDER LOCK I WAS
ACTUALLY IN A POINT TO THE
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT YOU
ARE ACTUALLY OFFERING A WITH
CBH DHCP H. K. AND C. PAN- AB
SIX EIGHT SIX. WHICH IS TRYING
TO LOOK AT DEVELOPING STATEWIDE
OUTCOMES AND PERFORMANCE
MEASURES TO HOLD THE COUNTY
RESULTS. ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
MANY PUBLIC FUNDS THAT WE
RECEIVE WE'RE LOOKING AT
CREATING AN ENTIRE WORKGROUP
THAT'S GOING TO BE FOCUSED
WITH. THE EXPERTS THAT ARE IN
THIS ROOM SO WE WOULD BE
BRINGING AND- THE COMMISSION WE
WOULD BE BRINGING ANTI EIGHT CS
AND OTHER FOLKS TO TOUCH OUR
DELIVERY SYSTEM AND WE WANT TO
HAVE A STRONG FOCUS ON HEALTH
EQUITY REDUCTION AND HEALTH
DISPARITIES. SO ARBIL IS A TO
YOUR BILL BUT IT IS INTENDED
THAT YOU EXACTLY WHAT YOUR
TALKING ABOUT DEVELOPING A
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF STATEWIDE
PERFORMANCE AND OUTCOME
MEASURES WHERE WE WOULD LOOK AT
THAT ON A REGULAR BASIS AND SEE
HOW WE ARE. PERFORMING AS A
SYSTEM. THANK YOU FOR THAT SO
ONE OF THE THINGS POPPED INTO
MY MIND ALSO AS I'VE HEARD THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH. WITH
DIFFERENT ENTITIES. BUT I HAVE
NOT HEARD THE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
REGIONAL CENERS WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE NEWLY DIAGNOSED.
IS THERE A FACET OF
COLLABORATION IS GOING. THROUGH
THE BEHAVIORAL MENTAL HEALTH
COMPONENT WITH REGIONAL CENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S BEEN SILENT. AND I'M
I'M LOOKING TOWARDS THAT- TO DO
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO FURTHER
PUSH THAT IN DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS WITH YOUR GUIDANCE
FOR. BUT I HAVEN'T HEARD THEM
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT TODAY
AS A PARTNERSHIP OR OF. OF A
PLACE TO FOCUS. MS COOPER DO
YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE COMMENTING
ON THAT. YOU KNOW WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS- I THINK THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT MORE COMPLICATED I'M NOT AS
ATTUNED TO OF WHERE WE ARE
INTEGRATING SIGNIFICANTLY AND
THAT WAY I KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN A HANDFUL OF WORK BUT I'D
LIKE TO TAKE THAT ONE BACK
BREAKING IN AND IN CONCERT WITH
MY TEAM AND GET BACK TO YOU.
YEAH I WOULD APPRECIATE IF YOU
COULD FOLLOW UP WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER HE'S
BEEN A CHAMPION IN THE SPACE
AND- WOULD LIKE TO SEE FOR HERE
I NAY COMMENT ON THEM. YES
MISTER YOU WANT. SO- THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHERE BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PEOPLE
WE'RE SERVING AND THE PEOPLE
WHO AREN'T BEING SIR WOULD
REALLY. HELP US MAKE RESOURCE
ALLOCATION DECISIONS SO WE'VE
HAD SOME RECENT CONVERSATIONS
WITH EXPERTS AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DAVIS. WHO ARE. OUR
PARTNERS IN DESIGNING OF EARLY
PSYCHOSIS PROGRAMMING AND I
DON'T HAVE THE PERCENTAGE IN
FRONT OF ME- BUT IT MAY HAVE
BEEN AS HIGH AS TWENTY PERCENT.
OF THE PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCE
PSYCHOSIS ALSO HAVE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
WHICH PREVENTS THEM UNIQUE
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF CARE
DELIVERY. IF WE HAD A BETTER
HANDLE. ON THE NEEDS OF THE
PEOPLE WE'RE SERVING IT WOULD
ALLOW US TO MORE STRATEGICALLY
TARGET INVESTMENTS- TWENTY
YEARS AGO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
BILL DIAGNOSIS THAT REFERRED TO
SOMEONE WHO. HAD BOTH A
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS. MORE
RECENTLY WE THINK OF SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS AND MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS AND SO. ATTENTION HAS
LAGGED A BET ON THE NEEDS OF
THIS PARTICULAR POPULATION. AND
WE WOULD DO WE WOULD DO VERY
WELL IF WE COULD BETTER
UNDERSTAND THAT SCALE OF NEED
AND BE ABLE TO COMPARE THE
INVESTMENTS WE'RE MAKING IN THE
OUTCOMES WERE ACHIEVING
RELATIVE. TO THAT LEVEL OF NEED
AND UNFORTUNATELY. WE'RE NOT IN
THAT. POSITION AT THE MOMENT
BUT WOULD LIKE TO BE. WITH THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK VERY MUCH
THIS PANEL FINALLY WE ARE ON
ISSUE TEN OUR FINAL ISSUE FOR
TODAY. WE DO HAVE THE SAME
PANEL HAS NOW AND THIS. IS ON
THE PROPOSED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE AXED FLECKS OF. TRAILER
BILL. CAN PLEASE BE. SO- WE
ACTUALLY GOING TO ASK THAT
KELLY FIVE REPRESENTS THIS ITEM
ON BEHALF THE PART. ON KELLY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH HAVING ME
TODAY. THANK YOU KNOW LAST YEAR
ABA ONE WITH A ACTED BROWN
GREAT BUT- TRUCK COUNTY. BACK
TO THE MAKING REQUIRED. THE
PUBLIC OFTEN. THANK YOU VERY
AYE GOING NAY THEY WERE.
PROPOSING SPEND MOST OF THOSE
STRUCK BY NOT RETURN YEAR. I
PLAYED. COUNTY SAID BACKGROUND
THERE LOCALLY BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T. AS OPPOSED TO HAVE
IT'S A NETWORK EACH YEAR FIVE
RIGHT. BAND WITHIN THE. ANYONE
TWENTY IF THAT COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR
SURPRISED HE CAN'T THAT THEY
WERE UNABLE TO CONNECTING YOU
YORK LANDED A COVETED RELATED
REASON CAN'T OPERATE BEACON
STREET IMPROVEMENTS INTERPRET
OR MAKE IT PERFECTLY EVERY TIME
VERY QUICKLY BODIES ALL COUNTY
LETTERS ARE EXTRACTIONS WITH
ALLEGATIONS ONE POSSIBILITY
THAT WE'RE NOT PROPOSING TO
EXTEND FOR ANOTHER YEAR ON THE
NET REVERSION DEADLINE. FOR ANY
UNSPENT FUNDS. WE ARE ASKED TO
COME WHY ARE WE NOT EXTEND
MANAGED TO BY WOMEN I LOOK IN
THE TO. THAT THE FRENCH.
BEVERLY ONE IS THAT THE PHONE
THAT THE- BURKE ENJOY. TWENTY
TWENTY INCLUDE. FIND THAT WORD
VERY IF AND CALL CAN YOU TO
VERIFY YEARS AGO AND INBOX CARE
THE RICH HERE TO. WE'VE ALREADY
THAT YOU THINK ONE. OF THE MOST
MOST I SPENT. BUDDY BRING OF
ANY IT BASED ON PLAN THE FIRST
THREE. WE DON'T THINK THAT THAT
POLICY IS GOING HAVE BEEN MADE
AND ON ABILITY TO SERVE WHICH
ARE A HOBBY FOR HOW PRIORITY TO
MAKE SURE. CLIENTS GET THEIR
INTERNET SPEED ON THE DATA WE
RECEIVE SHOULD BE WHERE WE GOT
TO OVER EXPENDITURE AND YEAR
NINETEEN OF POINT THREE BILLION.
WE DO THAT THAT OF THAT IF THE
TO A VERSION OF. THE GOOD FOR
EIGHTY FIVE NOW WILL FULLY. A
LOT OF CLEAR KNOW FOR SURE
UNTIL WE GET THE DATA WE
ACTUALLY THINK THAT THAT MEANS
COUNTIES WILL LOSE SIGNIFICANT
MONEY BECAUSE EVEN IF COUNTIES
REDUCE EXPENDITURES. BY 75%
COPPINGER DOWN SHE JUST A
QUARTER OF THE PAPER. SPENT
DURING THE CAN DOWN. WE DON'T
THINK THE BALLOT THAT GOING TO
BE FOR EXPANDED. BEGAN
GATHERING MY CAN WITH THE BEST
FUNDS TO REVIEW. ONE FOUR. WE
HEAR AGO AND WE HAVE THAT
ACCOUNT THE VERY TURNED NINETY
SEVEN. OF THOSE ON SO CAN. WE
GOT MORE ACTUALLY ABOUT NOT
EXTENDING THE ONE MORE YOU
BECAUSE THING LOOKED AT THE
FUNDING PLAN AND TO KEEP IN
MIND REVERTED FIVE. DON'T YOU
HAVE TO COUNTY MARC ALEX. EVEN
AT. SOMEBODY REFERRED AND- THE
TO GET THEM OUT ALLOCATION AND
THOSE. HAVE FUNDS THAT ARE
WE'RE WILL WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
IN THE DITCH FOR FUNDING IS
WERE FROM. COUNTY THAT GO OUT.
I'M. AND THEN YOU GET OFF THE
ABOUT STATUS OF THE AND
SPENDING SAVE BANK CIRCLE
AROUND THE BIG. STATED WE WE'RE
GONNA BE CALLING UNDER. AND
HAVE TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM TO BE A- THANK YOU
MISTER J. GET TO WHEN I'M OF
THE HEALTHCARE- IT YOU KNOW IT
ENTER OF THE IN YOUR- OF.
COMMISSION APPROVAL OF COUNTY
PLAN. YOU KNOW WHEN AB ONE FOR
WAS. WHEN THERE'S- DECLARED
THAT. FUND THAT WOULD ACCEPT TO
RIVER WORD RIVER. ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF THAT LITTLE LESS THAN
TWO THIRDS OF THE ANIMATION
FANS IN THE BALANCE OF P. E. I.
IN COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT. AND WE UNDERSTOOD THAT
AT THE TIME BECAUSE MANY
COUNTIES HAD NOT THEN PURSUING
UTILIZATION OF INNOVATION
FUNDS. WE KEEP TRACK AND WE
POST MONTHLY. A MONTHLY
DASHBOARD ON THE NUMBER OF
COUNTY INNOVATION PLANS THAT WE
RECEIVED- THE LEVEL OF FINDING
THE NAME OF THE PROJECT AND WE
ALSO TRACK HOW MUCH TIME IT
TAKES FOR THE COMMISSION TO.
REVIEW AND COUNTY INNOVATION
PLAN THIS FISCAL YEAR THAT'S
AVERAGING THIRTY SIX DAYS AND
WE START THE CLOCK EITHER WAY
AND THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. APPROACH THE PLANT.
OR YOU COUNTY BOARD TO HAD
APPROACH IT WE START THE CLAW.
FOLLOWING MANDATORY THIRTY DAY
PUBLIC REVIEW A PUBLIC
PRESENTATION ACCOUNTS ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE FOR EACH
COUNTY INNOVATION BUT I AM. SO
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE PROCESS
IS DIFFERENT FOR INNOVATION
THEN FOR P. E. I. OR C. AS THAT
OTHER MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
EXPENDITURES BECAUSE COUNTIES
ARE NOT REQUIRED. TO GET STATE
LEVEL APPROVAL AND SO THAT
ADDITIONAL STAFF DOES FEEL LIKE
A BURDEN. I'M I ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS WITH SUPPORT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
ABLE TO FACILITATE. MULTI
COUNTY. INVESTMENTS IN SHARED
INNOVATION SO WE HAVE EITHER
PROVIDED FINANCIAL SUPPORT OR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON. SIX OR
SEVEN DIFFERENT AREAS THAT
COLLECTIVELY REPRESENT ABOUT
FORTY COUNTIES. ON IT SEVERAL
WAYS TO REDUCE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT. STRENGTHENING FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS. HANGING
IN THE CRISIS MODEL I MENTION
EARLIER- WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH A NUMBER OF
COUNTIES TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
EFFORTS USE INNOVATION FUNDS.
TO ADDRESS RACIAL AND ETHNIC
INEQUITIES AND DISPARITIES. ARE
EARLY PSYCHOSIS WORK HAS BEEN
LEVERAGING COUNTY INNOVATION
FUND FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS NOW.
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS WE
HAVE APPROVED SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS A
COUNTY INNOVATIONS. AND NINETY
SEVEN POINT 6% OF COUNTY PLANS
ARE APPROVED BY THE COMMISSION
I THINK THERE'S AN ARGUMENT
THAT PERHAPS THAT PERCENTAGE IS
LITTLE TOO HIGH IT SUGGEST THAT
MAYBE- THAT INNOVATION PLANS
AREN'T AS EDGY AS THEY COULD BE
IF WE WANT TO FUNDAMENTALLY.
DISRUPT SOME OF THAT THE
SERVICE SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE TODAY THAT AREN'T WORKING
AS EFFECTIVELY. AS THEY COULD
BE- BUT WE DO NOT AGREE WITH
THE CHARGE THAT ARE PUT OUR
SYSTEM IS SLOW AND CUMBERSOME
WE DO AGREE. THAT IT IS AN
ADDED STAFF THAT COUNTIES OFTEN
ARE HESITANT. TO FACE. WE HAVE
DONE EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ENSURE THAT OUR BEHAVIOR IT IS
NOT WHAT CAUSES DEPARTMENTS AT
COUNTIES TO LOSE MONEY TO
REVERSION AND IN FACT WE HAVE
ADDED ADDITIONAL MEETINGS.
RIGHT UP TO THE JUNE DEADLINE
SO THAT. WE CAN REVIEW THOSE
PLANS TO AVOID REVERSION IF
NECESSARY. IN TERMS OF THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE STATUS OF
UNSPENT FUNDS BY COUNTIES WE
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO ASK C. B.
H. J. FOR CLARIFICATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT THAT HAS THAT IF
YOU'RE GOING FOR FIVE POINTS
OUT- WE DO NOT YET HAVE THE-
FISCAL REPORTING TO TELL US HOW
MUCH MONEY WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
REVERSION. IF THAT PROVISION IN
THE LAW IS NOT WAIVE IT IS NOT
POTS FOR AN ADDITIONAL YEAR- IT
DOES SOUND LIKE IT THEN THE
NUMBERS WOULD NOT BE VERY HIGH.
YEAH WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE
ARE BECAUSE. THE REPORTING IT'S
NOT YET AVAILABLE. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I JUST WANT TO OUT-
THE COULD HAS IN THE- IF YOU
RECOMMEND. THAT CURRENTLY FINDS
THAT RIVER COME BACK TO THE
STATE. AND ARE ULTIMATELY
REDISTRIBUTED BACK TO COUNTY SO
IN A- SORT OF YOU KNOW
COMPREHENSIVE ACCOUNTING
METHOD. I'M INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES
MAY LOSE SOME MONEY- BUT ACROSS
ALL OF THE COUNTY'S IMAGES THEY
DOLLARS THAT RIVER DON'T LEAVE
THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE SYSTEM.
THERE MAY BE SOME DELAYS IN
GETTING THOSE DOLLARS REVERTED
BACK TO THE COUNTIES BUT THAT'S
AN ISSUE WHERE WE MAY BE ABLE
TO SPEED THAT UP. IN THE PAST
THE COMMISSION HAS RECOMMENDED
THAT IN THE INSTANCE WHERE
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
USE THAT MUCH AS A REVENUES FOR
THREE YEARS OR LONGER OR IN THE
CASE OF SMALL COUNTIES FIVE
YEARS OR LONGER. THERE'S SOME
JUSTIFICATION THERE TO.
REDIRECT THOSE DOLLARS TO
PRIORITIES AND SO ONE THING
THAT YOU MIGHT CONSIDER IS
WORKING WITH COUNTIES TO.
EXPLORE THEIR ABILITY O RETAIN
THOSE DOLLARS. UNDER CONDITIONS
THAT THEY DEDICATE THEM TO
STATEWIDE PRIORITIES LIKE
ADDRESSING INEQUITIES WHICH WE
KNOW ARE- FUNDAMENTAL
CHALLENGES. THAT WE MUST DO
BETTER ON. CAPITA AGAINST ANY
QUESTIONS THAT BE THAT I MEAN
ADDRESS. IN MY FORMAL TESTIMONY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM S. K.
ARDA. HERE IN AND I'M ACTUALLY
GOING TO START WITH THE FIRST
QUESTION BY JUST SAYING THAT I
THINK- DR PIPER ANSWERED IT
PERFECTLY. WE REALLY ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF FUN WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE FEW
PLACES. WHERE CALVET NINETEEN
HAS IMPACTED SOME EXPENDITURES
SO SHE IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
COUNTIES ARE SPENDING MITCHELL
SAY DOLLARS WE TYPICALLY DO WE
SPEND 80% OF OUR IMAGE AS A
DOLLARS IN TWO YEARS. WE HAVE
WE HAVEFOR LARGE COUNTY THREE
YEARS TO EXPAND THOSE DOLLARS
FOR SMALL COUNTIES FIVE YEARS
TO EXPAND THOSE DOLLARS AND WE
DO DO THAT WITHIN THAT TIME
FRAME. SO DOCTOR PAPERS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD AND THAT THE AMOUNT
THAT UNSPENT IS IT'S A SMALL
AMOUNT AND WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE. IS A SMALL AMOUNT
OF DOLLARS WE ARE NOT ASKING
FOR SAFEGUARDING REVERSION OF A
LARGE AMOUNT BECAUSE THAT THAT
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN SPENT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THIS VERY
ISOLATED PROJECT. REALLY JUST A
HANDFUL OF PROJECTS. THAT HAVE
COME TO US AND SAID BECAUSE THE
POPE AT NINETEEN WE COULDN'T
OPEN A WELLNESS CENTER SO WE
COULDN'T EXPAND. THOSE DOLLARS
BECAUSE OF HOPE IN NINETEEN
WHERE WE PLANNED TO TRAIN FIVE
THOUSAND PRIMARILY VETERANS. TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID
WE WERE GOING TO START IN
OCTOBER. BUT I'M SORRY WE'RE
GONNA STARTING JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY WE COULDN'T WE HAD IT
BACK. TO OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT SOME OF THESE
FUNDS WILL BE WILL BE SUBJECT
TO REVERSION SO WE'RE LITERALLY
TALKING ABOUT A HANDFUL OF
PROJECTS. LOOK LIKELY NOT MORE
THAN TEN PROJECTS OUT OF THE
TWO THOUSAND THAT ARE OUT THERE
SO WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT A
LOT OF PROJECTS HERE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT A VERY SMALL
NUMBER- OF. INTER AND THAT IS
TRUE FOR THE INNOVATION SIDE
TOO BECAUSE THAT'S HOW BE A
SAID THEY'VE DONE. WHAT THEY
NEED TO D TO SUPPORT BOTH
COUNTIES THAT ARE ABLE TO HAVE
THE CAPACITY. TO DO TO GO
THROUGH THAT ADDITIONAL. THAT
HE DESCRIBED. FOR THOSE THAT
ARE TO THAT BUT HAD. WHILE
THEY'RE GIVING- BUT NOW. TO DO
THAT THEY'RE BRINGING THE
PROJECT AND WE GIVE THAT THE-
ALWAYS SEE THE COMMISSION IS
THAT IT. TO MORE SESSIONS IN
JUNE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS. IT'S FOR
THOSE THAT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR THE SAFEGUARDING OF
REVERSION FRONTS FOR THE
INNOVATION POT. REALLY IT'S
REALLY JUST ABOUT THE U.
COUNTIES THAT HAVEN'T HAD THE
CAPACITY. TO BE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH THAT ADDITIONAL STEP.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO PRODUCE THAT
INNOVATION PROJECT WHICH CAN
TAKE SOME TIME. RIGHT NOW THE-
THE COMMISSION RECOGNIZING THAT
THERE ARE STILL AREAS FOR
IMPROVEMENT. IN IN THIS PROCESS
TRANSCONTINENTAL'S ARE FINANCE
TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES THE CD HOW THEY CAN
IMPROVE THAT INNOVATION
PROJECTS. WERE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THAT WERE
PARTICIPATING IN THAT PROCESS.
AND CONTINUE TO HOPE THAT SOME
OF THE ISSUES GET RESOLVED SOME
OF THE ISSUES AND EXPERIENCES
THAT WE HAVE. BECAUSE THE
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE IT'S EVEN
FOR THOSE FOLKS. THAT ARE GOING
TO BE HEARD IN JUNE. IF
COMMISSION COMMIT OR THE CAN.
DOES NOT APPROVE. THE PROJECT
IF THEY DISAPPROVE THE PROJECT.
AND THERE ARE FUNDS THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO REVERSION IN THOSE
PROJECTS. THEY WILL HAVE NO
TIME. TO RETURN BACK AND
SAFEGUARD THOSE FUNDS THOSE
FUNDS WILL BE REVERTED EVEN
THOUGH THEY DID ABSOLUTELY
EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAD TO DO.
BUT IN THE END THE COMMISSION
DID NOT APPROVE THEIR PROJECT.
THOSE ARE THE PROJECTS THAT WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT SO AGAIN
YOU KNOW I THINK THE QUESTION
NUMBER THREE IS. HOW MUCH TIME
IS THAT THEY FUNDS ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT VERY VERY LITTLE.
WE ARE REALLY ONLY LOOKING FOR
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN ADVERSELY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC. IN
BOTH THE INNOVATION POT AS WELL
AS- FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN
COVERED IN CONTRACTS THAT HAVE
BEEN READY TO BE SPENT. BUT
JUST COULDN'T BE SPENT BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE TIRES TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY MEMBER
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE I WILL
SAY IT'S QUITE ENCOURAGING TO.
RECEIVE THE INFORMATION FROM
BOTH THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS
C. B. H. T. A. ABOUT. THE
SPENDING OF OUR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND WILL SAY. PARDON
THE PUN BUT IT'S AWFULLY
INNOVATIVE TO DO MULTI COUNTY
INVESTMENTS AND SHARED
INNOVATION AND- REALLY I'M
APPRECIATIVE OF TOKYO AND FOR
SHARING. WITH THAT I WILL
THANKS VERY MUCH THIS ENTIRE
PANEL AND ALL OF THE PANELISTS
WHO HAVE PARTICIPATED IN
TODAY'S HEARING. WE WILL NOW
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT AS A
REMINDER WE WELCOME PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY ISSUE ON THE
AGENDA INCLUDING THE NON
PRESENTATION ISSUES WHICH ARE
NUMBERS ELEVEN THROUGH
NINETEEN. WE DO HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEREFORE I
WANT TO URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE
SO THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM
EVERYONE. WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AND AS A REMINDER THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND SHOULD
BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET THE
TOLL FREE NUMBER IS. ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AT 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. OPERATOR WE ARE READY TO
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT. Q. IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEARCH
THANK YOU MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
TEN THAT AND I HAVE COMMENTS
FOR TWO CLIENTS ON TWO
DIFFERENT ISSUES BUT I'LL TALK
AS CONCISELY AS POSSIBLE. THE
FIRST COMMENT IS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS MERGING PHYSICIANS
ARE CONCERNED WITH THE SCOPE OF
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AS PROPOSED IN
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE MARSH
THAT. AS WELL AS IN AB ELEVEN
THIRTY WORDS YOU PHYSICIAN SEE
AND TREAT MANY PATIENTS WHO ARE
NOT ABLE TO ACCESS CARE IN
OTHER SETTINGS FOR VARIETY
REASONS. THEY COULD BE MENTAL
HEALTH PATIENTS PATIENTS WITH
POSTOPERATIVE DISCHARGE
DETERIORATION. CATIONS CAN'T
GET FOLLOW UP ORTHOPEDIC
APPOINTMENTS AS EXAMPLES-
TREATMENT EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
IS AN EMERGENCY BY THE TIME THE
PATIENT PRESENTS BUT IS NOT THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE FROM THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY STANDPOINT.
BY LIMITING THE OFFICE OF
AFFORDABILITY TO ONLY EXAMINING
COST TARGETS BY SECTOR OR
REGION FOR PROVIDERS WERE
MISSING A SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE
AFFORDABILITY FOR CONSUMERS.
THE OFFICE OF PORTABILITY
SHOULD ALSO BE DESIGNED TO LOOK
AT DELIVERY OF SERVICES ARE
TARGETS BY SECTOR ARE ONE WAY
TO LOOK AT EXPENSES BUT IT'S
SIMPLY COMPARES COSTS OF ONE
PROVIDER TO A SIMILAR PROVIDER.
IT MISSES WHETHER THE PROVIDER
IS EVEN THE RIGHT OR MOST COST
EFFECTIVE PLACE FOR THAT
SERVICE A CARE TO BE DELIVERED
AND WHETHER THE PATIENT HAD AN
EARLIER OR MORE COST EFFECTIVE
OPTION. THE OFFICE PORTABILITY
PASS SHOULD INCLUDE COLLECTING
DATA TO EXAMINE A REPORT ON THE
SYSTEM TRENDS GAPS IN DELIVERY
AND SYSTEM WIDE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR BETTER MORE EFFECTIVE CARE
DELIVERY NOT SIMPLY HOW MUCH
YOU SECTOR COSTS. WE WOULD ASK
THE COMMITTEE TO KEEP HIS
PROMISE OF MIND AT THE TRAILER
LOOKS LANGUAGE JUST PRO
DEVELOPED OR IS AB ELEVEN
THIRTY IS FOR FURTHER
DEVELOPED. THE SECOND ISSUE I'M
CALLING ON IS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
ITEM THREE FROSTED RECAST
MODERNIZATION INCLUDED
TRAVELING WAS TO EXPAND THE
OUTCOME REPORTING FOR CARDIAC
PROCEDURES. CURRENTLY HOSPITALS
AND CARDIAC SURGEONS ARE%
REQUIRED TO REPORT OUTCOMES FOR
CORONARY ARTERY BYPASS GRAFT
SURGERIES. THE NEW ARE
STRUGGLING WHICH WOULD EXPAND
REQUIRED REPORT. TO ANY CARDIAC
CHRISSY. THIS IT I THINK. MOVE
GOING FROM ONE PERSON REQUIRED
PEOPLE. TO AN UNLIMITED NUMBER
ACT INITIAL REVIEW WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
EXPANSION TO REQUIRE REPORTING.
FOR ANY CARDIAC PROCEDURES IN
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT MAY RESULT IN A REDUCTION
IN AVAILABILITY OF THOSE
CARDIAC PROCEDURES. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SPEAKING IN MORE
DETAIL WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE AN
ARCH BED ARE MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING KELLY
BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS COMING ON TWO ISSUES
FIRST AND KEEP A FEW COMMENTS
ON THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY DESPITE
REPRESENTING 26% OF ALL
HOSPITALS IN THE STATE THE
EIGHT PAGE MEMBERS PROVIDE 40%
OF ALL HOSPITAL CARE. TO
CALIFORNIANS REMAINING
UNINSURED AND 35% OF ALL
HOSPITAL CARE TO MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES IN THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE PUBLIC
HOSPITALS OPERATE MORE THAN
HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S TOP LOCAL
BURN AND TRAUMA CENTERS AND
TREAT HALF OF ALL THE DOCTORS
AND HOSPITALS IN THE STATE. ALL
OF THESE SERVICES I JUST
MENTIONED ARE VERY COSTLY TO
OPERATE PUBLIC HOSPITAL SHARE
MANY OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION CONCERNS I WANT TO
BE SURE THAT EFFORTS TO CONTAIN
COSTS DON'T HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR SAFETY NET
HOSPITALS OPERATING ON THIN
MARGINS WE THINK DR WHITFORD
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. ON THE PROPOSAL
SECOND REGARDING TELEHEALTH
CDPH STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY
TWO TO ENSURE TELEHEALTH
CONTINUES THE PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS INCLUDING
THOSE SYSTEMS OPERATE FEDERALLY.
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALL
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBER THE
BENEFIT YOU KNOW WITH KATIE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS YOU CAN REGARD TOUCH
ON THE PART EIGHT ISSUE THREE
I'M ALSO HAVE BEEN CAST. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT THE NEW
COUNCIL REFLECT AND HAVE
PRIMARY CARE REPRESENTATION.
AND CRITERIA FOR FUNDING
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS FOR FIVE
FIFTEEN SECOND. QUARTER PRIMARY
CARE WORKFORCE THAT WE NEED FOR
THE FUTURE. LOOK FOR THE
FOLLOWING UP ACROSS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME THIS EVENING. THANK
YOU THE CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU RYAN FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AND GOOD
EVENING THIS IS SERRA MCDADE
THING WHAT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I WOULD
AVOID- PARTS OF SECTION SUPPORT
FOR THREE ISSUES AND PART A THE
HEALTH AGENDA I WOULD BE ISSUE
EIGHT THE PMR HEALTH QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT- AT THE REQUEST BY
THE EXTENT AS WELL AS THEY
SHOULD NINE THE STAFF THE
REQUEST BY PIZZA TO. IMPLEMENT
THE GOVERNOR'S BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL WHILE WE WOULD PREFER
THAT THE FUNDING WOULD NOT COME
OUT OF THE AMOUNT THAT COULD BE
AWARDED TO COUNTIES WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT. UPDATES NEED
THE FAST AND THE STAFF WOULD
HELP COUNTIES ACT WITH THE
FUNDING BUT WE'RE IN SUPPORT
LASTLY WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE TEN THE IMAGE OF
FACEBOOK'S ABILITIES- WE DO
HAVE SHARE THE CONCERNS OF THE
PHD A WITH A FEW PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES- HAVING TO REVERT THE
FUNDING DUE TO THE PUBLIC
NINETEEN ENDEMIC. BUT WE
APPRECIATE DHS WORKING WITH
COUNTIES ON THIS LAST YEAR AND
THIS YEAR FOR THE POSSIBILITIES
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO TURN
IMAGES SAY DOLLARS INTO
SERVICES. IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RIGHT FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY THIS IS FAR REPLACE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION I WILL BE SPEAKING
ON TWO ITEMS. FIRST ITEM IS
NUMBER TWO OFFICE HEALTHCARE
PORTABILITY HEATED SEE A TRADE
MISSION TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS GET THE CARE THEY
NEED AND DESERVE NCHA SUPPORT
THE GOALS OF IMPROVING
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY BY
REDUCING THE RATE OF GROWTH AND
HEALTH CARE COSTS. THIS IS NO
EASY TASK IN THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
OUTLINED IN AB ELEVEN THIRTY
AND THE ADMINISTRATION'S
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WILL NEED
SEVERAL CHANGES IF IT IS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND SUSTAINABLE. AS
PROPOSED THERE COULD BE SEVERAL
DETRIMENTAL AND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR CALIFORNIANS.
THE BILL SUGGESTS THAT
HEALTHCARE SPENDING THAT EXISTS
TODAY IS IN THE RIGHT AMOUNT IN
IN THE RIGHT PLACE TO. BUT FOR
EXAMPLE THE CO THAT HAS SHOWN
CURRENT SPENDING ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH IS INSUFFICIENT FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS. IN
FACT THAT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION POSITION AS WELL
SEEN IN THEIR PROPOSAL TO
INVEST MORE THAN ONE BILLION
DOLLARS SOME BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IN STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. UNDER
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE THESE
TYPES OF INVESTMENTS WOULD ONLY
BE IMPLEMENTED IF OTHERS
SPENDING IS REDUCED. FOURTEEN A
CHOICE BETWEEN NEW BENEFICIAL
SPENDING AND CUTS TO EXISTING
SERVICES. C. H. WORKING BECAUSE
WITH DOCTOR WOULD THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS BY THESE. ARE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS FALLEN FORMING AREAS
AND THEY ARE OUTLINED IN
TODAY'S COMMITTEE. SUBCOMMITTEE
AGENDA. THE OTHER ITEM I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK TO IS THE
TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL AHA'S IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
AND WOULD LIKE THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO REPLACE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
LANGUAGE WITH SB THIRTY TWO AS
AMENDED IN THE FAMILY HELP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK
YOU RYAN THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS KATHY
MOSSBERG I'M GONNA SPEAK TO TWO
ISSUES THIS EVENING ON BEHALF
OF TWO CLIENTS FIRST ON BEHALF
OF THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS AND
ITEMS TO WORK- D. MAKES THE
HEALTHEQUITY REVIEWS THE LOCAL
PLANTS ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION FOCUSED ON
HEALTHEQUITY BUT BELIEVE THE
PROPER TIMELINE FOR
IMPLEMENTING A STATEWIDE EQUITY
APPROACH SHOULD FIRST FOCUS ON
A DAY THANKS TO GAPS AND NEEDS
AND ENSURING WE HAVE THE
FOUNDATION. TO SUCCESSFULLY
MEASURE OUTCOMES FOR THE
POPULATIONS WE SERVE WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH BOTH
THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE PROPOSAL
AS IT MOVES FORWARD IN THE
PROCESS ON THE SECOND ISSUE ON
BEHALF OF THE SECTION BUT
CENTRAL ACCESS HELP WANT TO
SPEAK ON ITEM FIVE HELLO. AND
WANNA ASSOCIATE MY OURSELVES
WITH ALL OF THE COMMENTS
ALREADY MADE AND CERTAINLY THE
COMMENTS FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ON THE CHAIR MEMBERS SITTING IN
THE CHAIR ALL WE ARE CO
SPONSORS OF AB THIRTY TWO WE
BELIEVE STRONGLY IN SUPPORTING
ACCESS TO TELEHEALTH EXPANDING
THAT ACCESS FOR FULL FULL
PAYMENT PARITY FOR VOTE FOR
ALSO INCLUDING TELEPHONIC CARE.
WE DO THINK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION. TRAINABLE FALSE
ON THE SUBJECT AND I NOTICE A
LONG. THIS EVENING SO I BELABOR
IT BUT THIS IS SPENDING. HELP
CARE. FOR WITH. ALL TELEPHONIC.
AND IT DOES HELP TO CLOSE THE
EQUITY AND EQUITY GAP THAT WE
HAVE FEET. SO WE THANK THE-
COMMITTEE TODAY AND STAFF. FOR
THE ANALYSIS AND HOPE THAT. THE
COMMITTEE WILL LOOK TOWARDS
ENSURING AB THIRTY TWO
LANGUAGES CAN REPLACE OF THE
DEPARTMENT STRAIGHT THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBER CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF
OF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORM REPRESENTING
THE THIRTY THREE DISTRICTS AND
MUNICIPAL HOSPITAL IN
CALIFORNIA HERE TODAY TO VOICE
OUR CONCERNS FOR THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY WE
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS AND PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO THOSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WHICH WERE OUTLINED IN- THE
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR TODAY
SUBCOMMITTEE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WENT AWAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY COMING ON SEVERAL ITEMS
FIRST WE SUPPORT THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED LOW
WAGE WORKERS WHO ARE STILL
EXPECTED TO CONTRIBUTE MORE TO
THEIR WAGES TO HEALTH COVERAGE
WE CANNOT GET TO UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE IN CALIFORNIA IF WE DO
NOT BRING IN THE CASA CARE.
REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE HEALTH
EQUITY IN QUALITY REVIEW
PROPOSAL WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH THE PEN AND HEALTH ACCESS
RELATED TO THAT MEDICARE HEALTH
TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL WE SUPPORT
THE EXPANSION HELLO HELLO IN A
WAY THAT HONORS CONSUMER
CHOICE. I DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT'S LANGUAGE THAT
WE CAN CONSUMER PROTECTION PIKE
SPENDING ALTERNATIVE ACCESS
STANDARDS FROM ANGLE TO THREE
YEARS AND FINALLY WE SUPPORT
THE CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF
MEDICARE INNOVATION AND
INTEGRATION ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO BUILDING OFF LESSONS
LEARNED FROM. THE ICEBERG THE
CALLAHAN PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY
WE'D RECOMMEND THE CREATION OF
AN OMBUDSMAN CONSUMER FAMILY
AND VOLUNTARY ENROLLMENT
PROPHECIES CONTINUITY OF CARE.
AND ONLINE NETWORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA HEALTH
ADVOCATES WOULD LIKE TO BRIEFLY
TOUCH ON A FEW ITEMS. ITEM
NUMBER THREE UNDER OSTENSIBLY
CAPTAIN MODERNIZATIONS WERE
EXCITED AND OPTIMISTIC THAT THE
THREE FOCUSED SIGNALED A NEW
ERA OF OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS
DEPARTMENT AND PARTICULARLY A
GLAD TO BE THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES AFFIRMATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION
RECOMMENDATION. AND THERE'S
STILL MUCH WORK TO BE DONE TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA HEALTH
REPORT CRISIS AND WE MUST
GUARANTEE THAT EVERYTHING
DEPARTMENT AT GROUNDED IN
EQUITY LINE. RECOMMITTING TO
STRENGTHEN HEALTH RECORDS AND
DATA SYSTEMS IS IMPORTANT
CENTRALIZING RELATED PROGRAMS
AFFECT FROM BTS INCLUDING THE
J. ONE VISA PROGRAM IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THESE CHANGES
WILL NOT BE SUFFICIENT TO
OVERCOME THE GAPS AND
INEQUITIES OF OUR HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM TODAY BUT WE
MUST ALSO GUARANTEE THAT THE
STRIDES MADE US BETTER NOT
LOCKED IN THIS INCLUDES
GUARANTEEING. COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTER REPRESENTATION
INDEPENDENT DECISION MAKING ON
WORKFORCE FUNDING SUCH AS
RESIDENCIES SCHOLARSHIPS AND
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE RESOURCES ARE GOING TO
THE INSTITUTIONS AND PROVIDERS
BETTER SERVING THE MOST HARD TO
REACH AND THEN JUST ON ITEM
NUMBER FIVE ON TELEHEALTH JUST
REALLY WHEN I APPRECIATE ALL
THE ON GOING WORK ON IT I AM
FROM THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
STAFF. AS WELL AS LEADERSHIP
FROM THE HEALTH COMMITTEE CHAIR
AND HIS STAFF AND ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AGUIAR-CURRY AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THIS
COMMITTEE ADOPT SB THIRTY TWO
AT THE ALTERNATIVE TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL TO ENSURE TELEHEALTH
ACCESS INCLUDING PHONE ACCESS.
FOR PATIENTS INCLUDES THAT OF
THE ONE AND THREE MEDICAL
PATIENTS THAT GET THEIR CARE
ACT COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I
SIXTY TWO CALL. TRYLINE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
MALLIN THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND THAT WE'RE
SPEAKING TODAY- ITEM FORTY ONE
FOURTEEN AGENDA AT AN ISSUE Q.
ON THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. FOR YEARS ARE
UNION MEMBERS WORK ON WAGE
INCREASES IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING TO MAINTAIN THEIR
AFFORDABLE HIGH QUALITY HEALTH
COVERAGE. WITH MAJOR FINANCIAL
CONSEQUENCES AND MANY OF OUR
BARGAINING DISPUTES WITH
EMPLOYERS ARE TIED DIRECTLY TO
EMPLOYERS TRYING TO SHIFT THE
RISING COST OF HEALTHCARE ON TO
WORKERS. SO WE BELIEVE BY
IMPLEMENTING A MECHANISM THAT
WOULD CURTAIL THE RISING COST
OF CARE. AND SHARING THE COST
SAVINGS WITH THE WORKERS WHO
HAVE BEEN PAYING INTO THE
SYSTEM WE BELIEVE THE CREATION
OF THE OFFICE WOULD RESULT IN
MEANINGFUL FINANCIAL RELIEF TO
TAX PAYERS EMPLOYERS AND OUR
MEMBERS. WITH LOWER PREMIUMS
OUT OF POCKET COSTS THE STATE
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO PAY TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS WITH
SOMETHING BUT THE OFFENSE IN
THE COMMITTEE AND STRENGTHENING
LANGUAGE. AND RESPECT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS WHILE ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT THE OFFICER TO JOT
THE HEALTHCARE COSTS ARE GET.
OR ITS APPROACHES AS NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. STRENGTHENED BY THIS
PROPOSAL. WE CERTAINLY AGREE
THE BALLOT CAMPAIGN BETWEEN IS
UNDERTAKING BEHALF OF COST
CONTAINMENT THAT PROTECT
WORKERS IN THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. BOTH CONSUMERS AND
PATIENTS IN THE STATE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A GOOD
EVENING. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COLD WAR HOLDEN
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP. I'M THINKING TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF THE CONTINUED
IMPORTANCE OF EQUITY CENTERED
HEALTH WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE RESPONSIVE
AND INNOVATIVE AND ADDRESSING
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
MARGINALIZED CHILDREN. ON ITEM
FIVE TELEHEALTH WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF INCREASING ACCESS
TO TELEHEALTH FOR FAMILIES OF
COLOR AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION MAINTAIN CURRENT
PHD TELEHEALTH SUPPORT FUNDING
FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS IN
A STRAPLESS PATIENTS USING
ASYNCHRONOUS TELEHEALTH AND BE
REIMBURSED. FOR AUDIO ONLY TELL
HEALTH. EIGHTEEN AND ARE ON
TELL HER ABOUT CRITICAL MOTEL
OF CARE. BY MENTAL HEALTH WE
HAVE TO PROPOSE CONTRACT THAT
SUPPORT WHOLE CHILD APPROACH TO
THEIR HEALTH WELL BEING AND-
SUCCESS STILL THERE'S MORE TO
THINK. PERFECT TO ENSURE THAT
INVESTMENTS IN MENTAL HEALTH
BEGIN IN EARLY CHILDHOOD AND
THAT LOCAL SCHOOLS IN ADDITION
TO COUNTY IT'S TOUGH BUT
RESOURCES AND TECHNICAL
CAPACITY NECESSARY. TO PARTNER
WITH LOCAL HEALTH PLANS AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS LONG
TERM FULLY IMPLEMENT SCHOOL
BASED MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS OF
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA AND GAVE
THE ACT ON BEHALF OF SK YOU
CALIFORNIA YOU'RE GONNA BE
OCCUPIED ON THE H. OPENED
BEHAVIORAL PROPOSAL UNDER
ASPECT ISSUE TO ON THE CREATION
OF DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCESS AND INFORMATION WE
APPRECIATE THE OR COMMIT VISION
OF THAT DEPARTMENT CALL WE
CASTING. ALTHOUGH A MEETING
THAT PPL WE DO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL WORKFORCE LANGUAGE
TO EXPAND IT TO INCLUDE ALLIED
HEALTH WORKFORCE PROJECTS AND
DATA REPORTING. ADDITIONALLY WE
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT ALL
EXISTING FUNCTIONS OF COST WITH
REGARD TO COLLECTING THE
FEEDING AND MAKING DATA
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ARE
PRESERVED AND. MAINTAINED I
UNDER OSCAR ISSUES. THE CREE OF
THE OFFICE OF AFFORDABLE. IT'S
A TO US THAT THE OFFICE IN FORT
HEALTHCARE COSTS HARDER IN THE
WEIGHT ACTUALLY. AND OUR HELP
WORKFORCE ABILITY ENTRY ME AND
ALSO A FACTOR IN. COLLECT
BARGAINING AGREEMENT. WE REMAIN
ABOUT THE COST SAVINGS ARE
SHARED WOODWORKER. WE BELIEVE
THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE BY TO
ENSURE THAT OUR SAVINGS
ACTUALLY TRICKLE DOWN TO
WORKERS AND CAN. ARE OPPOSED TO
SHAREHOLDERS AND LAW ON THE
DECK ACT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROPOSED. WE GENERALLY THOUGHT
THE BEHAVIORAL CAN BE. INVERSE
PRO. AS ONE BEING ACCESS TO
STUDENT HEALTH SERVICES BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT A
QUORUM MISSING PIECE IN THE
PROPOSAL WHICH ARE COUNTY
WORKFORCE AND STAFFING
EXPANSION NECESSARY FOR SUCH
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL TO
ACTUALLY BE SUCCESSFUL. THANK
YOU DR ARAMBULA ASKING THAT
QUESTION ON STAFFING AND WE
APPRECIATE AND COOPER COMMENTS
AGAIN MINISTRATION COMMITMENT
TO BUILDING OUT THAT WORK FOR.
SB I USE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
WHAT WHAT WORKERS ARE THE BEST
MOST SKILLED AND TRUSTED
PROVIDERS BY THOSE CURRENTLY
SERVING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AND ENERGY SERVICES.
WE WANT TO LOOK UP OUR CENTRAL
OLE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AGAIN MINISTRATION ON THE
WORKFORCE EXPANSION ESPECIALLY
AS WE NEED PENT UP DEMAND FORCE
TO REPRESS. AND ALSO WITH
TODAY'S THREE BILLION DOLLAR
YOU BEHAVIORAL. HEALTH
INVESTMENT THANK YOU. THE YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU I SIXTY NINE GOING. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR ARAMBULA
MEMBERS THIS IS A SHELTON THE
CAL ALLIANCE OF CHILDCARE
SERVICES- TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONGEST OF ITEM ONE UNDER
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
ESTABLISH THE OFFICE THE
SUICIDE PREVENTION IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE LEADERSHIP
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPA THE
OFFERING ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE TWELVE WHICH SET UP THE
FREE MARKET DIRECTION FOR THIS
OFFICE WE WERE OUT THERE. TO
FIGHT AS A TICKET TO GET PUBLIC
HEALTH CHALLENGE AND THE COVERT
PANDEMIC MAKES THE NEED FOR THE
FUNDS FOR THIS OFFICE VERY
CLEAR. WE'D ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT OF ITEMS
NUMBER NINE AND TEN OTHER
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. ABOUT THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROTECTOR FONG ABOUT HOW
BACK WHAT THE BILL. IS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT CALL
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD OUR WEB
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
COMMENTING ON TO THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
ASPECT OF STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
CREATION OF THE OFFICE HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY AS DIRECTOR
LANDSBERG OUTLINED HEALTHCARE
COSTS ARE RISING UNSUSTAINABLY
FOR CONSUMERS AND PATIENTS. TOO
MANY CONSUMERS FORGO CARE
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT AFFORD IT
GETTING PRESCRIPTIONS DOCTOR
VISITS LAB TESTS AND OTHER
NECESSARY KERR. THE OFFICE AIMS
TO TAKE A HOLISTIC APPROACH AT
CONTAINING HEALTH CARE COSTS
RESULTING FROM YEARS OF
NEGOTIATIONS AND ENGAGING
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
WHAT CAN WORK AND IT HAS BROAD
SUPPORT FROM CONSUMER AND
BUSINESS GROUPS. ARGUED WOULD
BE SET BY SECTOR WOULD TAKE TO
A REGIONAL VERY. RECOGNIZING
THE DIFFERENCES AND COMPLEXITY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM BUT IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT THESE TARGETS ARE
ENFORCEABLE AT DOCTOR WHAT'S
SAID THE GOAL OF THE OFFICE IS
NOT TO BE PUNITIVE BUT TO WORK
WITH THE INDUSTRY TO CONTROL
COSTS WHILE ENSURING ACCESS AND
IMPROVING QUALITY AND EQUITY.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER AT
THE END OF THE DAY CONSUMERS
ARE THE ONES PAYING THE BILLS.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE SPECIFIC
AGENCIES OVER SPECIFIC PARTS OF
THE INDUSTRY BUT NO AGENCY
TASKED WITH LOOKING AT THE
ENTIRE HEALTHCARE SECTOR. MUCH
LESS SETTING GOALS FOR
AFFORDABILITY QUALITY AND
EQUITY I WILL NEVER MEET A GOAL
THAT WE DON'T START. WE THANK
DR WORD AND THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS ISSUE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING IN
THE PROCESS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
KIDDING RIGHT NOT BE HALF OF
THE CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION ON AGENDA PART A ITEM
FIVE WE SEE TELEHEALTH AS A
VITAL TOOL THAT ALLOWS
PROVIDERS INCLUDING PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALISTS. THE OPTION TO
PROVIDE CARE TO THEIR PATIENTS
BIRCHLEY WHEN CLINICALLY
APPROPRIATE AND PREFERRED BY
THE PATIENT AND THEIR FAMILY
I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF SEVERAL PREVIOUS CALLER WE
ALSO FEEL STRONGLY THAT
PROVIDERS MUST BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN CURRENT FAX ABILITIES
AND HE NOT FOR BOTH VIDEO AND
AUDIO ONLY TELEHEALTH.
THEREFORE WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION PUBLIC HEALTH
PROPOSAL AND INSTEAD REPLACED
IT WITH EIGHTY THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY- AS
AMENDED IN THE ASSEMBLY. HEALTH
COMMITTEE THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MA'AM CONNECT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBERS KNOCKING OUT OF
ON BEHALF OF THE FRAGRANCE
CREATOR OF THE NATION I'M
COMMENTING ON ITEM FIFTEEN
WHICH WOULD NOT BE GRANTED BUT
COSMETIC FRAGRANCE LABOR
INGREDIENT RIGHT TO KNOW ACT OR
SB THREE TWELVE HUNDRED
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
FTA VERY INTERESTED IN SB THREE
TWELVE AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
REVIEWING THIS REQUEST AS IT
RELATES TO IMPROVING
IMPLEMENTATION WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
ENSURE IMPLEMENTATION.
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATUTE
THANK YOU. THANK MA'AM. NEXT
CALLER PLAY. THANK YOU RYAN
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
JERRY MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATIE
AND JEREMY YOUR HELP WELL. IT'S
OVER NOW I WANTED TO PROVIDE
SOME VERY SHORT COMMENTS ON
THAT YOU'RE DONE THE ITEM ON
THE AGENDA WERE ITEM ONE THE
DALLAS MAN OF THE AUTHOR THE
FACT THAT THE ENGINE. EIGHTY P.
H. TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS BOTH
REPORTED BOTH ALL SECOND FOR
ITEMS TO THE ANNUAL HEALTHCARE
SERVICE PLAN HEALTH EQUITY
ALREADY REVIEW PROPOSAL WE
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
ABOUT COLLEAGUES THAT HELP
ACCESS. AND THE PROBLEM. FOR
FIVE THE STATE WILL HELP THE
BOLD BE VERY. MEDIA LANGUAGE
THAT WHAT WILL TELL BUT- IN
PAYMENT FOR ONLY MODOC. WE LOOK
TO WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE MINISTER TO ME HELLO
LIKE. PERMANENT TO ENSURE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES- EIGHT.
UNLOCKED I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THOSE. DIRECTOR DOING OF THE
COMMENTS ON THE NEED TO FIND
THE REMAIN TWENTY FOUR COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PARTNER- IF YOU
INSURE THAT THE STATE STUDENTS
RECEIVED MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT THEY NEED THAT THEY
RETURN TO SCHOOL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO OUT. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT- MECHANICAL THAT
WOULD CHILDREN FONTANA
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER REPRESENT ALL OF THE
CHILDREN OF THE CENTURY
SACRAMENTO IMPOSTER COUNTY
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM SH I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLAR
HEALTHY FUTURE FOR FOSTER YOU
PROPOSAL. TO EXTEND THE INFANTS
OF WOMEN IN THE CENTER COUNTY
EXPECTING YOU CURRENTLY RECEIVE
THE INFANT SUPPLEMENT THREE
MONTHS PRIOR TO CHILD BIRTH IN
OUR EXPERIENCE THAT SMALL
INVESTMENT HAS MADE A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE
ABILITY OF OUR CLIENTS PREPARE
FOR THE UPCOMING BIRTH. OF
THEIR CHILDREN. OKAY GIVING
THEM THE- TO KEEP A STUDIES A
CAR SEAT. MY YOU PARKWAY. AND
OTHER AYE THAT ARE REQUIRED PUT
PARENTS MOMENT THEY LEAVE THE
HOSPITAL. WITHOUT IT THEY'RE
LEFT SCRAMBLING FOR RESOURCES
AT A VERY DIFFICULT AND
STRESSFUL TIME IN THEIR LIFE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYOR
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION COMMENTING ON THE
OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY WE ARE ALSO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED I'M SURE
MANY OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. WELL WE
AGREE WITH MANY OF THE GOALS OF
THE TO AFFORDABILITY PROPOSAL
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
IT'S WRITTEN A COULD IMPACT
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE AND
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS. THAT'S
JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF DRUG
TREATMENT APPROVED TWO YEARS
AGO TO CHURN OFTEN FATAL MUSCLE
WASTING CONDITION AND PRINT
COPY TO MILLION DOLLARS PER
CHILD COULD MINISTER. OUR
PATIENTS ARE ENTITLED TO
RECEIVE TREATMENTS LIKE THE
PHONE UNDER BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW BUT JUST A HANDFUL
OF PAPER THE YEAR AT THE
COCKPIT EASILY PUSH A
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL OR THEIR
SECTOR OVER ITS TOP TARGET.
WILL THE OFFICE BE EMPOWERED TO
ESTABLISH SAFE HARBORS FOR NEW
HIGH COST TREATMENTS LIKE THIS
ONE WHAT A CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
BE EXPECTED TO SEEK APPROVAL
BEFORE ADMINISTERING SUCH
TREATMENT. WHAT THEY BE
REQUIRED TO OPERATE WITHOUT
KNOWING IF THEY BE PENALIZED
AFTER THE FACT WILL THEY BE
EXPECTED TO LIMIT ACCESS TO
COSTLY TREATMENTS LIKE THIS ONE
IN ORDER TO STAY WITHIN THEIR
TARGET. STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
THE AFFECTED TO MAKE THAT KIND
OF RATIONING LEGAL NONE OF
THESE QUESTIONS ARE CURRENTLY
ANSWERED BY EITHER PROPOSAL BUT
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK TO ADDRESS QUESTIONS LIKE
BEAT IN THE COMING WEEKS.
SERVITES CERTAINTY FOR
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN OUR
PATIENTS AT THE TOP WON'T LIMIT
ACCESS TO MEDICALLY NECESSARY
AND LIFE SAVING CARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU BRING TO
THREE GO OUT. OKAY NUMBER
BUSINESS FOR CIVIC CYCLE SO.
REPRESENT LICENSE COLLEGES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN NOT TO BELABOR THE POINT WE
DO WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THEIR STRONG
COMMENTS REGARDING- ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE- WE DO ALSO AGREED
THAT. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS
PREMATURE WE ARE ASKING THAT
THE COMMITTEE WOULD JACKSON
ADMINISTRATION DAHLE PROPOSAL
AND EITHER A SUPPORT AB THIRTY
TWO TO THE POLICY PROCESS
WORKPLACE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WITH SB THIRTY TWO I
SPECIFICALLY SPEAKING OUR
MEMBERS HAVE SEEN TREMENDOUS
BENEFITS TO AUDIO ONLY
MODALITIES IN THE TREATMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS- THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC. IN PARTICULAR THOSE
IN MEDICAID- SPACES- WITH
REGARDS TO ASKING WHICH SEES
THAT SERVE THESE POPULATIONS
PREDOMINANTLY WE WOULD ASK THAT
YOU RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
KEEPING AUDIO ONLY HELLO
MORALITY'S ON THE SAME A
REPAYMENT RATE AS. AUDIO VISUAL
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALL PLEASE.
THANK YOU TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER TERRY MEMBERS
PROP PLANE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCIES IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM FORTY FIVE SIXTY OR ISSUE
NUMBER ONE THAT WILL ESTABLISH
THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS WILLIE
TORN CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY CLINIC
ASSOCIATION OF L. A. COUNTY ARE
PROVIDING COMMENT ON AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THE STATE WILL
HELP PROPOSAL- BE A COMMUNITY
CONVERSATION THE LAKE COUNTY IS
A VERY STRONG SUPPORTER OF
EXPANDING TELEHEALTH. INCLUDING
TELEPHONIC CARE- CLOSE THE
COVER THINKING PANDEMIC WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DIALOGUE- AND COMMENTS MADE
THIS EVENING AROUND INCLUDING
EQUITY AND EXPANDING ACCESS TO
TELEHEALTH THE SPECIFICALLY
TELEPHONE VISIT- IN ECHOING OUR
STATE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
HOPELESS ADVOCATES MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY TWO WE URGENTLY REQUIRE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE JACKIE
ADMINISTRATION TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL AND REPLACE IT WITH AB
THIRTY TWO AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY. AT
THE MANDATE IN ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE WE REQUESTED
COMMITTEE ADOPT LANGUAGE THAT
WILL UPHOLD ACCURACY HELLO HOW
FLEXIBILITIES AND PAYMENT FOR
IDEA MODALITIES AND WE REALLY
THANK THIS COMMITTEE AND ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND MAKE BOTH VIDEO AND
AUDIO FLEXIBILITY PERMANENT. AS
THAT WE'VE MADE GREAT STRIDES
TOWARD HEALTH EQUITY IN THE
STATE AND WE MUST. CONTINUE ON
THAT PATH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MAY NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING IS WORTH
VOLATILE THE NATIONALIST OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER I ALSO WANT TO COMMENT
ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORTERS OF AB THIRTY
TWO AND WE REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECTED
MINISTRATION TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL OUR SOCIAL WORKERS
HAVE FOUND THAT TELEHEALTH
PHYSICALLY AUDIO ONLY
TELEHEALTH- ADDRESSES EXISTING
HEALTH DISPARITIES- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IF
ENACTED IN ITS CURRENT FORM
LEAVE BEHIND BILLIONS OF
PATIENTS. OF BLACK INDIGENOUS
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
RECEIVING CARE I ALSO WANT TO
SUPPORT ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH
IS THE- OFFICE AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND I ALSO WANT TO
SUPPORT THE OFFICE AS HEALTH%
CARE AFFORDABILITY- WHICH TAKE
A COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE
WHOLE HEALTH OF BENCH I WOULD
HAVE THE BEST POTENTIAL TO
ENSURE THAT THE BENEFITS OF MY
FORMS ACTUALLY REACHES
CONSUMERS EMPLOYERS WORKERS.
AND TAXPAYERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I SEVEN PLEASE AHEAD.
BY ELEVEN ZERO. HELLO GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS CRISTIAN
FLORES AND I AM TWENTY FOUR
YEARS OLD I AM A FORMER BOSS
UNITED BEARING ON WHAT. I'M
CALLING REGARDING ON PART BE
UNDER GAS TAX BY FOUR POINT FOR
THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
PREVENTING AND REDUCING COST
YOU ALMOST MISSED BUDGET
PROPOSAL. WHICH WILL ADD
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
DEVELOP THE TRAINING TOPICS FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS AND PROBATION
OFFICER. AND A GENTLEMAN COOPER
REPORTER CONVENTIONAL HOUSING
FOR YEARS WHEN COUNTIES WITH
THE HIGHEST NUMBER COST BASED
PROGRAMS ARE PARTICULARLY
CRITICAL DURING. THE PANDEMIC
OF CARBON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JOE
JONATHAN I'M FROM HUMBOLDT
COUNTY AND I'M A FORMER FOSTER
YEARS I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
ORGANIZATION TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND HEALTHY FUTURES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH PROPOSAL TO
EXTEND THE INFANT SUPPLEMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS JERRY
JERRY THOUGHT REPRESENTING THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WE
AREN'T PART OF ITEM SIX THE
PROPOSAL TO CREATE THE OPPOSITE
MEDICARE INNOVATION INTEGRATION
INDIVIDUAL ALZHEIMER'S AND
DEMENTIA DEPEND ON A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS PROVIDED BY MEDICARE
MEDICAL PARTICULARLY WITH
RESPECT A LONG TERM SUPPORT
SERVICES. YET B. TWO PROGRAM SO
OFTEN PRESENT A CHALLENGING
MAIN MAYES FOR BENEFICIARY
NAVIGATE WITH THE GREAT
BENEFITS OF THE PROPOSAL WHICH
ADVANCES THE WORK OF A MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING AS WELL AS THE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM COMEDY
CONNECT WE OFFER THE- SUPPORT
FOR THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU BYE
AND CHECK ONE PLEASED AHEAD.
YES GOOD EVENING I'M LORRAINE
S. PATEL THE AIR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL INDIAN HEALTH
BOARD REPRESENTING FIFTY NINE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE DSS
OFFICE OF TRIBAL AFFAIRS FOR
THE THREE ADDITIONAL HEPA STAFF
THE CAL WORKS INDIAN HEALTH
CLINIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROGRAM. IS IN NEED OF REVISION
FOR THE MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING TO BETTER MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE THIRTY SIX
RURAL AND URBAN NATIVE AMERICAN
CLINICS STATEWIDE THIS
IMPORTANT SUPPORT FOR THE
OFFICE OF TRIBAL AFFAIRS WILL
HOPEFULLY IMPROVE THE ATTENTION
NEEDED TO IMPROVE. THE DSS
ABILITY TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THE
NEEDS OF THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE HOMEWORK INDIAN HEALTH
CLINICS AND THE SECOND ITEM I
WANTED TO BRIEFLY MENTION IS
I'M ALSO SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
TELEHEALTH REIMBURSEMENT IN
ADDITION TO ASK YOU AGENCIES
AND OUR AGENCIES TRIBAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT FQHCS
SHOULD ALSO BE INCLUDED FOR
REIMBURSEMENT. AS WE
COMMUNICATED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT YOUR
HEARING. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU THANKS
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
JORDAN FROM ABOUT FOUR O'CLOCK
SHE AT THE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF COALITION- TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT OF THE- SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
FOR THAT- DOLLARS FOR THE
HEALTHY FUTURES FOR FALL SHE
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE INFANT
OPPONENT. I THINK WITH THE
MEMBERSHIP SHOULD SHARE THAT
PRINTING YOU HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC A LACK OF ACCESS
TO MEDICAL SERVICES HOUSING
SERVICES THAT FINANCIAL RELIEF
AVAILABLE TO THE FEDERAL
STIMULUS PAYMENT- WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE- THREE SIX
SIX WHICH WILL SUPPORT
EXPECTANT AND PARENTING USED TO
MEET THE- THE NEEDS. OF OUR
PARENTING YOU AND THEIR
CHILDREN ALSO WANTING TO CALL
IN SUPPORT OF THE PREVENTING
AND REDUCING POVERTY
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL L. MAKE
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE FOR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PRODUCT-
PROGRAMS THAT WILL SUPPORT THE
HOUSING STABILITY OF CALIFORNIA
FOSSEY'S THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
VERY AT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS HILLARY THE CAL
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON BOTH THE PROPOSAL TO
RECAP AND MODERNIZE OUR POSH
AND NOT AT THE OFFICE
HEALTHCARE PORTABILITY THE
FIRST KEY CONCERN THE PM I
WOULD LIKE TO RATES REGARDING
OFSTED PROPOSAL IS THE MAKE UP
OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING COUNCIL. DESPITE THE
FACT THATTHE COUNCIL HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY AND AUTHORITY
OVER SUCH KEY CONSIDERATIONS AS
GENERAL PHYSICIAN EDUCATION
THAT THE CLIENT BY PERCY OF THE
POSITION WORKFORCE THE
PLACEMENT OF PROVIDERS IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR NEW RESIDENCY
PROGRAM. UNLIKE THE COMMISSION
IT REPLACES THERE ARE NO
DESIGNATED SEATS ON THE COUNCIL
PROFICIENT THIS LACK OF DIRECT
ENGAGEMENT WITH PROVIDERS
OVERSIGHT AND SAM I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE ALTERATIONS THE PROPOSAL.
THAT FOCUSED ON THAT ISSUE.
MUCH OF THE DATA PERMIC
STATUTES THE HOW PROGRAM ART
RUN HAVE BEEN. IN THE- LEAVING
SUCH OP. UP TO A REGULATORY
PROCESS ONLY MINIMAL
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. SAM I
WOULD RECOMMEND ADDING A
REQUIREMENT FOR AN ANNUAL
REPORT AT A MINIMUM COVERS OFF
THE ANNUAL ALLOCATIONS TO
PROGRAM MYSELF YET. IT'S WHAT
ENHANCE ACCOUNTABILITY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
FOR THE NEWLY PASSED THE
PARLIAMENT. A FINAL ISSUE THAT
I AM I WOULD LIKE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IN THE
HOSPITAL CALLED BALL IS THE
REPLACEMENT OF THE WORKFORCE
SURVEY WITH NEW QUESTIONS. WE
HAVE CONCERNS THAT PROVIDERS
MAY NOT BE COMFORTABLE
ANSWERING SOME OF THE NEWLY
ADDED QUESTIONS AND MAY CHOOSE
INSTEAD TO SIMPLY NOT RESPOND
AT ALL. LIMITING THE ACCURACY
OF CRITICAL DATA REGARDING
ACCESS AND POSITION
AVAILABILITY. FURTHER
DISCUSSION REGARDING THE NEW
SURVEY AND WHY THE EXISTING
SURVEY STRUCTURE IT'S ADEQUATE
ISN'T IT. AFTER THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY PMI
IS SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS TO
CURB COSTS WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM INCREASED
COMPETITION REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE COMPLEXITY AND
INCREASE CARE COORDINATION.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE CURRENT PROPOSAL AND
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THANK YOU
CHANGES PRIOR TO ENACTMENT. OF
THE AMENDMENT BILL AMENDMENTS
ARE BEING DISCUSSED THE CURRENT
DEFINITION OF PROVIDER IN THE
PROPOSAL IS OVERLY BROAD. WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE CHANGES THAT
NARROWED THE DEFINITION OF
PROVIDER TO ONLY FOCUS. ON THE
REAL COST DRIVERS IN THE- THAT
IS SHOW THAT HELP COSTS HELLO.
R. J. BY POLICY IN THE MY- TO
MOSCOW. COMPONENT OF WHICH ARE
THE HIGH AND MARKET I'M HOT
MARC. APPLYING ARE IN THE
PHYSICIAN PRACTICE COULD REFER
IN SMALLER. BEING GOBBLED UP BY
OTHER EXACERBATING THE
CONSOLIDATION. STUDIES SHOW
THAT ONE HOSPITAL ACQUIRED
PHYSICIAN PRACTICES COST
INCREASE. ADDITIONALLY THE
ACCOUNTABILITY LEVEL OF WHO IS
TASKED WITH MAKING HOT CROSS
TARGET DECISION MATTERS. IT'S
CRITICAL DECISION SHOULD BE
TAPPED TO A STATEWIDE ELECTED
OFFICIALS SUCH AS THE GOVERNOR
OR THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER.
EXPERIENCE TELLS US THAT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ARE OFTEN LOST WHEN THESE TYPES
OF DECISIONS ARE LEFT IN THE
HANDS. OF AN APPOINTED OFFICIAL.
YEAH MAY ALSO WANT THE
LEGISLATURE TO BUT- AT THE
PROPOSAL HE ALSO CLAIMS
DATABASE NEEDS BE UP AND
RUNNING BEFORE THE STATE SHOULD
CONSIDER SETTING CAR PARK THAT.
TO ATTEMPT PROCESS BEFORE
SUFFICIENT ACCURATE DATA IS
AVAILABLE IS A RECIPE FOR
DISASTER. FINALLY CMA WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES IN THE
POLICY PROCESS. RATHER THAN THE
BUDGET PROCESS. HEALTH
COMMITTEE CHAIR WHAT IS ALREADY
CARRYING AB ELEVEN THIRTY AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF AN OFFICE OF
HEALTHCARE PORTABILITY CAN'T
REALLY MOVE FORWARD BEFORE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ALL PAYER
CLAIMS DATABASE. THERE IS
LITTLE REASON TO RUSH THE FOR
THE BUDGET WITH LESS OVERSIGHT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. THE
MULTIPLE POLICY PROCESS AND- IN
CLOSING THEME WOULD LIKE TO LET
JUST TO CONSIDER THE BILL UP
ALL THE- BEING OFFERED AND
HEALTH SPACE. WHEN DETERMINING
OF STRATEGY FOR THE BUDGET
PROCESS. HOW THE ALL PAYER
CLAIMS. OFFICE ABOUT- AIRPORT.
THE RECAPPING POSH THAT AND NOT
EVEN CONSIDERING THE NOW
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION OF MEDIC
HOW ARE AT. WORK REPRESENTS A
GREAT DEAL OF CHANGE HARD WORK
AND LIKELY TEMPORARY OF PEOPLE
A PART OF THE- BUT WHAT. SHOULD
NOT ONLY THE BAND WITH BUT THE
HEART OF THE DEPARTMENT WHICH
SEEMS LIKE THEY WOULD BE
STRETCHED BY SO MANY SWEEPING
PROPOSAL. BUT THAT OF
PHYSICIANS AND PATIENTS
STRUGGLING TO COPE WITH SO MUCH
CHANGE IN THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
ALL AT ONCE. WHILE MOST ARE
STILL ATTEMPTING TO ATTRACT THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC. EMA
URGES A MEASURED APPROACH
CONSIDERING THE RELATIVE
CAPACITIES OF THE STATE
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS. ABOUT
THE DATING ALL THE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ANY BLOOMBERG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES HERE TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS ON MY AGENDA-PART E IT DEPARTMENT OF AGING
ISSUE NUMBERS. WE SUPPORT
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE OFFICE OF
THE PATIENT REPRESENTATIVE
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
IF THE COURT INCAPACITATED ON
REPRESENTED RESIDENTS. BUT
OPPOSE THE USE OF RESOURCES
FROM THE CDPH OF LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. CASTRO
WE BELIEVE THIS S THE STATE'S
OBLIGATION AND SHOULD BE PAID
FOR WITH GENERAL FUND. IN
ADDITION THERE IS A CRITICAL
TIMING ISSUE I WOULD LIKE TO
RAISE THE REQUIREMENTS OUTLINED
BY THE CANNER VERSUS MUST COURT
RULING SHOULD BE DELAYED A YEAR
TO JULY TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. TO ALLOW ADEQUATE
TIME FOR THE OFFICE TO BE
ESTABLISHED ALONG WITH TRAINING
AND HIRING LOCAL AGENT
REPRESENTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HEY MEMBERS AND CHAIR HE
LIKES IT WITH BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA BIKE HERE TO SUPPORT
A FEW ITEMS ON THE HEALTH
AGENDA. FIRST ITEM TO THE OFTEN
HEALTH AFFORDABILITY AS A
NONPROFIT HEALTH PLAN GUIDED BY
THE MISSION TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY HEALTHCARE. AT
AFFORDABLE PRICES. WE STRONGLY.
WITH HEALTHCARE AND WE ALSO
COMMAND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
FOR HIS AUTHORSHIP AND
LEADERSHIP ON THE COMPANION
BILL ON THE POLICY PROCESS THAT
CAN BE BUILT. ON THE LEVIN
THIRTY WE WENT OUT TO FIVE
FIFTY FOR ALL COST DRIVERS IN
THE SYSTEM NOT TO HEALTH. TO BE
ANALYZED AND REGULATED IN A
TRANSPARENT WAY TO HELP BRING
PREMIUM INCREASES. IN LINE WITH
WAGE GROWTH. THIS WE ARE AT THE
OF ISSUE NOW. INCREASED ACCESS
TO CAN TO HOLD SERVICE UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. WE APPLAUD. LET YOUR
QUESTION FOUR HUNDRED STATEWIDE
IN BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE
CAPACITY IN SCHOOL I HAD TO
OFFER MAYBE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE FROM SOME OF THOSE
THAT WERE EXPRESSED ON TODAY'S
PANEL ON THIS ITEM- WE DO
BELIEVE AND IN FACT I KNOW
FIRST HAND THAT HEALTH PLANS
CAN BE EQUIPPED TO LEAD IN THE
SPACE- ARE SUPPORT REFLECTS NOT
JUST OUR ROLE AS A MEDICAL PLAN
BUT WITH THE COMMISSION
MINISTER THE PROGRAM. BUT ALSO
OUR GLOBAL EXPERIENCE A PIONEER
IN A VERY SIMILAR PARTNERSHIPS
WITH TWENTY MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOLS ACROSS TWO COUNTIES
WHICH WE WILL DESCRIBE WHAT DO
YOU TELL IN A LETTER THAT WLL
SUBMIT SHALL WE COULD BUT
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU I NAY FOUR PLEASE CALL. THE
CREEK CARE NUMBER WILLING TO
MARIA WITH NEXT IN CALIFORNIA A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON UPLIFTING THE VOICE OF
CALIFORNIANS HOUSTON ADVOCATING
FOR AFFORDABLE ACCESSIBLE AND
EQUITABLE. HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER TWO OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY AND
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WILL BENEFIT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BY SETTING
EQUITABLE AND TRANSPARENT
TARGETS TO ADDRESS RISING COSTS
AND THE FRAGMENTATION OF OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA
HAS HAD MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS HEALTH
HEALTHCARE ACCESS QUALITY AND
COST DURING THE PANDEMIC THAT
HAS SHOWN THE IMPACTS OF
SYSTEMIC RACISM ON COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. DELAY THE CREATION OF
THIS OFFICE WILL MEAN PEOPLE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE BURDENED
WITH HEALTHCARE COSTS AMONG
OTHER BASIC. NECESSITIES PEOPLE
ARE FACING AT THIS TIME. MUCH
OF TODAY'S HEARING FOCUSED
TOPICS TO ADDRESS SYSTEMIC
RACISM WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE
MARKET. AND SYSTEM WE HOPE THIS
ISN'T THE ONLY STATE INVESTMENT
TO ADDRESS THE ADDRESS EQUITY
AS WE ALL KNOW RACISM TOUCHES
ON ALL. ALL OTHER ISSUES LIKE
HOUSING CLIMB IN TRANSPORTATION
AMONG OTHERS THAT ARE
SYSTEMATICALLY TIED TO A
PERSON'S HEALTH OUTCOME. NEXT
IN CALIFORNIA IS SPONSORING SB
SEVENTEEN WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
AN OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY TO
HELP GUIDE THE STATE TO ADDRESS
SYSTEMIC. EQUITY ACROSS ALL
FACETS THE GOVERNMENT NOT JUST
IN HEALTH CARE LIKE MANY OF THE
HEALTHCARE INVESTMENT EQUITY
INVESTMENTS TALKED ABOUT TODAY
TO ADDRESS EQUITY WE HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE WILL PRIORITIZE
MAKING MEANINGFUL INVESTMENTS
TO ADDRESS EQUITY AT A HOLISTIC
LEVEL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU BYE EIGHTY ONE SHE'S GLAD.
IF YOU PAY EIGHTY ONE IT BROKE
UP WHEN YOU SAID THAT AND I'M
CONCERNED WITH THE MUSEUM AB
ONE FLIGHT EIGHTY ONE OF. MY
LOOK OKAY GOOD EVENING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME AT THE
MONTERREY COOLEY I'M HERE WITH
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES ARE YOU
CALLING ABOUT SECTION BE UNDER
THE AT THAT TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR TWO ITEMS NOT ON THE
AGENDA. THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS PREVENTING AND
REDUCING PROCTOR YOU PUBLIC
PROPOSAL AND A SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND HEALTHY
FUTURES FOR FOSTER YOUTH
PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE AT THE
MOMENT. REGARDING THE
PREVENTING REDUCING POVERTY AT
HOME WITH THIS PROPOSAL WE
ADMINISTER THURSDAY IN MARCH TO
UNDERSTAND THE CUMULATIVE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC ON
CURRENT FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
MORE THAN ONE IN FIVE YOUTH
REPORTED EXPERIENCING PUBLIC
THAT THE START OF THE PANDEMIC
THE PROPOSAL WOULD ADD HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE BUT
WITH THE TRAINING TOPIC FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS AND PROBATION
OFFICER AND IF THAT WAS FUNDING
FOR COUNTIES WITH THE HIGHEST
HOUSING COSTS THE DOCUMENT THE
FUNDING FOR THE- PROGRAM. WHICH
PROVIDES TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OF
IT THE PORTABLE HOUSING AND
SUPPORT SERVICES THE FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH UP TO AGE TWENTY
FOUR ELEVEN COUNTIES WITH THE
HIGHEST HOUSING COSTS IN THE
STATE HAVE EXPERIENCED A ONE
HUNDRED AND 17% INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON THE WAITING
LIST FOR THE PROGRAM. JUST
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY COMPARED
230% FOR THE LOWER COST COUNTY
SO IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS
REGIONAL INEQUITIES- DURING
COLLISION OF THIS INVESTMENT IN
OUR STATE AFTER YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I AT PLEASE
CALL AHEAD. GOOD EVENING. IS
ELIZABETH COULD AND I'M A
FORMER AUSTRALIA FROM THE
JERICHO. AND I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS FOR SEVEN AND TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND OKAY IF YOU
CHANGE WITHOUT YOU PROPOSAL TO
EXTEND THE IN PRINCIPLE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU FIND
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING KAREN MEMBERS IT'S A
FAIR HUCKLE REPRESENTING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA A
DIFFICULT ITEM NUMBER TO THE
OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY. MICROLINER
COMMENTS BUT THOSE THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS. AND ALSO
CAN BE SURE THAT ANY DISCUSSION
OF AFFORDABILITY TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT MAINTAINING PATIENT
ACCESS TO INNOVATIVE TREATMENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RANGE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBER SERVERS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
COMMENTED ON TWO ITEMS COVERED
BY THE COMMITTEE TODAY IN
REGARD TO THE OFFICE OF
AFFORDABILITY WHILE WE BELIEVE
THE GOAL OF THE OFFICE IS
COMMENDABLE WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
OF THE SCOPE OF THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE AND ART WHAT ABOUT
THAT MOMENT POSED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. IN REGARDS TO THE
TELE HEALTH MEDICAL PROPOSAL WE
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL IN
CURRENT FORM. THAT ENCOURAGE SB
THIRTY TO BE ADOPTED AND IT
PLEASE TELL HEALTH PHYSICALLY
AUDIO ONLY FORMS AND OTHER
FORMS OF ASYNCHRONOUS CARE ARE
ESSENTIAL TO ADDRESSING
EXISTING HEALTH DISPARITIES YOU
CAN READ OUR REVIEWS DECREASE
BARRIERS AND INCREASE ACCESS TO
CARE FOR PATIENTS ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN RURAL AND UNDERSERVED
AREAS OF THE STATE. LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND COMMITTEE ON
THESE ISSUES MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TONIGHT. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY
SEVEN NINE GOING. HI GOOD
EVENING MANY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ALEXIS A FORMER BOSS TWO YEARS
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
COLLECTION OF MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS. MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLAR
HEALTHY FUTURES FOR FOX STREET
PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE IMPACT
UPON THAT I WANT TO ECHO THE
STRONG NEED FOR THIS AND THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS SUE
EVAN SOMEONE FAMILY SERVICES
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR AND
MAKING SPEAKING THIS EVENING I
AM HEAD TO AND STATE MY SUPPORT
FOR- SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT ON
THE AGENDA ON THAT POTS BEYOND
THE DFS AND THAT IS A STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION PREVENTIVE REDUCING
THE YOU'VE HEARD THE- PROPOSAL.
THIS WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
FUNDING THAT IS DESIGNATED AS A
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROVIDER
WE ARE STRUGGLING TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT HOUSING HAVE WAITING
LISTS AND WE KNOW THAT THE
SPELL ON THIS MONEY WILL HELP
ENORMOUSLY SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION
ESPECIALLY IN THE HIGH AREAS
TRANSACTION LA COUNTY IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. SO WITH THE
INTENT TO MUCH SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND- THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK I NINE ONE PLEASE
CALL AHEAD. HI THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBER- OF THE BUT SUB- MY
NAME FIFTEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
SAKHALIN CARL I'M CALLING
REGARDING THE ITEM FIVE ONE
HELLO HOW ARE WE MUST ENSURE
THAT THE BUDGET BOTH IS THE
HEALTH OF ALL CALIFORNIANS- AND
THE NETWORK OF MEDIC CAL
PROVIDERS IS CRITICAL THAT THEY
ARE WELL POSITIONED TO MEET THE
HEALTHCARE DEMAND FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARY. AND ARE ABLE TO
CLOSE- DISPARITIES IN GAS WE
REQUEST THAT IT COMMITTEE
ADOPTED LANGUAGE THAT WILL
UPHOLD TECH TELL HELP BUT
PEOPLE NEED AND PAYMENT FOR ALL
AUDIO ONLY MODALITIES PROVIDERS
MUST BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
CURRENT TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITY
THAN PAYMENT FOR BOTH VIDEO AND
AUDIO TELEHEALTH. WE ARE DOING
REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE ADMINISTRATION
TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL AND REPLACE
IT WITH SB THIRTY TWO WHICH THE
COMMISSION IS THAT YOUNG THE
COURT ON AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I
NINETY THREE PUT GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS AGENCIES THE MAP ON
TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD I'M A
STUDENT AND I WORK FULL TIME
AND I'M ALSO A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH I'M CALLING REGARDING
PART B. UNDER DSS TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION TO PREVENTING OR
REDUCING FOSTER YOU COMMON FOR
BOTH OF. WHICH ARE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS TO ALYSSA TRAINING
TOPICS FOR SOCIAL WORKERS
INFORMATION AUTHORED AND A
TECHNICAL ACT THAT THE SUPPORT
OF TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FOR
YOU. AND COUNTIES WITH THE
HIGHEST RENTAL CAR. WHICH IS L.
A. COUNTY SAN DIEGO SACRAMENTO
SAN FRANCISCO THESE PROGRAMS
ARE PARTISAN WITH CRITICAL
DURING THE PENNANT. ENDEMIC.
RECOVERY PERIOD THANK YOU. OKAY
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU BYE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BORN BAD
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS. I'M
COMMENTING ON AGENDA- ITEM D.
ITEM FIVE TELEHEALTH AND
URGENTLY REQUESTING THAT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION REFLECT
THE CURRENT PRIORITIES AB
THIRTY TWO THIS INCLUDES
CONTINUING PAYMENT PARITY FOR
BOTH AUDIO AND VIDEO VISITS
REIMBURSING MEDIGAP PROVIDERS
FOR VIDEO VISITS AND CONTINUING
BURKE ONE MOMENT. AT THE CIVIC
PROGRAMS MEET HEALTHCARE
DEMANDS IN THE MEDICARE
BENEFICIARY AND THE LIMIT
DISPARITIES THANK YOU HAVE A
GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RIGHT NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
JANE SCHROEDER ON BEHALF OF
FIRST THANK YOU FOR CALLING-
IT'S FOR SOMETHING THAT WASN'T
ON TODAY'S AGENDA BUT IT'S PART
BEYOND YOUR DS BASS I'M CALLING
TO EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR PREVENTING AND REDUCING
FOSTER YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL. FOR PROVIDE H. B.
CLASS IN SIX COUNTIES OFFERING
FREE HOUSING SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT
SUPPORT FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
AND WE'RE EXPERIENCING THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT OF RISING
RENTAL COSTS AND MAKING IT- IF
POSSIBLE PLEASE FIFTEEN THE
PROGRAM AND ESPECIALLY TO
EXPAND TO MEET THE GROWING
NEEDS AND THAT BLOOD TO. START
ROCKETING WAIT WHAT- WELL ONE
HUNDRED AND 17% INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF NEW ON THE WAIT LIST
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
AND TWO THOUSAND TWENTY AND THE
HIGHEST **** COUNTY. THE
PROPOSAL WOULD ESTABLISH
FUNDING TO HELP MEET THAT NEED
AND SO WE'D BE REALLY EXPRESS
THEIR STRONG SUPPORTER.
ENCOURAGER I THOUGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALL
PLEASE. THANK YOU I NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU THIS TIME.
HARPER DO YOU- QUEUING UP ONE
MORE TIME AND SEEING IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER CALLERS. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WITH THAT I WILL TAKE
THAT AS THE CONCLUSION OF
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THAT IS THE
END OF OUR HEARING TODAY. WE
ARE NOW DROWNED THANK YOU
EVERYBODY.